please good sir I beseech you as a man
of science nay as a man of reason you
mustn't stifle my research at this
critical juncture you have no idea how
close I am to finding a cure for this
blasted pestilence I need only a handful
of Life subjects to complete my research
the black doctors emphatic please fell
on deaf ears as a stone-faced researcher
took notes on his latest pontifications
the doctor whom these clods had reduced
so rudely to a mere number as cp049
banged his gloved fist up against the
wall and to think he once thought of
these men as intellectual equals fellow
Travelers on the road to Scientific
Enlightenment what a positively sick
joke before the doctor got another
chance to appeal for his right to
experiment the researcher left him alone
once more a truly sad state of trainers
nobody appreciated a true scientist in
this day and age it was sure to be
another day of languishing alone in this
cell wishing he had the capacity to do
more so he was surprised as anyone when
the alarm started going off and the door
of his cell swung open automatically the
plague doctor stepped out of his cell
and into the Hall where many other
humanoid anomalies were roaming confused
as to why they'd been suddenly released
what was happening as it turned out what
was happening was one of the most brutal
chaos Insurgency raids the staff of site
19 had ever seen it had been planned
immaculately you see guards rotate
semi-regularly at site 19 due to the
high pressure nature of the job lots of
deaths and mental breakdowns as you
probably correctly predicted even the
administrative staff of the SCP
Foundation are only human well mostly
anyway so they're not immune to little
oversights here and there and it's in
those oversights that expertly trained
chaos Insurgency infiltration agents
make their living no less than 15 of
them had been working undercover in site
19 for just over two weeks and they did
a fine job of lowering the metaphorical
drawbridge for a heavily armed Invasion
Force the guards who weren't plants were
quickly murdered by the infiltrators and
even some of the on-site task forces
were quickly overwhelmed and gunned down
by the high Precision rifles of the
chaos insurgency's finest while the
front liners were distracted by the
sudden assault the infiltrators found
their way to the site security control
room and massacred everyone inside
opening every single door in the site
was as simple as putting in a few stolen
key codes and flipping a few carefully
remembered switches consequently while
Foundation agents and cast Insurgency
mercenaries Clash Sabers high priority
anomalies like scp-049 simply wandered
the facility watching the Calamity
unfold within the foundation was beset
on all sides shot at by heavily armed
maniacs and attacked from within by the
numerous roaming anomalous entities that
were eager to get their hands on
Foundation Personnel definitely not an
ideal situation to say the least the
plague doctor only had one thing on his
mind though hmm these definitely want to
do my research any good unless I can
escape and find my way to a suitable
laboratory oh now there is an idea but
his scientific fantasies were soon
interrupted by a chaos Insurgency
Soldier swinging the butt of his M4
carbine into his avian exoskull with a
supremely unpleasant crack the doctor
was Dazed by it momentarily the pain
coming at him like a Thunderclap but the
Insurgent never got the chance to take
another swing before the Insurgent could
do anything the plague doctor lunged out
with practice speed grasping him by the
throat immediately everything went black
and the insurgents limp corpse collapsed
to the ground serves him right the
doctor internally amused soldiers
attacking Medics is violating even the
most basic rules of gentlemanly warfare
then another flash of immense pain has a
different rifle but collided with the
back of his head the doctor fell to one
knee feeling dizzy but before he could
retaliate he felt the two sharp prongs
of a cattle prod pressing up against his
neck the Sudden Rush of electricity
surged through his neck sending his
muscles into a wave of involuntary
spasms the insurgents crowding around
him chimed in with their own agonizing
cattle prods relentlessly shocking him
until the flashes of white hot pain soon
became an impressive blanket of total
dark even on his most cantankerous days
the SCP Foundation had never treated him
like this when he eventually came to he
was still in darkness standing upright
with high-tech shackles holding every
limb in place it was beyond
uncomfortable for the poor plague doctor
but it succeeded in the task of keeping
him under control he couldn't move an
inch there were muffled voices beyond
the dark beyond the confines of this new
containment the modulated gas mask
voices of insurgents and something else
faintly accented oddly familiar but he
couldn't quite place it soon the voices
were replaced by another sound the
grinding of crowbars Levering Nails out
of cheap wood with a creaking tumble a
rectangle of bright light opened up in
front of him populated by a number of
silhouettes on either side were chaos
insurgents in familiar tactical Garb and
in between them stood a tall
well-groomed man with an expensive
looking purple smoking jacket and a
pencil mustache for a few fractions of a
second his face was a portrait of
excitement but as he took in the side of
the plague doctor standing before him
all the joy drained from his snooty
continents what the hell am I looking at
here the man in the smoking jacket said
the doctor indignant adds such a
response from the man who'd presumably
ordered his assault rasped a man of
science could sir the man in the smoking
jacket ignored him and continued to
berate the chaos insurgents with an odd
level of confidence for someone
reprimanding trained cold-blooded
Killers I wanted scp-650 the startling
statue not this clownish Ren Fair
cosplayer what the hell did I pay you
Ruffians for I was told you chaos
insurgents were the very best at this
and for your empty price I expect
Excellence the rent continued much like
this leaving everyone in attendance the
insurgents the plague doctor feeling
thoroughly exhausted by him and unable
to do anything about it you see this
wasn't just any chaos Insurgency client
your average tin pot dictator or arms
dealer you know the time this was the
one and only Pascal legat one of the
most famous or rather Infamous anarch
collectors in the game he'd been a
founding Person of Interest for years
due to his dealings with the chaos
Insurgency and Marshall Carter and dark
limited all to the end of expanding his
anarch collection but his vast wealth
and connections had always shielded him
from Foundation probes for those
unfamiliar with the subculture sure and
art short for anomalous art is exactly
what it sounds like artistic projects
with anomalous properties to give it
that extra kick one of the most popular
groups of Interest dealing in an art is
the iconic are we cool yet which
incidentally had recently excommunicated
Pascal Legette for being an exceedingly
wealthy uptight Square who really didn't
represent the collective's rebellious
ethos and considering his response was
to pay the chaos Insurgency to raid site
19 for a few pieces for his own private
collection costing him millions of
dollars in both groups many lives it was
safe to say he wasn't taking it well
look we got you that other Statue and
that thing killed four of our best guys
so how about we just call it even said
one of the insurgents I'm sure you can
have fun with bird brain here too Pascal
flooded and reluctantly dismissed the
higher guns having the plague doctor
here definitely wasn't ideal especially
considering he wanted to host the
ultimate an art exhibition to put are we
cool yet worthless
Magnifique to shame but he would make do
with what he had perhaps he could say
that 049 was a commentary on the
ever-present nature of disease in
Mankind's life and our forever archaic
approach to it yes yes that would do
nicely needless to say the plague doctor
was infuriated by all this the violence
against his person the kidnapping the
disrespect and most of all the
interruption to his precious research
especially considering how close he'd
gotten to finding a cure for the
pestilence but instead he was soon
spirited by a legion of heavily armed
goons from his wooden box to a glass one
in one of legette's many opulent
hallways there were other glass cases on
either side of him and more on the other
side of the hall all two reinforced for
the plague doctor to even smash through
it on his own damn it legette's own
private anarch exhibition probably
wedged between his oversized dining room
and his jewel encrusted crapper
occasionally Pascal himself would jaunt
down the hallway to gaze upon his new
stolen anarch pieces and of course the
plague doctor would try his best to
reason with him I am a patient man
this is simply barbaric by what right do
you imprison me here is your intention
to deprive the world the entire human
race of my valuable medical
breakthroughs could you live with that
on your conscience good sir there was
never any meaningful response the plague
doctors soon learned that Pascal Legette
didn't like his art interactive it was
simply meant to languish away in a glass
box being watched being passively looked
at those chaos Insurgency louds hadn't
even bothered to bring his notebook or
medical bag so he was without the tools
to even perform his experiments as loath
as he was to admit it this was even
worse than being mocked up by the SCP
Foundation but all this wasn't entirely
unfamiliar there was something in the
glass box across from the plague doctor
that he vaguely recognized back from
site 19. he'd never seen it up close but
he had heard researchers speaking about
it and even seeing a few pictures and
such a strange construction it was a
peculiar haphazard sculpture made from
concrete rebar and spray paint quite
ugly in this humble doctor's opinion but
there was something oddly entrancing
about it and for reasons beyond the
doctor's recollection four of legette's
men stood around the glass box in where
it was being stored always watching the
man were frequently switched in and out
as though they were watching in shifts
always fixing their Gaze on its peculiar
malformed body maybe it was all the
electrical shocks and knocks to the head
but he just couldn't remember why Pascal
was having the piece so carefully
observed but he knew on some Primal
level that the secret to this would
perhaps be the key to his own Escape if
only he could remember still time passed
Pascal drifted in and out sometimes with
guests the plague doctor had learned not
to speak these animals could not be
reasoned with as a scientist he would
instead carefully observe until his
observations bore fruit he noticed that
Pascal's guests all people who looked
equally as wealthy and pompous as Pascal
himself all seemed to look right over
him and instead focus on the ugly statue
across the hall still forever observed
by any four of Pascal's men some of them
looked actively nervous just being in
its presence curious the plague doctor
made a mental note of this just as he
did when Pascal gave his guests a
reassuring pat on the shoulder and told
them please calm yourself it's harmless
while my Personnel are keeping an eye on
it little by little the plague doctor's
memories of his Infamous neighbor had
begun to return he knew what he must do
to escape now all he needed to do was
wait for the perfect moment soon enough
Pascal's mention was filled with a bevy
of anarch snobs from hither and yarn a
private Soiree to show off his new
collection they wander the halls in
three-piece Tuxedos and designer
ballroom dresses sipping champagne from
imported Crystal all such lovely refined
High Society people and if the good
doctor's plan went off as he intended
they would all be such lovely refined
High Society corpses the plague doctor
waited until mercifully he and the four
members of personnel watching the
sculpture were the only ones left in the
hallway he'd been so good so patient
that none of the men guarding the
sculpture at present had ever heard him
make a noise he was so invisible to them
that in all likelihood they probably
didn't even notice he could make a sound
and Matt worked for his purposes just
fine though in any case if he wanted
this to work he would need to time his
plan perfectly even a fraction of a
second out of place and the whole thing
would have dire consequences still the
doctor was still a Frenchman at heart
and as a Frenchman he knew he would
rather die nobly in the process of
Escape than remain capped assured by
this worthless buffoon he'd be sure to
take as many of these men down with him
in the process as he was able the plague
doctor exhaled deeply drawing a lung
full of air then bellowed as loud as he
possibly could the sudden unexpected
noise was so shocking that it jogged the
four Watchers almost reflexively to turn
and look at him and in the split second
that they did the plague doctor closed
his eyes in the dark times seemed to
move slower perhaps due to the doctor's
Keen Focus cultivated over many a
century he listened carefully to the
sequence of sounds glass shattering four
choked gasps in sequence four brutal
crunches then nanoseconds later more
glass shattering the plague doctor's
eyes snapped open just in time just as
predicted the sculpture being entirely
unobserved had smashed through its glass
case murdering all four members of
personnel by snapping their necks and
then smashed through his own glass case
to do the same to him the play leg
doctor had cut it so close in fact that
he opened his eyes to the face of the
sculpture staring into his own its
concrete limbs wrapped around his neck
very good timing indeed with a sigh of
relief the plague doctor slipped out of
the sculpture's concrete grasp and
backed down the hallway keeping his gaze
fixed stunned the sculpture the entire
time he had heard it decimate Pascal's
men he certainly didn't fancy undergoing
the same fate the second the plague
doctor backed around the corner
rendering the sculpture or as the SCP
Foundation called it SCP-173 out of
sight he could hear terrified screaming
coming from the other end of the hall he
was not a sadistic man but the plague
doctor would be lying if he told you he
didn't take just a little bit of
pleasure in hearing that sound somewhere
else in the vast Mansion of Pascal leget
the sculpture was slaughtering its way
through servants and party guests while
the plague doctor searched for some kind
of exit anyone who dared getting in his
way was given a Swift and merciless
Touch of death sending their body
unceremoniously to the ground anyone in
his way was preventing him from finding
a cure for the pestilence and thus
endangering countless lives it was of
course regrettable to have to kill
anyone but some sacrifices must be made
for the greater good of mankind well
it's not necessarily always regrettable
per se on his way out while the
murderous Rampage of SCP-173 seemed to
distract anyone of note the plague
doctor just so happened to encounter a
fleeing Pascal Legette hoping to find
some kind of Escape himself it seemed
that now fate was on his side once more
to have his Jailer right here in the
palm of his hand would be such a perfect
Parting Gift funnily enough Pascal was
far more talkative to him now he rattled
off a rapid-fire series of threats
bribes and pleas claiming in the end
that he never meant any harm he was the
one who freed the plague doctor from the
SCP Foundation they were on the same
side here all this was for the art no
offense was ever intended Pascal Legette
simply lived for art then die for it
good sir the plague doctor said and with
a single touch Pascal's eyes rolled up
into the back of his head and he fell to
the ground dead it was one of the few
non-scientific deaths that he felt truly
no guilt for after some time searching
the screams around the rest of the
Mansion eventually went silent that did
wonders for his focus it didn't take
long for the plague doctor to locate an
exit a fine mahogany door with elaborate
adornments befitting a man as gaudia's
Pascal and began strolling towards it
his chest swollen with pride and a sense
of accomplishment then he blinked and a
few feet in front of him stood the
sculpture it was there so suddenly that
the plague doctor fell backwards in
shock but he devoted everything to
keeping an eye on that monstrosity with
everyone else in the Mansion presumably
dead at this point it had now come back
for him it stood there staring silently
red ready to exact the terrible price
for freeing it as soon as the doctor
dared to Blink the plague doctor began
crawling backwards down the hall just
wanting to put some distance between
himself and the sculpture as the seconds
passed he could feel his eyes drying out
until the inevitable blink the sculpture
was standing right in front of him now
gazing down almost mocking it had closed
the distance so quickly if the plague
doctor blinked again he was sure that
his eyes would never open again all it
had to do was wait as the seconds passed
and the doctor began to feel his eyes
drying up again that subtle sting
quickly grew into a nagging pain that
could not be denied sooner or later he
was going to have to bang the front door
flew open and in an instant the hallway
was filled with heavily armed troops all
wearing the familiar black and gray of
the SCP Foundation the plague doctor had
never been so relieved to see the
organization that had kept him locked up
for so many decades for once they'd
saved him from something even worse of
course the sculpture didn't say anything
but the disappointment of losing that
one more victim seemed to radiate off of
it like a lingering bad smell the plague
doctor willingly gave himself up and
heavy machinery was brought in to pick
up SCP-173 with the help of the iPods to
make sure it didn't try any funny
business in transit Pascal had gotten
away with his Shady dealings for years
but the Brazen attack he funded against
site-19 was now enough for the
foundation to track him down when his
corpse was found in the halls of his own
home with no obvious cause of death we
can happily tell you that nobody was
disappointed by the evening the plague
doctor was happy to be back in his cell
his research could continue here and in
time he knew that the Personnel of the
SCP Foundation would listen to reason
and comply with his demands after all
science Marches On regardless of who
chooses to march with it but he would
forever feel a little nervous in Psych
19 after that knowing the concrete
monster he was sharing the a building
with he hoped that if ever there was
another Containment Breach involving
that thing that it didn't feel like
paying him a visit for old time's sake
it's the late 90s and an Air Canada
flight experiences severe malfunctions
while traveling from London to Vancouver
the pilots are unable to do anything and
the plane crashes into the woods of
Northern Alberta the crash was
devastating only 10 of the nearly 300
people on board are alive and even
though they survived the initial
disaster their battle for life has only
just begun it's late autumn in Northern
Canada and there's no telling when help
will arrive if at all if the survivors
want to make it through the night they
need to find shelter and fast as they
trudge through the freezing Woods the
group finds a path that looks like it
might lead them to civilization after
all if there was a path in the woods
that meant they were probably in a
national park and if they were in a
national park there had to be a ranger
station around somewhere where they
could warm up and call for help they
didn't have many other options so they
followed the path which opened up to a
clearing but instead of finding a ranger
station or Campground they found
something none of them could have
expected it was a pawn but there was
something off about it as they got
closer they saw that this strange Pond
wasn't filled with water but blood the
survivors were horrified that couldn't
really be blood could it it must have
been a weird algae or chemical reaction
but one member of the group a man named
Thomas Dean who had been on his way back
to his hometown of Prince George British
Columbia thought there was something
strangely familiar about this he
remembered being a boy and going to
visit family in Alberta and hearing an
urban legend from the older local kids
according to the stories somewhere out
in the wilderness in the northern part
of the province there was a pond full of
human blood and what made it even worse
was that some said the pond was a
gateway to Hell the SCP Foundation was
also aware of the Legend and had been
trying to pinpoint the exact source of
it for decades prior to the Air Canada
crash they would finally receive
definite confirmation of the blood Pond
when Foundation Personnel intercepted a
radio transmission from a ranger station
located within the Wood Buffalo national
park it was the survivors of the crash
who had managed to make it through the
night and they were about to be escorted
out of the park by Rangers the
foundation mobilized quickly to cordon
off the pond as at the time they were
unsure of what potentially harmful
properties the pond might have had they
set up watch station Epsilon 38 and put
staff on guard to deter travelers from
the area the pond was given the
designation of scp-354 and classed as
Euclid Foundation scientists made a
number of interesting discoveries about
scp-354 when they collected samples for
testing first the pond was not in fact
full of blood merely an inorganic liquid
that closely resembles blood in color
and consistency second and even Stranger
Than The Red liquid is that the Pawn
doesn't seem to have any definite Banks
or a bottom instead the liquid in the
pond increases in density as the radius
away from the center increases the
liquid congeals at the edges becoming
more solid and blending into the
surrounding soil it also becomes thicker
as one descends deeper into the pool and
the bottom of the pond has not yet been
reached if it even exists initially the
foundation found no signs of life within
the blood Pond but that would all change
at 203 pm on the day following the
opening of Watch Station Epsilon 38 when
the science team noticed an unusual
level of activity on the Pond's surface
security footage feed showed a shape
rising out of the pond followed by a
deafening shriek after that the feed was
cut and Foundation lost all
communication with watch station Epsilon
38 fearing the worst a mobile task force
was dispatched to the location when they
got there all Personnel at the watch
station had been killed by what could
only be described as a gigantic bat the
task force was able to neutralize the
end
and as soon as they could the foundation
moved in to increase security around the
SCP creating area 354 and installing a
permanent security detail after this
point the pond started to regularly spit
out a variety of monstrous entities
almost as if it was reacting to the SCP
foundation's increased security measures
after
scp-354-1 the giant bat came
scp-354-2
354-2 was an echidna-like monster the
size of a pair that was virtually
bulletproof but unable to escape area
354 the foundation neutralized this
anomaly with Napalm
scp-354-3 was a floating black sphere
capable of firing deadly beams of
concentrated energy the area's head
scientists was able to hit it with a
sledgehammer causing the sphere to
malfunction and self-destruct before it
was able to escape the area the
foundation wasn't as lucky with
scp-354-4 this creature was a reptilian
humanoid that stood roughly 15 feet tall
and was unable to be put down with
gunfire this was the first Creature from
the pond to successfully Escape
containment and was only able to be
neutralized when the foundation sent in
Mobile task force omega-7 also known as
Pandora's Box the data on Pond
incursions is partially corrupted so a
complete list of creatures is not
available but some of the other monsters
that came out of the blood Pond include
a killer robot a set of gigantic
tentacles that drag several d-class
Personnel into the pond a pair of
panther-like creatures one made of ice
and the other of magma that ignored
Foundation staff and instead fought each
other and one seemingly normal human man
who was executed as soon as he emerged
from the pond tests on his body revealed
that he was in fact totally normal and
would have posed no threat these
anomalies came out of the pond at fairly
regular intervals for several months
before the pond went silent for an
unprecedented 22 months the head
scientists at the time noted I suspect
this means one of two things either the
red pool has died or power down or
whatever the correct term for it is or
is charging up for something big to come
through o5 believes the former is the
most likely explanation and has recalled
30 of our total personnel and cut 25 of
our funding while I can only hope that
they are correct if the latter situation
is true we're soon to face some terrible
monstrosity and we won't have anywhere
near the force necessary to deal with it
I worry for all of our safety his words
would prove eerily prophetic following
the events of exploratory Mission 354
Alpha the foundation's research and
development team built a specialized
craft to explore the pond because of the
strange properties of the Pond's density
the craft was essentially made to be
both a submarine for parts of the pond
where the contents were liquid and a
drill for when the liquid congealed into
a semi-solid towards the bottom the
exploration team consisted of agent
Swanson agent turquoise agent 86 Dr J
McArthur Chris Simmons Leroy Tucker and
a pilot named Mark with the team
assembled the ship was sent down into
the pond nothing eventful happened for
the first two days of the mission but at
4 30 a.m on the third day gravity
suddenly reversed for the crew of the
ship this seemed to indicate that they
were approaching the halfway point
though what would be on the other side
nobody could say on the fourth day the
ship surfaced proving definitely that
the pond was in fact some sort of portal
the crew looked out of the portholes to
see the darkness of night above them
while sensors outside the ship detected
nothing harmful in the atmosphere around
them the crew were wary of exiting the
craft the other side of the pond was
nothing like the world the crew knew for
one thing the night lasted for 28 hours
before Don came and when the Sun finally
Rose it was much larger and redder than
the Earth's sun under the light of the
strange red star the crew could see that
the pond on this side was massive
compared to what they've come into more
like a large Lane surrounding the lake
was sand and rocks that were covered in
a kind of moss that disappeared under
sunlight and grew during the night the
team left the ship and started to
explore during their time in This
Strange World they found that the day
lasted just a few hours shorter than the
night meaning that whatever Planet they
were on had a roughly 43 hour long
rotation as opposed to our own planets
24. the team found a number of anomalous
elements on their expedition including
razor-sharp grass that can puncture skin
in streams of liquid carbon dioxide they
heard some loud Roars in the distance
once or twice but other than that the
planet was eerily silent with seemingly
no animal life and not even wind when it
rained the soil remained dry and based
on that the scientists theorized the
plants in this world were more efficient
at absorbing moisture on the 25th day
the team ran into a huge metal wall that
appeared to be artificially constructed
luckily Leroy Tucker a quick thinking
researcher was able to rig a blowtorch
from camping supplies and melt a hole
through the metal on the other side
there was finally wind and odd black
grass that's the extent sense of what is
known about the other side of the wall
because the Expedition logs are heavily
corrupted after that point but we know
that whatever was in there wasn't good
because the team never returned
strangely there's no record of any names
mentioned in the ship's log almost as if
being killed on the other side
completely erased them from history no
other Expeditions into the pond were
launched after that on an undisclosed
day a year following the discovery of
the blood Pond and construction of area
354. the site was completely evacuated
and power was cut to the area mobile
task force data 12 was dispatched to
investigate the cause of the evacuation
but before contact could be established
the area's on-site nuclear warhead was
detonated completely destroying the site
MTF data 12 was then attacked by a
convoy made up of d-class and other
low-ranking staff who had evacuated area
354. it was apparent that there had been
some kind of mutiny within the site and
that a dissolution of the chain of
command had led to its evacuation and
destruction the Convoy totally
annihilated the MTF data 12 and no
further contact with the former
Personnel of area 354 has been made
since following the site's detonation a
new site was constructed called simply
the red pool containment site unlike the
previous facility which focused on
research and neutralization the new site
is entirely concerned with containment
the shift and directive came as a
response to the Pond's apparent reactive
nature each creature that emerged from
the pond seemed to be in retaliation to
the foundation's actions and it was
theorized by some that the Mutiny at
area 354 was triggered by some kind of
psychic attack from the pond itself an
interview in the SCP file on 354 reveals
that there was one more disastrous
attempt to control and understand the
blood Pond according to an interview
with a foundation agent the head doctor
proposed a scheme to drain the blood
Pond using a system of pumps and hoses
all non-essential Personnel were
evacuated in case of emergency leaving
only the pump technicians d-class
personnel and a few agents for security
however as soon as the pump was
scheduled to be turned on everyone at
the site experienced a mass dissociative
episode the agent described the feeling
they all experienced as like being in a
dream and suddenly realizing that you're
asleep he said everything stopped being
real it was like we had to Escape right
now when asked what happened when the
pump was turned on he simply explained
that it wouldn't let them this interview
confirmed the theory that the pond is
not only capable of releasing monsters
out into our world but also that it's
capable of powerful but much more subtle
psychological attacks this suggests a
chilling possibility that the pond isn't
just blindly reacting to being attacked
but it's fully sentient and the actions
of the SCP Foundation have only served
to annoy it and worst studies of the
ponds banks have proved evidence that
the area of congealed liquid around the
perimeter of the pond has been steadily
expanding that's right the pond is
getting bigger the last thing the
foundation agent stationed at the site
I'd said before being dragged out of the
interview and sedated was it gets bigger
and stronger every day and now we've
made it Angry a veteran worker of the
SCP Foundation sits at his terminal
performing one of the most critical
tasks in the entire organization
creating a file for an as yet
undescribed SCP but there's something
terribly wrong his eyes are glazed over
his mouth hangs open is this a zombie or
a trained Foundation researcher
what is going on like any large
International Organization it takes more
than just the exciting action-filled
jobs to keep the wheels turning at the
SCP Foundation sure the head researchers
guards mobile task force soldiers and
members of the o5 command get all the
praise but a legion of number crunchers
cleaners and paper pushers are equally
important one such person was archivist
Walter Bainbridge who had been tasked
with digitizing some of the older
records that the foundation had on file
it was when he was innocently recording
the details on
scp-050-060 that he first came under the
strange and startling effects of
scp-055 but the most peculiar part as
with all incidents of
scp-055's anomalous effects taking hold
is that Walter had no idea any of it was
happening in his new digitized filing
system he first took note of scp-053
Euclid class also known as the young
girl this anomaly was a seemingly normal
human female child who provoked
homicidal Insanity in those directly
exposed to her then scp-054 safe class
a non-aggressive humanoid female made
entirely of as well as biologically and
chemically identical to regular Spring
Water next
scp-056 Euclid Class A being that
changes form to suit its environment but
only when all observers lose focus of it
and then
scp-057 safe class an underground
chamber that crushes the humans who walk
Within it was at this point that Walter
received a concerned message from one of
his superiors at site 19 Mr Kovach the
message praised the thorough
digitization of the other anomalies
records but was confused about why
Walter had left out any mention of
scp-055 immediately Walter was
embarrassed how could he have forgotten
as cp055 that iconic anomaly known for
well he couldn't quite say off the top
of his head but he'd be sure to look
into it a quick trip to the site-19
archive showed him that there was
actually quite a hefty file on the
nature of
scp-055 which must have been the result
of a huge number of studies what struck
him as strange was that all the files
were filled out in pen rather than being
typed up like a traditional file the
majority of these notes were written in
shorthand too as though they were
frantically taken during the tests
themselves on extremely short notice
there weren't even any redactions Walter
made a mental note of what he had seen
put the file back in its proper place
and headed back to his computer terminal
however after riding in an almost
trance-like stay he looked back on his
work to see that he had written an entry
on
scp-058 a giant evil bovine heart with
insect legs and a scorpion Stinger
strange he thought that's when Walter
got a call from Mr Kovach on his
foundation issue phone and he didn't
sound happy he'd given Walter direct
instructions to go back and digitize the
files on zero five five and instead he'd
been working on zero five a what was the
meaning of This Walter was typically an
extremely loyal and diligent employee
but the verbal barrage from his
supervisor had him considering talking
back just this once and hoping it didn't
get him demoted to d-class and thrown
into 682's Acid Bath for playtime Walter
Galt picked up some courage and
interrupted Mr kovach's rant to ask if
he had any idea what scp-055 actually
was the line went silent for a moment
then his supervisor spoke again this
time with less confidence of course I
can tell you about
scp-055 it's a classic one of the first
hundred how could you forget it's uh or
yeah you know it's I think it's the one
with um
another long pause as Mr Kovach seemed
to search for the words but instead just
trailed off into silence knowing that
some of the anomalies on file were
dangerous mimetic hazards Walter was
worried for a moment that he may have
accidentally killed his boss by getting
him to think too hard about
scp-055 he asked if Mr Kovach was okay
and finally got a reply
I'm sorry I seem to have zoned out for a
second there what were we talking about
again but this time it was Walter who
couldn't answer he had no idea at all
what the two of them were discussing
just moments ago he felt disoriented and
kind of sick like they'd taken some low
level amnestics Mr Kovach told Walter to
get back to his filing duties and they'd
speak later Walter then checked the
messages he'd received from Mr Kovach
earlier and there it was plain as day
you missed zero five five go back and
digitize that before proceeding Mr K but
Walter had never even heard of an
scp-055 if such an anomaly even existed
what was going on here in that moment
Walter realized he was dealing with
something much Stranger Than Just a
standard digitization job after all how
could he properly complete his duties of
scp-055 seemed to be impossible to speak
right or even think about unless you
were directly observing it at that
moment Walter had to know and ask around
the entirety of site 19 to find the
answers if he had to
sadly for Walter he was about to embark
on a much more challenging task than he
could have ever imagined to paraphrase a
supposed quote from Socrates all I know
is that I know nothing and that's also
about the extent of the knowledge we
have on
scp-055 also known as the anti-mean and
the self-keeping secret what does it
look like when and how was it obtained
by the foundation what are its anomalous
abilities the is this thing dangerous we
may never know because the only
anomalous ability of scp-055 that we're
aware of is the fact that nobody is
capable of retaining any information
about it it's crucial to note that
whatever 055 is it isn't invisible or
Indescribable Foundation Personnel are
perfectly capable of entering its
containment chamber and observing it
without incident but mere minutes after
leaving the chamber any memories of the
particulars of 055 seem to spontaneously
erase themselves
hence the self-keeping secret but this
didn't deter Walter perhaps his greatest
Advantage was that he didn't know enough
about the thing he was investigating to
know how futile his mission was he
wanted to know the unknowable and a
pesky issue like impossibility wouldn't
stop him he'd get to whoever he needed
to at site 19 to get the answers he
needed of course most people had no
knowledge of the mysterious anomaly the
common response he got back from his
colleagues was zero five five do we even
have a zero five five well the
realization of sudden memory loss or the
realization of 055's existence has been
known to cause momentary stress there
are no known long-term physical or
mental effects from zero five five's
anomalous abilities it's a fleeting idea
in its purest form like forgetting why
you walked into a room 055 could be the
most harmless object on the foundation's
roster or the most deadly either way we
just don't know
at times Walter worried he was going
insane zero five five and everything
related to it was gaslighting him was
zero five five even real the one thing
that proved to him that 055 must have
existed is that its containment chamber
existed
according to the official records kept
by the foundation on the site-19
containment facilities
zero five five is kept in a five by five
by 2.5 meter Square Room constructed of
50-foot thick cement with a faraday cage
surrounding the cement walls the report
continues that access is via a heavy
containment door measuring 2 by 2.5
meters constructed on bearings to ensure
door closes and locks automatically
unless held open deliberately
055 cell is one of the few to have no
posted security guards and any Personnel
working on other scps in the area are
ordered to remain at least 50 feet from
the geometric Center of zero five five
cell
where the anomaly itself is capped when
he tried to explore further why the cell
was constructed in this manner he found
that surprise surprise nobody knew
055 was an anomaly whose containment
requirements were so mysterious that it
automatically netted itself a ketter
class designation after all how can you
properly contain something you can't
even hope to comprehend there were
plenty of rumors about the true nature
of zero five five
some of the more conspiratorial Minds at
site 19 theorized that 055 was actually
an autonomous or remotely controlled spy
inserted into the site to observe
Foundation operations or even Humanity
as a whole if you're on the more
paranoid end of the psychological
Spectrum this Theory makes total sense
an anomaly that's physically impossible
to remember even when writings and
pictures on the subject exist would be a
perfect spy however this was all
ultimately little more than speculation
Walter was barely any further along than
when he started there were multiple
points in his investigations where
Walter seriously considered giving up
until finally he had a major
breakthrough Dr Bartholomew Hughes and
Dr John marichek were two scientists
that had performed extensive research
into zero five five and who Walter hoped
might have the answers he sought about
the self-keeping secret these scientists
were the first to discover the
anti-memetic nature of 055 performing
numerous tests on d-class Personnel to
see if it was possible to create
feasible written records sketches or any
other records or Impressions that could
bypass its anomalous effects the
disorienting memory ruining effects of
055 also extend to any materials
concerning 055 it seems to be a truly
uncrackable code but Dr Hughes may have
finally found some cracks in the armor
for starters the fact that we're able to
remember that zero five five is an
anti-memetic is an ironic exception to
its anti-memetic qualities this
Revelation also inspired another
realization from Dr Hughes
would it be possible to discover more
about zero five five from the process of
deduction rather than the typical
induction in other words could they
possibly learn about zero five five by
figuring out all the things it isn't
rather than what it is Dr marichek
designed an experiment with Dr Hughes to
explore this Theory they designed the
experiment around a simple question is
055 not spherical in designing the
question to specifically find out what
055 isn't they hope to subvert the
anomaly's anti-memetic powers Walter was
fascinated by this potential method of
getting answers marichek and Hughes
found that while the questioning process
for those exposed was often arduous and
frustrating they could now definitely
say that 055 is not a sphere it is
theoretically possible to discover the
true nature of 055 by an almost endless
barrage of deductive questions though
whether command would authorize the
resource sources for such extensive
testing is still an open question Walter
and his desperation begged marichek and
Hughes for clearance to view zero five
five himself the Curiosity had become
too great during a search to just walk
away with the single fact that zero five
five wasn't spherical he needed to see
this thing and after several weeks of
filling out forms and cutting red tape
his wish was finally granted Walter
Bainbridge was allowed a private
audience with
scp-055 the subject of his month's long
Obsession Outsiders observe that Walter
spent just over an hour in the
containment chamber taking photos
drawing sketches writing down notes
recording audio logs and reciting memory
mnemonics he was pulling out every stop
to counteract the anti-memetic effects
of the self-keeping secret he was
adamant that he would not be defeated by
his non-spherical Nemesis not after all
this time and effort once his time in
the 055 containment chamber was over he
retired back to his office to finally
digitize his exhaustive findings so that
his supervisor Mr Kovach would finally
get off his back Walter smiled took a
deep breath and began to type
scp-059 ketter class this anomaly is a
radioactive mineral that emits a unique
radiation known as Delta radiation
exposure to this radiation has caused
strange fungal growth on the infected
wait what was this supposed to be about
again oh well it couldn't have been that
important Dr Dan anxiously paced in his
cell it was the only way he'd been able
to occupy himself for the past six
months save for pouring through files
and when he was lucky being able to
oversee another failed termination
attempt he only stopped pacing when for
a brief and horrible moment he realized
that monster was probably doing the
exact same thing in its big metal cube
at this very moment that horrible
creature that he'd thrown away his life
for a feudal shot at killing perhaps the
whole thing had been a Fool's errand
after all he was formerly a researcher
under the employee of the SCP Foundation
secure contain protect they had truly
sadistic beasts like scp-106 the
nightmarish old man and scp-352 Baba
Yaga in containment cells and there was
no plans to terminate either of them
they weren't the global occult Coalition
for 343's sake why did Dr Dan even want
to terminate
scp-096 in the first place he tried to
explain it to them again and again but
his pleas had fallen on deaf ears in his
mind the impetus for destroying the shy
guy was terrifyingly clear it was a
monster that killed anyone or anything
that looked at its face even a
photograph of it even a tiny collection
of pixels when its rage state was
induced it seemed that no nothing would
stop it it would have an intuitive
psychic link to its victim charge at
them at Breakneck speed and only find it
Zen again once all of them were dead and
if a picture of scp-096 was leaked onto
the internet it would cause a chain
reaction that triggered an XK class and
the world scenario there were plenty of
creatures and entities that the
foundation knew about that could
theoretically bring about the apocalypse
but to him 096 was the most realistic he
preyed upon the inherent curiosity and
thirst for knowledge seeded in every
human heart the same drive to Simply
know that led to the creation of the SCP
Foundation would be Humanity's Doom in
the face of an scp-096 outbreak and if
such a thing happened the foundation
would need to break the Masquerade of
secrecy to have any hope of saving
Humanity in his many feverish nightmares
Dr Dan had seen it all so clearly the
first photographs of SCP 096's face
would be leaked online perhaps a few
hundred people across the globe would
look in disparate enough locations that
it would be almost impossible for the
foundation to detect and save all of
them as scp-096 went on its bloody
Rampage of course as the image
proliferated as images on the internet
often do the purview of 096's violence
would only grow people across the nation
would start to take notice and soon
after that across the world mysterious
creature causing Mass casualties would
be the headline on every news desk
because why would anybody want to talk
about anything else perhaps some foolish
reporters would take video footage of
the creature everyone has a phone these
days with high definition cameras
pictures would be taken and posted more
and more of it would flood the internet
too many simultaneous moles for even the
SCP Foundation to whack the news would
spread panic and history area would
spread people wouldn't even know what's
triggering all this horror if the
foundation didn't go public and tell
them that it was the pictures that was
killing everyone and by then wouldn't it
already be too late the antidote to fear
is knowledge it's why when anything goes
wrong where refreshing timelines and
feeds and news websites for any kind of
information and if you were told an
Unstoppable monster was killing scores
of people and might be coming to a
neighborhood near you sometime soon
wouldn't you want a good look at it
wouldn't you want to know your enemy
having no idea that the mere Act of
knowing was what sealed your horrible
Fate by Dr Dan's Bleak estimations if
only several million people died as a
result of this kind of scenario it could
be considered a positive outcome he'd
seen it all but no matter how many times
he tried to articulate this to his
superiors he wasn't listened to they
didn't take him or the threat correct
that scp-096 posed seriously every time
he warned of the apocalyptic potential
of scp-096 he was simply told to get
back to working on those goggles it was
why he needed to give those naysayers a
demonstration it was why a certain
photograph needed to show up in the home
of a certain Mountaineer it's why all
those people had to die there was no
other way the deaths of the civilians
and the researchers and the mobile task
force members were of course regrettable
but it was the only way to prevent the
deaths of so many more they gave him
what he wanted permission to put this
gangly time bomb in the ground even if
the beast's death was inextricably tied
to his own execution at the hands of the
very employers who authorized him the
world was full of funny little ironies
like that another one is that even
though Dr Dan now had the authorization
and funding to terminate
scp-096 he was discovering that he
lacked another important factor the
capability they tried incinerating it
exposing it to massive amounts of
radiation exposing it to an insane
degree of kinetic trauma the equivalent
of being hit by an out-of-control bullet
train they tested every kind of
experimental off the books Weaponry that
they had access to through various
research projects proton blasts lasers
high intensity energy beams nothing even
when they fried off every scrap of Flesh
on the monster's body its unbreakable
skeletons still remained and in what
seemed like no time at all it'd be back
in Action its very existence seemed to
mock him the guard opened his cell door
staring disdainfully at the disgraced
researcher that same guard had slammed
his head against a wall a month earlier
one of his friends had apparently been
killed in the legendary 096 Containment
Breach that set this whole sword thing
in motion up an atom scumbag he sat in
the gruff's early voice training a
handgun on the doctor he knew wouldn't
fight back they need you in test chamber
6. Dr Dan allowed himself a small grin
imperceptible to the guard who clearly
hated his guts they'd approved his 096
vs 682 cross test marvelous how
marvelous to all the others it would
seem like just one more entry in the
long line of 682 cross tests he thought
it Darkly funny in his eyes the
foundation had no hope of ever killing
scp-682 its defining quality was being
impossible to kill and it didn't present
nearly the threat to the entire world
that 096 posed their futile attempts to
murder the lizard were little more than
a money sink to justify the site's
exorbitant funding but perhaps he could
turn this to his benefit maybe a CP 682
would hold the secret to actually
killing off his Nemesis within 30 hours
Dr Dan had his disappointing answer both
anomalies had undeniably done a real
number on each other and Dr Dan did take
a kind of sick Amusement in the mental
trauma that scp-682 had induced in 096
But ultimately it was all for nothing
682 had skin 096 alive and melted off
its flesh with acid but once again that
indestructible skeleton stood firm this
had been the 27th termination attempt
since the incident the 27th failed
termination attempt Dr Dan mentally
corrected himself
096's skeleton kept defeating them even
their most Ardent attempts to penetrate
the bones and destroy the creature
within had failed during a previous
attempt they tried to access the brain
by putting a diamond hard drill into its
eye sockets of course it was the drill
that actually broke much to Dr Dan's
seemingly tireless frustration needless
to say in the debriefing interview with
Dr Carver a researcher who once would
have considered him a colleague he
wasn't in High Spirits if he managed to
kill this thing then he would always be
the hero who made a terrible sacrifice
in order to save many more lives if he
didn't kill 096 he was little more than
the monster who murdered all those
innocent people for nothing though you'd
never hear him say it out loud if it
wasn't for that damnable indestructible
skeleton this monster would be long dead
already if only there was some way to
break the creature's bones that's when
it hit him
SCP-173 the sculpture a site 19 icon
often overlooked because of its more
silent but deadly style but undeniably
one of the most frightening and
dangerous anomalies out there it had
racked up a truly shocking body count
since it was first interred at site 19
in 1993 one broken neck at a time and
it's one of the few creatures out there
that even the hard to destroy reptile
himself is utterly terrified of perhaps
a monster that practically has a PHD in
breaking bones would be the ideal
candidate to vandalize the Shy Guy's
vertebrae once his proposed proposal was
greenlit for initial testing Dr Dan
arranged for the shy guy with a bag over
his head of course to be brought into a
testing chamber with the ever stoic
SCP-173 when all the researchers and
guards were safely outside all it took
was a single blink to make all of Dr
Dan's darkest dreams come true in the
nanoseconds his eyes were closed he
heard the most beautiful sounds in the
world a loud fleshy Crunch and a pained
howl from 096 he opened his eyes to an
equally wondrous sight zero nine six
doubled over at an unnatural angle its
spine snapped between the fourth and
fifth vertebrae spinal fluid leaking
down the creature's flank that freaky
little sculpture had done it it had
actually damaged the Integrity of the
Shy Guy's skeleton it was at that moment
that Dr Dan knew he could kill this
thing admittedly there was a Containment
Breach shortly after that when the bag
slipped off of 096's head and it charged
through the nearby steel wall killing
multiple people before being subdued and
recontained but when it comes to
projects involving Dr Dan a mere handful
of innocent people being killed sits
comfortably within the acceptable margin
of error a day later Dr Dan was standing
before a crowded boardroom with agents
researchers and even a few members of
the o5 council in attendance he
explained his findings to them and the
fact that even more importantly they may
have a way to bring The Wretched
existence of 096 to an absolute halt his
plans were approved not long after he
was putting them into motion Dr Dan was
surrounded by researchers and heavily
armed guards as 173 was escorted into
the test chamber with a forklift 096 was
there still bagged off to the side was a
giant tub of hydrofluoric acid connected
to a hose and injector attachment if
this didn't work nothing would everyone
stood back in a safe Zone as 173 was
released to do its thing crunch just
like the previous time 096's spine had
been successfully snapped spinal fluid
dribbled down its skin everyone had
rushed into the chamber one group kept
173 isolated with their stairs the other
headed by Dr Dan prepared the acid
injector and shoved it into the breach
in 096's spine as the acid was pumped by
the gallon into 096's Bones the creature
let out the most horrifying whale it
kicked and bucked as more acid was
pumped in melting those indestructible
Bones from within the creature even
began to vomit acid as it panicked
melting the bag off of its own head some
panicked and averted their gaze Dr Dan
didn't he stared directly at the
creature's face for the first time as it
melted in front of him with nothing
short of pure relation heading one had
he actually won the creature let out a
gurgling shriek and the guards opened
fire their bullets splattered into the
monster's melting Flesh and Bones as it
hollered and treat they didn't let up
firing up and down its body spraying it
with white hot lead it began to melt and
bubble away expanding into a great
gruesome puddle on the floor beneath
them Dr Dan laughed like a madman even
as the guards grabbed him and dragged
him away from the foul-smelling greasy
mess bubbling with chemical life he just
kept laughing even though he knew the
death of 096 meant an equally Swift
death of his own it didn't matter it had
all been for something the world was
saved it was over he'd finally won have
you ever seen something you weren't
supposed to something that made you feel
off something you regret Secrets like
these are Best Kept to your self but
since you're still alive whatever you
saw wasn't nearly as bad as what Peter
Holland saw one fateful night in January
of 2015. Peter was an unremarkable man
an office worker slaving away at The
Daily Grind and like a lot of people
Peter enjoyed nothing more than coming
home after a long hard day kicking back
and watching some TV it was this
innocent activity that led to Peter's
horrifying brush with
scp-5049 altering the course of his
otherwise average life forever the event
started at around 1005 PM Peter was
channel surfing glued to the couch in
his sparsely furnished apartment
commercials commercials commercials as
far as Peter's tired eyes could see he
paused for a moment to watch the end of
an ad for a car he could never hope to
afford on his salary but something
stopped him from changing the channel
again the next ad had begun and it was
playing a strange scratchy jingle that
gave Peter an odd sense of unease but
even Stranger Than That was the text on
screen demon Dan's Discount homunculus
Depot in baby blue bubble lettering he
forced a smile this had to be some weird
comedy skit or viral marketing campaign
or maybe it was something he drank but
no this was a real commercial and things
were about to get even weirder the peppy
logo faded to a concerning sight a tall
humanoid figure dressed like a used car
salesman but one that definitely wasn't
human his skin was dark green and
covered in patches of thick fur he had
long fingers with intimidating Claws and
a grin full of needle-like fangs it
looked almost demonic and after a few
seconds the demon began to speak hey
there folks it's a man demon Dan coming
at you with the latest and greatest
deals from demon Dan's Discount
homunculus Depot we've just accepted the
shipment of brand new models that would
make even the most Discerning customers
weep with excitement let's see what
we've got the creature apparently named
demon Dan stepped away from his desk
revealing two long furry goat legs that
ended in large pointed Hooves Peter now
assumed he really was going crazy but at
this point he was along for the ride
demon Dan continued his pitch looking to
make your way through the capitalist
hellscape that makes home look cozy come
try one of our newest businessman models
Dan gestured behind him to where Peter
was horrified to see a total of 52 adult
male human bodies hanging from a wall
there was something uncanny about them
they seemed almost Hollow like a highly
realistic costume or a prop from a
horror movie Peter didn't have much time
to think about it though as demon Dan
went on if you're looking for an extra
challenge of inequality the
businesswoman model may be a right fit
for you the commercial then revealed the
wall of human female bodies strung up in
a similar fashion now you may be
thinking but Dan business sounds hot I
just want to have some fun and the fine
team here at demon Dan's Discount
homunculus Depot have got you covered
the camera zoomed out to show an area of
the store filled with children's
decorations and more of these strange
hollowed-out human suits in child sizes
to match and who has more fun than kids
no one that's who for a limited time the
purchase of any child size unit comes
with a complimentary 50 off coupon for
parental units you just can't say no to
a deal like that before Peter could
process the madness that was unfolding
before him the camera cut again the
store's logo appeared on the screen once
more along with several cuts to
locations around the store itself there
are more human bodies hundreds of them
demon Dan's sleazy voice rang out over
all of it here demon dance discount
Among Us Depot we know it's not all fun
and games the brightest Among Us have a
mission to accomplish the seven Lords
are ever planning their Invasion after
all so you're looking for function over
form well we've got that in Spades down
here in the Tactical Services Department
you'll be kicking Us in no time when
you're wearing the latest models at the
best prices seven Lords Invasion what
did any of this mean suddenly the camera
was showing him a new room red curtains
parted revealing more of these person
suits several bearing a striking
resemblance to real human celebrities he
managed to make out Gucci Mane Avril
Lavigne Paul McCartney and Britney
Spears before demon Dan's appearance
once again drew his attention I've got a
special treat for you we're happy to
announce the VIP look-alike Department
we all know how difficult the creation
of homunculus is it's a fine art that
takes years of practice so when a
replacement order on VIPs comes in every
detail needs to be perfect unfortunately
really that's not always the case but
for the right price you too can look
like famous icons from around the globe
the image of celebrity bodies faded from
View and Peter was left looking at the
grinning demon Dan standing behind the
front desk of his impossible store once
more he said there you have it folks
come on down to demon dance discount
homunculus Depot if you're viewing the
advertisement then you've been selected
for entry please enter the nearest door
for instant deals and upgrade those old
Duds for one of our newest models what
are you waiting for come on down the
logo popped up again hovering above some
bold text that said please enter the
nearest store Peter had had enough he
switched off the TV what a horror show
he thought they should just warn you
before they put short horror films on TV
like that he had no idea they could just
slip them in among regular commercials
surely demon Dan in this store couldn't
be real right but as his eyes drifted to
the door in his room he didn't feel
quite so certain well there was only one
way to find out Peter got up went over
to the door took a deep breath and
walked through it Peter Holland was
never seen again not as himself anyway
the SCP Foundation has long been aware
of this Sinister transmission known as
scp-5049-2 and luckily has found ways to
prevent it from claiming more victims
the foundation television analysis
Department as well as web crawler 40y 40
which is the software the foundation
uses to root out anomalous activity
online are always vigilant for signs of
demon Dan's commercial running just
observing demon Dan who is himself
classified as
scp-5049-a and his ads put you in
immediate danger as they can transform
any nearby doors into
scp-5049-1s those are interdimensional
portals that remain active for around 15
minutes after viewing the ad so then
what specifically is
scp-5049 it's the entire pocket
Dimension known as demon Dan's Discount
homunculus Depot a cutie or class
spatial anomaly constantly on the
lookout for new human victims which it
transforms into fleshy suits for its
demonic clients which let them blend in
around humans prior to its Discovery by
the foundation it's likely that demon
Dan and his associates claimed hundreds
if not thousands of lives but sadly even
discovering this anomaly came at a
gruesome cause to the foundation on
February 16 2020 the ad played on safe
storage Warehouse 13's break room
television at the time of the broadcast
four Foundation Personnel were present
including security agent William Birkin
worrying that this was a potential
security threat agent Birkin
investigated the door to a nearby closet
the second he opened it he was
transformed to the storefront of demon
Dan's Discount homunculus Depot he saw
demon Dan himself standing at the corner
while four smaller reptilian M's fought
over a small flesh suit demon Dan
scolded them before turning his
attention to agent Perkin you are
supposed to be here little man how
naughty I'm gonna have to have a word
with marketing once I'm through with you
agent Burkin fearing for a safety drew
his weapon and shot demon damn three
times the creature dematerialized before
appearing right next to agent Birkin and
disarming him with a swift chop the
unfortunate security agent was then
grabbed by the considerably larger demon
Dan and thrown over Dan's shoulder we
know all of this because agent birkin's
standard issue Foundation body camera
recorded the whole terrifying ordeal
even as demon Dan dragged the helpless
Birkin back into the Twisted Workshop
behind the store there Birkin saw what
would soon be his own fate right before
his eyes Dan's minions converting human
bodies into fleshy suits for their demon
clientele and this this unfortunate
security officer was next Dan gave him
over to a pair of large sheep like
demons and told them to drain skin and
declaw him birkin's video feed finally
cut as the demons pulled out the rusty
tools and began to work on him of course
the SCP Foundation wouldn't take an
attack on one of their operatives inside
one of their facilities no less lying
down the unfortunate death of William
Birkin allowed the foundation to refine
their methods of intercepting the
broadcast of demon Dan's commercials
they even had a new mobile Task Force
Mobile Strike Force Kappa 11 or the
Baphomet Bashers specifically to deal
with demon Dan and his cronies they did
more than just prevent him from taking
new humans though when the Baphomet
Bashers teamed up with an A-Class
Clairvoyant entity to improve their
efficiency in predicting future
broadcasts they were able to launch
sting operations and arrest 21 different
demonic customers for interrogation this
impressive strike back finally gave the
foundation some meaningful leverage over
demon Dan and through the use of their
Clairvoyant entity they were able to
call a temporary truce and arrange a
meeting with demon Dan himself Captain
Steiner an agent of the foundation
external negotiation Department was the
one to interrogate demon Dan they sat
across from each other at a table and
Demon Dan was clearly tense frustrated
with the way the foundation had been
messing with his business all of their
sting operations were frightening off
his customers in return for letting him
continue his work the foundation wanted
Dan to turn over all the information on
his bosses and customers allowing the
foundation to track their movements when
Dan was evasive about whether he'd
comply they tried threatening him Dan
laughed them off go ahead take your best
shot little man there's a dozen more
just like me you won't stop anything
finally he was pressured into giving a
yes or no answer as to whether he'd
willingly collaborate with the
foundation and act as an informant
against his kind when demon Dan hinted
that he may be willing to comply he
began to make a horrifying gurgling
noise and gripped his head in pain he
began speaking in Latin in a voice that
wasn't his own as though the seven demon
Lords he served were speaking through
him they said you are a fool Jailer to
think a pathetic morso such as this
could Aid you against us I have allowed
you to toil in your own delusions for
far too long you may have taken
advantage of azimodius all those years
ago but you stop nothing You Hinder
nothing you jail and barter to no avail
your time is coming and then demon Dan's
head exploded which obviously prevented
him from giving any incriminating
information on those he worked for
whoever the demon Lords are there's
certainly the secretive type you may
think that this is the end of Demon
dance discount homunculus Depot and of
scp-5049 but soon another ad ran it
advertised the same products and
services out of the same store the only
difference was that this time a
different entity was starring in it
what's in a name ancient folklore and
fairy tales sometimes tell of the
importance of names that they can hold
the power to summon or vanish whether
you buy into the Superstition or not
you'd be unwise to ignore the power a
name can have especially if you ever
dare to venture into scp-4000 why use
your own name too many times in this
extra-dimensional forest and you may
find that what walks out isn't you at
all at least once a year the foundation
leads an expedition into scp-4000 to
explore this keter class Dimension but
if you go down to those Woodstock a day
then you'd better follow the rules
remember the foundation has implemented
these guidelines for your own safety and
it's in your best interests to follow
them first and foremost when referencing
anything inside scp-4000 be it a person
place or thing you cannot under any
circumstances use names or titles
communication is key when exploring
scp-4000 and making use of specific
descriptors will deter any adverse
effects on your journey for example you
may want to refer to the location of
scp-4000 as the woods where you need to
speak carefully an apt description for
such a place of course there is a reason
the foundation doesn't provide a handy
flashcard of alternative descriptors for
any Personnel taking part in the annual
Mission into scp-4000 nothing found
there can be referred to with any
consistent name so it's perhaps
advisable to look over a thesaurus and
expand your vocabulary before visiting
scp-4000 as you'll need to come up with
a lot of different ways to refer to the
people and creatures around you but
don't worry the foundation will be able
to train you how to properly refer to
scp-4000 in both written and verbal
communication in a similar vein the
second rule states that no Personnel
member should respond to their own name
while in scp-4000 naturally you and your
fellow Expedition team will not be alone
in the forest you find yourselves in the
denizens of scp-4000 are perpetually
mutating creatures some appearing to be
trustworthy While others are hostile it
is for personnel members own safety that
no consistent names or titles are used
to refer to each other in conversation
this has been known to cause Personnel
returning from scp-4000 to experience
Vivid hallucinations and in some
instances has led to the appearances of
creatures found in scp-4000 in our world
thirdly when interacting with the life
forms residing in scp-4000 Personnel are
advised to accept any gifts that they're
offered but are warned to under no
circumstances consume anything that is
given to them while inside the forest
finally in above all do not divulge any
name nickname code name Alias or any
other personal designation when
interacting with any native entities and
disregard any designator that an
inhabitant of scp-4000 attempts to
assign to you personnel must however
remain courteous in the presence of any
native creature of scp-4000 and treat
these entities with respect and
formality access to scp-4000 can only be
achieved by performing procedure 4000
Holloway a ritual requiring a steady
flame in an indoor fireplace fueled by
only organic kindling Personnel are
required to combine the powdered bones
of one male lion one male red fox and a
baleen whale and cast these into the
fire with a personal possession holding
strong sentimental value to the staff
member performing 4000 Holloway next
Personnel are to add three feathers of a
bird such as a raven or Crow and must
respond with the correct counter phrases
once the fire begins to emit a voice if
these conditions are met and the correct
responses given Foundation Personnel
will gain access to the entry point of
scp-4000 if any error is made during the
course of Performing procedure 4000
Holloway then under no sir circumstances
should this ritual be repeated staff are
urged to apologize for any incorrect
actions then refrain from engaging this
procedure in the future should procedure
4000 Holloway be completed successfully
Foundation Personnel will find
themselves arriving in the access point
to scp-4000 emerging from the mouth of
an old well in the center of the forest
exploration teams sent into scp-4000 are
advised that this Dimension does not
adhere to the laws of physical space
that Personnel will be accustomed to
there is a single confirmed safe route
that must be used when traversing The
Forest of scp-4000 a dirt path leading
in a circuit both beginning and
terminating at the entry point previous
attempts to map the landscape of
scp-4000 all confirmed that the only way
to safely exit this Dimension is to
follow the entire length of the path in
One Direction until eventually returning
to the well you have been warned any
attempt to travel back to the direction
you came in will result in a loss of
contact with the rest of the Expedition
team as mentioned scp-4000 is home to a
number of entities often noted to be
undergo showing continuous and dramatic
changes in form these physiological
mutations appear to occur whenever these
creatures are unobserved making
distinguishing between them difficult
when questioned about the exact nature
of these changes the inhabitants of
scp-4000 claim to have no control over
them and expressed distress and
dissatisfaction when said changes occur
guidelines have been put in place by the
foundation regarding the interactions
between personnel and creatures found in
the forest and adhering to the rules
regarding the use of consistent names
and titles remains vitally important the
native creatures appear semi-humanoid
and are reported to be highly
temperamental should any staff member
happen to offend one of these natives
they may be subjected to anything from
verbal assault to acts of extreme
physical violence from the scp-4000
resident if any foundation Personnel
further question why there are so many
rules when visiting scp-4000 then they
need to look no further than the
discoveries and fate of Dr Eugene japers
who during his initial expedition to
scp-4000 in 2005 and countered a
humanoid native City whose head
resembled the rabbits as the pair shared
a polite conversation the rabbit-like
creature made an inquiry regarding Dr
japer's name asking how was your name
keeping to the rules Dr japers did not
divulge any name or other form of title
to the creature at this time however
japers remained courteous and polite
during the interaction the rabbit
responded with the following are you
simple I'm merely asking how your name
is my name has smelt of raspberries
lately I think or snapdragons perhaps
it's so hard to tell these days but one
makes an effort in his reply Dr japers
made a reference to his own name as
having tasted rather tart as of late
before concluding the conversation with
the rapid entity Upon returning to the
scp-4004 is three years later Dr japers
was met with the same creature and once
again engaged in conversation with it
after briefly discussing their previous
encounter Dr Jeffers was able to turn
their exchange towards something the
rabbit had mentioned before about
finding it difficult to describe his own
name when asked to clarify this point
the rabbit replied I can only assume
it's because of how long we've been
apart heart to my name and I that is
it's a good name a proud name I'm fairly
sure by this point though it's probably
decayed from its former Grandeur if it
even still exists after this mention of
its relationship with its own name it
should be noted that the rabbit referred
to Dr japers by the title fellow scholar
the third and final encounter between Dr
japers and this entity came in 2013
after the doctor was sent into scp-4000
with instructions to conduct a more
thorough interview with the subject it
was during their third conversation that
the rapid man revealed details of a long
forgotten war between human beings and
the residents of scp-4000 apparently
these creatures the FAE do not originate
from the forest in which they now reside
and according to the rabbit man's claims
were born in our world much as it
Grieves me to say we were betrayed the
rabbit explained we had fought side by
side you know in the war against that
factory we had done nothing but help
them and what did they do they destroyed
us they took so many of our lives in all
of our names some of us fled here when
the war was just beginning but not many
not many still though I don't hate them
it has been assumed by some that the
foundation was directly involved in
whatever may have wiped out the FAE
causing them to either Retreat or be
banished to the forest of scp-4000 and
additional assumption has been made that
whatever weapons were used on these
creatures is directly responsible for
their constantly shifting State
rendering them without their own names
or identities whatever the case may be
it was during their conversation that Dr
japers in reference to their second
encounter referred to himself as a
fellow scholar to the rabbit in order to
coax information from him however in
doing so the doctor had unwittingly
accepted the title that the native
entity had given him by mistakenly
responding to the name fellow scholar
the doctor had broken the rules of
interacting with the creatures of
scp-4000 an easy mistake but a costly
one the doctor would later leave
scp-4000 traversing the safe path back
to the well and Dr J for Spanish shortly
after his exit from scp-4000 his
whereabouts are currently unknown the
foundation has made several attempts to
investigate his untimely disappearance
but to this day he remains missing and
the fur left on the inside of his
expedition gear displayed no strange
properties the single goal it would seem
of the creatures residing in scp-4000 is
the theft of names however this
naturally extends far beyond the
dimension's definition of identity theft
though an unfortunate blunder Dr chapers
allowed the friendly nature and demeanor
of the rabbit entity to trick him into
accepting the name fellow scholar by
giving Dr japers a name the rabbit was
free to steal not only his name but his
very identity while it is unclear how
this transference is achieved by the
creatures it is due to the risk of this
that the foundation employs such strict
rules for any research team tasked with
traveling to the forest of scp-4000 make
no mistake names have more power than we
realize and this is evident in few
places more so than scp-4000 a pocket
Dimension where ever-changing survivors
of a forgotten Massacre exist as
identities alone remember a name is a
powerful thing whichever side of the
world you find yourself on your name
binds you to who you are but if your
name becomes someone else's then someone
else of yours becomes theirs too it was
July of 2004 and Bill Murray was
enjoying the peak of an extremely
successful career not only had the
iconic actors starred in some of the
most beloved comedies of the 20th
century including Ghostbusters and
Groundhog Day he'd voiced the main
character of the recently released
live-action Garfield movie it'd been a
financial success but it was a critical
flop not that this bothered Bill he was
happy with the performance and the
paycheck
what he wouldn't be quite as happy about
was the horrifying encounter he was
about to have with scp-3166
on July 8th bill was enjoying a cold
drink on the porch of his luxurious
Beverly Hills Home the sky was beginning
to darken as the sun set in the west it
was a blissful evening his wife Jennifer
was inside watching TV nothing seemed
particularly out of the ordinary until
he noticed a quick flash of orange in
the distance it was almost too fast to
register this large orange-shaped
darting past the corner of his eye for a
second he entertained the thought that
it might have been an escape Tiger but
it was gone too fast to really tell Bill
finished his drink and headed inside he
had enough for one night the next
morning he got up to read the paper and
found the Garfield movie getting
slaughtered by the critics one review
stated no one can accuse Garfield the
movie of infidelity to its source it
Faithfully conveys the banality of Jim
Davis's cartoon another called it a film
without energy and without spirit
put the paper down and ate his breakfast
a few blows to the ego were worth it for
the paydays that came with big budget
family films just then his wife came to
him with a strange question were you
walking around downstairs in the middle
of the night no he hadn't he'd been
sleeping like a baby why did she ask
well Jennifer said I heard some rustling
downstairs last night
sounded like something big
he hadn't heard anything though and told
her it was probably just Her Imagination
he put it out of his mind and continued
about his death he decided he would keep
his eyes peeled for that orange blur
again though Bill didn't see anything
peculiar the rest of the morning and
went to a local cafe for lunch he
ordered a coffee and a cream cheese
bagel then made a quick trip to the
bathroom while his food was prepared
when Bill returned to his table though
there was something strange
instead of a bagel there was a large
heaping of lasagna on the table what was
going on this Cafe didn't even serve
lasagna Bill knew something was terribly
wrong things only got stranger when bill
came home to find a small tuft of orange
Furs snagged on the frame of his front
door and it wasn't synthetic for her
like you'd see on plush toys or stuffed
animals no this was real animal fur
maybe someone was just goofing off or
trying to play some weird prank on him
but it didn't feel like it
deep down Bill Murray knew that he was
in grave danger whoever or whatever was
behind this
it wanted to hurt him that night his
worst fears were realized Bill's wife
had left town for the week and he was
headed to the kitchen in the middle of
the night for a glass of water when he
saw something a huge figure moving up
against the glass door leading to his
backyard the thing was huge nearly seven
feet tall with a bloated fur-covered
misshapen body that was pressed up
against the door its fur was bright
garish orange a cartoon Orange
strangest of all though was the sound it
was making
it sounded like it was purring Bill
backed away from the door and then ran
back to his room to hide the whole night
he sat cowering as he heard scratching
against the walls like something was
trying to get in he was terrified and
too scared to do anything even move
finally as morning broke the noises
seemed to stop Bill had to do something
he couldn't let this nightmare go on
another night what if things got worse
what if that thing managed to get inside
he called the local police and when they
arrived he explained the incredibly
strange situation as best he could he
told them he was being stalked by some
kind of huge cat or at least someone
dressed like a huge cat also there was
lasagna involved the officers
interviewing him could barely contain
their laughter as he told them his story
a giant orange cat perhaps one of them
theorized he angered some kind of
obsessive Garfield fan through his
involvement in the live-action movie
after all the original comic had been
running for years and had been extremely
popular who knows what kind of nut jobs
were obsessed with seeing only a
faithful adaptation of the source
material as the officers departed bill
was confident that they weren't taking
him seriously he couldn't rely on any of
them for protection thankfully from a
multi-decade movie career he had plenty
of disposable income and decided to hire
a private security team to protect him
while he looked into this mystery he had
two trained bodyguards positioned around
his home at all times for the next month
they were armed and given the cryptic
orders to fire on anything orange
meanwhile Bill began to Fall Down A
Garfield Rabbit Hole he felt strangely
compelled to research all the Garfield
media he could find as though the answer
to his terrifying situation was somehow
hidden between the lines Bill explored
the entire backlog of thousands of comic
strips he read the books and interviews
with Jim Davis he watched the cartoons
and straight to DVD animated movies
ironically for a guy who'd recently
portrayed the lasagna loving orange cat
Bill had never felt quite so immersed in
the character before
he found the strange Pathos in the
routine of Garfield and his friends one
particular comic really piqued his
interest though originally published in
October of 1989 the comic began with
Garfield being woken up by a strange
Chell an almost Eerie sensation the
character observed aloud that he didn't
feel like he was in his own home he
explored his little home further trying
to find his owner John or his housemate
and sometimes Nemesis Odie but found
nothing as Garfield remarked on feeling
alone a purple speechbox delivered the
Sinister message
you have no idea how alone you are
Garfield
he then finds that his home looks like
it's been abandoned for years
the for sale sign outside is practically
ancient
Garfield slowly comes to a horrifying
revelation
everyone really is gone
and his adventures and friends now exist
only in his imagination he's trapped in
a prison of his own creation trying to
Stave off his endless loneliness in
denial about the reality of his
situation the comic ended with a quote
directly from Jim Davis himself saying
an imagination is a powerful tool it
content memories of the past shade
perceptions of the present or paint a
future so vivid that it can entice or
terrify all depending upon how we
conduct ourselves today as he read those
words Bill Murray felt a chill down his
spine why had he wanted to get involved
in the Garfield movie in the first place
what have he gotten himself into before
he could slip any deeper into his own
mind Bill heard a faint choked scream
downstairs
he felt his breath catch in his throat
he was terrified but needed to see what
was happening
be carefully and quietly began to creep
down the stairs at the bottom he poked
his head around a corner and that's when
he saw a member of his security detail
lying dead on the floor his face was
Blue from asphyxiation his mouth was
stuffed with lasagna
it looked like he had been force-fed to
death
they wanted to scream but he couldn't or
maybe knew he shouldn't just then he
heard a soft meaty thumping noise coming
from the nearby living room he didn't
know why but he felt compelled to
approach as if by forces Beyond his
control he made his way to the living
room and when he'd got there he saw
where the noise was coming from Bill's
jaw dropped in pure horror there was the
other member of his security detail
lying limp and lifeless under a giant
orange figure it was a grotesquely huge
creature wearing what looked to be a
kind of crude Garfield outfit made of
sewn together cat palettes it's stank of
pasta and rotten meat in its giant Paw
It held the golden trophy which it was
using to pound the security guard's head
into mush while making quiet cat-like
purring noises the creature suddenly
stopped and looked up locking eyes with
Bill the fear of death came over him he
froze as the giant freakish Garfield
stepped over Donny's corpse and began to
come towards him bill turned and ran but
Garfield was gaining on him before he
could make it to the front door the
creature knocked him over he was laid
out on the ground looking up at it as it
reached into its own body cavity and
began to pull out handfuls of lasagna he
was about to shove a wad of the horrible
decaying pasta into Bill's mouth when
suddenly a ding Was Heard and the
creature stopped
looked up as if sniffing the air and
then suddenly turned and lumbered
towards the kitchen
Bill watched as the Garfield monster
entered the kitchen where somehow there
was a steaming hot fresh lasagna sitting
in the open oven the creature had sensed
the presence of external lasagna and
felt the compulsion to integrate it into
its body grabbing fistfuls and shoving
it into itself
just then a group of highly trained SCP
Foundation Personnel burst into the room
and subdued the creature
they'd been in Ambush the foundation had
been tipped off to the presence of the
creature by monitoring the local police
department dispatches and the report of
a seven foot tall comic book cat
terrorizing a Hollywood actor was
definitely worth looking into the
monster that had almost taken Bill
Murray's life was
scp-3166 a deadly pathophysical being
that tends to manifest around people
somehow involved in the Garfield
intellectual property it appears
whenever the public perception of
Garfield falls out of favor and because
Bill had starred in the critically pan
Garfield movie he was currently at the
very top of
scp-3166's Hit List
thankfully he managed to survive his
terrifying ordeal and was administered
amnestics by Foundation Personnel so
that he could return to his normal life
this frightening and mysterious creature
has been around since 1989 appearing
after the publication of The Haunting
Garfield comic that Bill had read that
very night
it appeared in the office of United
media who were the Publishers of the
Garfield comic strip at the time and
began wreaking havoc since then the
creature's manifestation has been a
constant threat whenever Garfield loses
its popularity or audience as a result
the foundation has spent years as the
funding source behind all Garfield media
and even planting hypnotic memetics into
the comic strips to ensure that there is
always a loyal fan base
the fur is indeed real organic cat fur
albeit an unnaturally orange color and
instead of organs the creature is filled
with lasagna worst of all though is that
testing has revealed that the meat in
the lasagna is genetically identical to
the Flesh of Garfield's Creator Jim
Davis how did this thing come into
existence perhaps it was Jim's sheer
force of imagination that dragged it
into being as he himself said an
imagination is a powerful tool all in
all it's lucky that Bill Murray was able
to survive his encounter and return to
his normal life well as normal as life
can be for Bill Murray and if you see
Bill Murray don't bother asking him
about scp-3166
the amnestics were quite effective and
just as he's fond of saying himself
no one will ever believe you Jay and
Michael were a pair of urban exploration
YouTubers looking for their big break
you might remember their video exploring
the dead mall on the outskirts of your
town or the supposedly haunted 1950s
insane asylum out in the sticks but you
certainly won't find these videos
anywhere online after the incident at
scp-823 all of their content was
scrubbed away from even the most
comprehensive internet archives why you
ask because these unfortunate Urban
explorers decided that their big break
would be exploring a certain abandoned
theme park and it would be one of the
last decisions they ever made Michael
and Jay had heard rumors about the theme
park its name was lost to time as was
the date of its opening and closing and
the reason it was even abandoned in the
first place even some of the most
hardcore Urban explorers didn't dare To
Tread there something about it a good
friend had once told Jay just didn't
feel right sometimes if you dare to
venture into the forest near the theme
park at night you can still hear music
the Jolly piping tunes of rides and
Carnival stands still beckoning as if to
say we're still here come and play of
course none of this frightened Jay and
Michael they could already smell the
sponsorships from headlamp and compact
camera companies no amount of anxiety
would stop them from making their Doom
trip to the so-called Carnival of
Horrors it's a terrible shame if they'd
listen to the stories of this place
about how unnatural and evil it could be
they might still be alive today like all
the best Urban explorers they arrived at
the woods near the abandoned theme park
in the dead of night they ignored the
signs warning them about everything from
structural instability to dangerous wild
animals to asbestos nothing would keep
them out nothing they reached the
abandoned theme park not long after
though was a mere shell of its former
self during the several decades of
Abandonment nature had reclaimed it the
ferris wheel was covered in overgrown
Ivy and the carnival stands were
blanketed with mold as the duo swept
through the grounds with their
flashlights and cameras they saw a faded
sign that bore the words Thriller
Chiller the Park's most popular roller
coaster they also took their time to
Marvel at the exceptionally creepy
looking Tunnel of Love the broken down
house of mirrors and a huge grinning
statue of the Park's former mascot happy
hippo this theme park was something out
of a nightmare which naturally made it
potential video gold but as the excited
Duo wandered further into the park they
couldn't help but notice the quiet tinny
carnival music music that seemed to be
drawing them closer Michael asked Jay if
he could hear the strange Impossible
music and felt a chill creep in when he
answered that he did could all the
stories be true they were lost in
thought but their legs kept moving they
were getting closer to something now
they could feel a presence and was that
music getting louder an instant later
though another sound cut through the
silence bang bang it echoed out through
the still night air birds flew from
their perches in the trees Jay and
Michael both fell to the ground dead
their heads taken off by the 50 caliber
rounds of a highly trained mobile task
force sniper on the payroll of the SCP
Foundation their recording equipment
along with their bodies were taken and
destroyed any trace of them were
scrubbed from the internet it may seem a
little harsh but a bullet to the head is
much Kinder fade than what would have
awaited these two if they'd kept walking
that's because the carnival of Horrors
is no dark fairy tale the rumors are all
true and something really is waiting in
the dark that's why this abandoned theme
park is known to the SCP Foundation as
scp-823 a Euclid class anomaly with a
violent history what's even more
unnerving is that the researchers
studying 823 have repeatedly implored
the o5 council to increase the Park's
classification to ketir and allocate
more resources for containment only to
be denied but after you've heard about
the horrors that unfolded there and the
danger it poses you'll probably take the
researcher's side the park is divided
into two zones the yellow zone and the
Red Zone there are to be at least six
members of foundation Personnel present
in the yellow zone at all times to
ensure that no civilians wander in are
two Urban explorers earn themselves a
death sentence not just by wandering
into the yellow zone but passing
dangerously close to the Red Zone this
is the true epicenter of the Park's
dangerous anomalous activity it's a
place so hazardous that anyone entering
whether they're a civilian or a member
of foundation staff is to be executed at
a distance by sniper fire without
hesitation once upon a time though
nobody knows exactly when there was a
theme park that seem no different to any
other eager children and thrill-seeking
teens arrived by the busload ready to
stuff their faces with cotton candy and
corn dogs and then reverse the process
on a vast array of roller coasters but
even then during these Good Times there
was something dark lurking behind the
cheerful facade little by little
everyone visitors and employees alike
started falling victim to strange and
horrific accidents around the park of
course when it comes to theme parks
accidents come with a territory but none
like this here are just a handful of the
horrific and mysterious deaths that
occurred while the park was open so
strap in because just like a roller
coaster this isn't for the faint of
heart a pair of young lovebirds decided
they wanted to enjoy the Romance of the
tunnel of love the two sad in a swan
shaped boat as they were ferried through
darkened passageways anyone would assume
that they were having a great time but
at some point terrible shrieks of pain
and fear began to echo through the ride
attendance confused and terrified
stopped the ride and found that the
screaming persisted just some stupid
teens playing a prank they figured and
started the ride again but when the swan
shaped boat finally exited the tunnel of
love the park employees were greeted to
a horrifying site the two teens dead
their bodies somehow fused together at
multiple points another unlucky customer
met a gruesome fade inside the house of
mirrors they entered but while inside
they were stalked by a mysterious
carnivorous humanoid entity known as
subject 79 the customer was pursued and
eventually caught by subject 79 and
brutally dismembered some parts of the
body were fused to the house of Mirror's
interior While others like the right arm
were never found the customer actually
survived their ordeal and whether that's
a happy ending is up to you but it
wasn't just the customers at the park
who were in danger a 23 year old Park
employee working a summer job collapsed
while entertaining children dressed as
the Park's cheerful mascot happy hippo
it wasn't uncommon for people to get
overheated and collapse in the heavy
suits on hot days but one thing was
different here he was screaming crying
and trying desperately to remove his
mask people rushed to help but nobody
could get the suit off and it was
declared dead soon after when he was
eventually cut out of the suit coroners
found that the employee had choked to
death his mouth trachea and lungs were
filled with a fibrous substance later
determined to be identical to the
stuffing of his costume an intense
roller coaster known as the Thriller
Chiller was a magnet for horrific
accidents which became more violent and
intense over time the first accident
seemed like a typical theme park tragedy
a safety harness failed dropping a rider
15 feet during an inverted Loop they
landed on the track below breaking their
neck and skull causing instant death
while the this was a tragedy it wasn't
exactly anomalous but the next major
accident on the ride was an entirely
different story this time 15 people met
with disaster while riding the Thriller
Chiller roller coaster starting from the
front and moving back one car at a time
each group of riders was decapitated by
blunt force trauma a new pair of
decapitations appeared to happen at
every turn and loop on the ride forensic
scientists still have no idea how this
could have possibly occurred despite all
of these disasters the park was only
finally abandoned after a day known as
Bloody Sunday when the anomalous powers
of the location reached a 20-year Peak
it's believed that 231 people were
killed during the Carnage of that day
and another seven were horribly maimed
the SCP Foundation contained the
carnival of Horrors not long after but
the mysterious deaths didn't even end
there Foundation mobile task force row
71 also known as the origami tones were
sending to assess containment procedures
and discover the source of all the
anomalous deaths they were unsuccessful
though and instead they merely added to
the list in exceptionally horrifying
ways One agent was found dead surrounded
by empty grenades and bullet casings it
appeared he'd removed the explosive
propellant from all of his ballistics
and consumed it dying in the process
another was found with his jaw broken
having apparently pulled out and inhaled
his own teeth and dying of the resulting
internal damage the commander got the
worst fate of all so horrifying in fact
that we can't tell you the full details
all you need to know is that something
was shoved into his brain that really
didn't belong there the foundation
considered having the entire park
destroyed with a massive air strike
courtesy of the mobile Task Force new 7
AKA Hammer Town however the o5 council
denied this request on the basis that
the park was too close to populated land
they'd have no plausible cover story for
the bombing and they don't even really
know if blowing up the park would
prevent anomalous activity from
occurring the carnival of Horrors is
here to stay folks the foundation just
hopes to keep it from getting new
visitors so then back to why the
researchers want this place upgraded to
ketir after all these classifications
aren't about how dangerous an anomaly is
they're about how difficult and
complicated they are to contain but
here's the problem according to the
researchers the Red Zone where the
dangerous anomalous activity is at its
peak is inbound to one fixed position
its change position at least three times
already and even worse it appears to be
growing not seemingly so Euclid class
now is it after all you might not even
need to visit the carnival of Horrors to
be in grave danger if it keeps growing
then someday soon the carnival of
Horrors may be visiting you okay guys so
to wrap this video up I really don't
think this cursed episode of this show
was real it's obviously just a really
good scary fan animation and the fact
that the creators behind it didn't come
out and claim ownership of it sooner
allowing it to be reposted and
re-uploaded so many times is really what
got people thinking was legit that being
said it's still a good attempt at what a
cursed Lost episode would look like so
shout out to those animators man anyway
I've been the goat hellholder 98 be sure
to like this video subscribe to my
channel down below and hey if you know
about any more lost media you want me to
cover leave it in the comments I'll
check it out now and be sure to follow
my socials at hell holder98 I go live
most days and post updates about new
videos on my story so go check it out
alright until then I'll see you
somewhere down the line the moment his
finger pushed the button to stop the
camera recording the practiced false
smile dropped from Holden's face it was
hard not to feel down after he'd
finished filming a new video not thanks
to any post-creativity slump but the
more depressing knowledge of just how
much of an uphill battle this whole
thing was it felt like yesterday when
Holden had first gotten into the
creepier side of the internet he never
ventured into anything illicit or
outright illegal mind you but there was
a distinct corner of the web that had
pulled him in when he was still at
school and just starting to spend more
time online this part of the internet
was filled with scary stories that were
mostly fake or made up for likes but
that could have been real there were
unsettling animations short clips that
were hand drawn to give people the
creeps and keep them up at night not to
mention a whole Archive of Public Safety
announcement videos terrifying workplace
and road safety warnings that used to be
broadcast on TV and were as petrifying
than the most acclaimed horror movies
speaking of things that were broadcast
to TV that had gradually become Holden's
specialty one of his friends had sent
him the link to a fictional account of
someone who had supposedly uncovered an
unaired episode of a Saturday morning
kids cartoon or so this person claimed
anyway they went on to describe bizarre
imagery so intense and terrifying that
it was unbefitting of a show for
children then the person who made the
original post explained how they got
into contact with the show's creators
via email to ask them about this cursed
episode The showrunner responded stating
that the episode the poster had
allegedly seen didn't even exist to
Holden it didn't matter if the story was
real or not that wasn't the point what
was far more important was that it felt
real to him it was plausible even
possible that there were pieces of media
out there in the world that had never
seen the light of day episodes of TV
shows or entire movies that were so wild
and out there but they could have been
banned and buried long before the dawn
of the internet wherein there was a
record of everything and nothing was
ever really lost the idea of uncovering
those lost pieces of media became
Holden's primary hobby he'd come home
from school throw his backpack onto his
bed and then sit in front of his
computer for hours without even changing
out of the clothes he had been wearing
all day in class but all all the time he
spent trawling through form threads
following and messaging collectors on
social media listening to theories and
coming up with his own eventually it
began to encroach on other things much
to his mom's disappointment Holden's
grades took a rapid decline it wasn't
long before he was failing his classes
bad enough to not make the cut to
continue on at school but as much as it
upset his mother Holden really didn't
mind he was already thinking Way Beyond
high school and he knew he didn't need
grades to be able to do the one thing he
wanted to do with his life Holden set up
his own Channel with the plan to start
uploading videos under his new online
alter Eco and before long hell holder 98
was born he centered his whole internet
Persona around lost media discussing
which popular rumors were true and which
were fictionalized for likes and clicks
it started out with a few discussion
videos where he would simply sit in his
bedroom a camcorder opposite to him as
he spoke but before long holding was
adding more and more Flair to his
content learning how to edit on his
computer adding Clips or screenshots he
could find of supposed Lost TV episodes
to give his videos some credibility a
very necessary quality when trying to
determine if certain things were real or
not each video he finished he had
another two topics to a list of ideas he
kept planning to just perpetually churn
out content until he eventually had a
huge hit that went viral although the
one thing he didn't realize until it was
perhaps too late was that social media
success didn't happen overnight in fact
it didn't happen over many many nights
either no matter how often Holden
promoted his channel on his social media
profiles or how many new videos he
uploaded he couldn't seem to get any to
land well and get boosted by the
algorithm at least that's one of the
things he attributed the problem to he
pointed the finger of blame at anything
that he could one day it was that the
algorithm was suppressing his channel
and boosting others who had already got
more subscribers the next in my be his
slow internet connection had led to one
of his videos going live at a time when
the site had low traffic the one
possibility that Holden didn't stop to
consider was that maybe his genre of
content was too Niche but that the days
of the internet's interest in Lost media
had already peaked back when he was
still in high school nevertheless he
kept trying making content day in and
day out working under the assumption
that if he just made enough videos then
one day he was sure to blow up that
would be his big break his ultimate win
a video that did well enough to Garner
thousands if not millions of views but
the more time he devoted to Hell holder
98 the only number that seemed to be at
all increasing was the number of videos
he had posted each one barely garnering
view figures that were above a single
digit to make matters worse getting help
with growing his online brand was next
to Impossible every now and then he
would post on forms asking for advice or
if anyone wanted to collaborate so he
could gain some exposure from creators
with bigger follow
those posts were often met with a slew
of apathetic snide responses or comments
telling Holden 2 just quote make better
content as if that was solid specific
advice on top of that his mom had
outright refused to support her son's
chosen career path citing his failure at
school as the main reason speaking of
any friends Holden previously had at
school had all moved away in the years
since going off to pursue college and
other higher education some were even
starting their new and exciting
professions the old saying said it's
Lonely at the Top but Holden was just as
lonely down at the bottom posting his
content in total obscurity as if he was
just shouting into an empty void with no
one around to hear the few people Holden
did still consider his friends were all
as chronically online as he was most of
them fellow lost media collectors after
interacting with them in the common
threads of various forums the handful of
like-minded guys were as close as Holden
had to people actively supporting his
channel the collectors would usually
give him pointers or topics to discuss
in videos and contributing to the single
digit view count underneath his uploads
although to him it wasn't nearly enough
he didn't want just his friends to see
his videos he wanted an audience a fan
base of his own it was late the light of
the computer monitor Illuminating the
dark of Holden's bedroom hunched over
his desk he was clicking and dragging
clips into the timeline of a video
project trimming them down to make the
whole thing better paced snipping out
bad takes where he stumbled over his
words or misspoke it was while editing
that Holden noticed another screen
lighting up on his desk accompanied by a
vibration his phone he reached for it
seeing a notification popped up on the
lock screen it was from gov one of the
Lost media collectors and it read dude
urgent found something that you can make
a video on hold inside it was late it
was already focused on editing this
current video tonight if you got it
finished then he could go to sleep what
do you know about the deathly videotape
goth asked in a second message before
Holden even had a chance to open it
first the what he replied bluntly before
sending another text saying can't this
wait until the morning I'm trying to
edit if you don't act fast it'll be gone
forever came the response only a second
later followed by a link lethargically
hold and tap the hyperlink oath had sent
his phone opening up its browser and
displaying the web page it was a buy and
sell website one of those places where
people offloaded junk they didn't want
any more to strangers for a bit of extra
cash the page in question showed a few
grainy photos taken on a phone of a
small rectangular object in someone's
hand what is that Holden asked it's a
videotape bonehead both fired back
although they'd never met in person
Holden always cut the sense his friend
was a little older than he was looking
back on the seller's ad it was for a
secondhand Sony color collection 60 to
90 minute mini DV videotape a type of
cassette used in a lot of old handheld
recording cameras so what holdenast in
another text look there have been rumors
for Aegis about something called The
Deathly videotape growth replied in a
series of Rapid Fire messages it used to
be all the rage on a lot of old lost
media forums the real nasty ones before
they got shut down supposedly there's a
recording on this tape of some kind of
live show except when you put in your
VCR and press play you see something
horrible nobody even knows if it's real
or just a legend how do you know this is
the same tape Holden queried by now he
had typed out the same link on his
computer and was looking at the for sale
page on the bigger screen while he
texted back and forth with goth read the
item description he answered Holden's
eyes scanned down the page finding a
short message from the seller to anyone
interested I'm giving this old Mini DV
tape away I don't know where I got it or
why I watched it but I wish I hadn't it
had ruined everything for me it's
impossible to enjoy anything else now
that I've seen what's on it let me make
this clear I am not selling this tape
I'm giving it away free of charge I hope
that getting rid of it will help sounds
ominous Holden texted if you're so sure
if this is the deathly videotape then
why don't you get it keep reading goeth
responded underneath the item
description was another note that the
seller had written please note I am
unable to leave my town at present nor
can I mail this tape to anyone even if
you pay postage collection only if
you're interested please contact me at
the following address below was an
address it was in Holden's Hometown only
a few streets away from where he and his
mom lived this could be it dude came
another slew of messages from Ghost you
buy this tape and make a video recording
then you might finally go viral but you
better be quick before someone goes and
picks it up thinking it's just an
ordinary tape Holden looks back at the
address double checking where it was at
most it'd take a quick walk there and
back he thought and if this tape was as
elusive as ghost said it was then owning
it would mean Holden would be the only
one who could make a video featuring it
after messaging the seller the night
before Holden found himself rushing
through his quiet neighborhood to the
address all night as he tried to sleep
he kept thinking of the video he was
going to make how he could finally put
him on the map and at long last bring
him the e-fame he'd been working towards
wrapping his knuckles against the front
door he was met by an older man who
stood on the other side he was walking
with a crutch with a few bruises and
stitched up cuts on his face the second
that Holden explained he was there for
the tape the man reached to an unseen
shelf just inside the door frame and
thrust the rectangular cassette into his
hands before shutting the door as
quickly as he could without it hitting
Holden Square in the face he stared at
the tape in his hands though through its
transparent green plastic case he could
see a hand scrawled note I know you'll
ignore me if I tell you not to watch
this it read so if you do then on your
own head be it having spent the rest of
the day looking up exactly what he'd
need to play such an old outmoded
recording format and convert the footage
to digital so he could include it in his
video Holden had retrieved his mom's old
VHS player from the attic wiping the
thick layer of dust off of it it's a
took a while for him to get everything
ready to go not just finding the right
adapters and cables to hook the VCR up
to his TV as well as linking that to his
computer plus angling his camera right
and making sure the ring light he bought
for filming was putting enough focus on
his face after the substantial prep
Holden took a deep breath summoning up
the faux excitement and Stage smile
before he hit the record button on his
camera what's up guys it's hell holder98
here now today I've got a real treat for
you all so my friend gov shout out to
him told me that a while ago there was
talk about something called The Deathly
videotape we found a mini DV tape that
we think might be that very same tape so
we're gonna watch it and see if it's
legit dropping his Persona as his face
turned away from the camera Holden
punched the play button on the VHS
player his eyes glued to the TV screen
as the camera's lens was fixated on him
okay nothing so far he observed met with
nothing but a blank black screen
suddenly after 12 seconds of nothing the
playback started instantly and home
golden started relaying what he was
seeing on the tape to the camera there
was no sound either because the
recording on the videotape was filmed
that way or Holden hadn't properly
figured out how to hook it up to the VHS
the video itself showed a recording of
Sesame Street Live and for the most part
just seemed pretty underwhelming
characters were up on stage their
puppeteers managing to stay out of sight
as they entertained their young audience
after two and a half minutes Holden was
starting to feel like he'd gone to all
this effort over what seemed to just be
someone's old unwanted home video just
as he was considering turning off the
camera and throwing the videotape in the
trash at almost the three minute Mark
something weird started happening on the
stage the actor playing one of the
bigger characters seemed to be having
some trouble instantly trying to pull
off his cumbersome costume much to the
distress of the kids in the audience
looking on in horror but it wasn't just
the illusion that had been broken the
actor was trying to get out of his
costume because he was choking he
dropped to his knees on stage clawing on
his own throat before Finally Falling
face down totally still asphyxiated dead
over the next almost 20 seconds the same
thing started happening to another three
of the characters on stage all of them
violently choking while the children in
the audience screamed and cried silently
on the inaudible tape then at three and
a half minutes the video cut out Holden
was unsure how to react at first a
little creeped out only to be somewhat
bemused he played it down for the camera
remarking that the video seemed tame
compared to some of the more graphic
fake content he'd seen but the whole
time even after rapping recording
sitting awake all night to edit his
reaction video blurring out the parts
that would break the terms of service he
had no idea what he'd seen was actually
real or not finishing the final edit
just as the sun was coming up Holden hit
upload and crawled into bed while his
video was uploaded the buzz of a text
message from goth awoke him dude I told
you this video was going to make it big
without even replying Holden booted up
his computer and opened the page for his
newly uploaded video The View count was
already in the thousands and climbing
comments pouring in underneath mostly
from people debating whether or not the
contents of the tape had been faked
Holden punched the air and excitement
he'd finally done it but as the video
kept playing he heard a wretching sound
coming from the computer's speakers he
turned to look back at his earlier self
filmed only the night before except what
he was seeing play out on screen now
wasn't what he remembered happening last
night it couldn't have because the
Holden in that video was choking that
wasn't possible he was alive and
watching his own video right now but
somehow the footage was shown him dying
his Airway blocked face turning red then
blue was tears streamed down his cheeks
in the video hell holder 98 fell down
dead from asphyxiation and watching it
made Holden feel sick to make matters
worse none of the comments under the
video seemed to have witnessed the same
ending Holden even texted oath to ask if
the same thing had happened but he
described the ending exactly as Holden
remembered filming it but afterwards it
didn't stop happening everything he
watched ended the same every clip online
every TV show every movie Holden
couldn't even read a book without some
characters fictional or otherwise
Keeling over and choking to death just
like the characters on the tape he
barely had time to acknowledge the hits
his reaction to the deathly videotape
we're getting he was too busy trying to
figure out why he couldn't stop seeing
people dying the exact same way even
himself when he watched back his old
hellholder 98 videos reacting to the
deathly videotape garnered a respectable
3 million views but hellholder 98 never
uploaded again afterwards his channel
went silent remembered only as a one-hit
wonder until the video and the entire
Channel were taken down Holden was never
reported missing the foundation made
sure of that when they came by to
collect scp-583 and place the videotape
into contain
an elderly woman watches from her living
room window as heavy Sheets of Rain Fall
outside she rocks back and forth in her
chair nervously it's been raining for
days the road is washed out I can't get
into town but what am I to do what am I
to do she says out loud to herself the
rocking chair creaks under her weight
but not as much as it had three days ago
before she ran out of food I am so
hungry the old lady moans she glances at
the door that leads to her basement
maybe I can find something to eat down
there she stands up her 90 year old
bones Creak as she slowly shuffles
towards the basement door the empty
chair rocks back and forth from the old
woman's momentum as if someone is still
sitting in it she opens the door and
looks into the pitch black darkness
there are no windows down there the only
light is connected to a drawstring in
the middle of the room the old woman
slowly makes her way down the uneven
wooden steps when she reaches the bottom
she reaches out her wrinkled hand
groping in the darkness for the
drawstring her hand brushes something it
feels like sticky yarn then she feels
the legs of a spider Scurry up her arm
the old woman lets out a shriek as her
hand locates the string and she pulls
hard the light flickers on it creates a
dim glow but at least she can now see
what's in the basement the string swings
back and forth casting a snake-like
shadow on the far wall the old woman
scans the floor for anything to eat a
leftover tuna can some pickled
vegetables a wrap anything we'll do at
this point there is nothing there the
old woman feels her strength has been
almost completely drained she doesn't
know how she'll make it back up the
stairs in desperation she looks around
the basement One Last Time her eyes fall
on an old rusty saw she pauses for a
moment I need to eat she Whispers The
Old Woman slowly walks towards the saw
she picks it up and examines it God gave
me two hands for a reason she says her
eyes locked on the rusty blade she
places one hand on the wooden workbench
that sits against the wall and grips the
saw tightly with the other the old woman
takes a deep breath and brings the saw
down towards her hand where are we going
d-94322 asks the SCP agent driving the
car house on Hadley Hill the agent
responds wow that doesn't sound creepy
at all d-94322 says as he cranes his
neck to get a glimpse of the top of the
mountain through the SUV window why
don't we just play the quiet game until
we get there the agent says as he
focuses on the pothole-ridden back roads
of Mount Zion Georgia
d-94322 holds on tightly to the handhold
above him to keep his body from slamming
into the door every time they go over a
big bump they continue on for a few more
minutes when a rundown house comes into
view the agent pulls off the road and
stops the SUV here you go he says
handing d-94322 an earpiece what am I
supposed to do with this
d-94322 asks just stick it in your ear
the agent says with just a little
contempt in his voice you don't have to
be rude about it d-94322 replies as he
grabs the earbud and sticks it in his
ear hello testing anybody out there
hello d-94322 can you hear me says a
voice in his head ah yeah you can just
call me d-94 for sure d94322 is kind of
a mouthful very well the voice from the
earbud agrees my name is Dr Andrews I
will be walking you through this test
with
scp-4173 alright doc shall we get this
party started d94 says as he steps out
of the SUV he looks up at the house that
sits atop Hadley Hill the sky is dark
and clouds race over the mountain as if
they would rather be anywhere else but
here here we go d94 starts walking up
the slippery Hill being careful not to
fall he reaches the overgrown walkway
leading up to the house and pauses is
there a problem Dr Andrews asks now just
try to psych myself up to go into this
creepy House response d94 what's inside
anyways that is not your concern at the
moment but if you do exactly as I tell
you you should be in and out in no time
whatever you say Doc d94 walks down the
path reaches his hand out and grips the
cool brass knob he turns it and pushes
the door open the inside of the house
smells like mothballs and decay all
right I'm in he says good head down the
hallway and turned to your left you'll
see a door that leads to the basement
let me know when you're there d94 walks
down the hallway the old wooden floor
groans under his feet he reaches the
basement door it's slightly ajar this
place gives me the creeps rightfully so
Dr Andrews chimes in it is an old spooky
house on top of an old spooky Hill in
the middle of nowhere obviously it's
going to be creepy an old woman died
here under mysterious circumstances
around 20 years ago but you don't really
need to worry about that no ghosts here
I think you think d-94 shots as he takes
a step away from the basement door
I'm just kidding there's nothing but
harmless old
scp-4173 in that house and when has an
SCP ever heard anyone right there is a
long uncomfortable pause
anyways why don't you head on downstairs
so we can get you out of there as soon
as possible yeah sure d-94 says as he
begins his descent into the darkness I
can't see anything is there a light no I
think it burnt out years ago but that's
okay I can guide you it's what I'm here
for says Dr Andrews walk towards the
East wall but watch your head the
ceiling is low in that corner you'll see
what you're looking for when you get
there d94 is silent for a moment East he
asks turn left Dr Andrew's response oh
all right why didn't you say so doc d94
turns left and walks forward after a few
feet there's a loud bang as he slams his
head into the ceiling
of a I told you to watch your head
yeah thanks says d94 as he rubs the bump
forming beneath his hair this place is
even spookier than the first floor you
know that right I promise there's
nothing in that room right now that can
hurt you Dr Andrews reassures d94 wait
what do you mean right now don't worry
about it just let me know when you reach
the wall d94 after a few seconds d94's
eyes adjust to the darkness he can just
make out the damp concrete wall in front
of him it looks as if the wall is
perspiring I'm here he says good there's
a little door maybe five feet to your
left you see it asks Dr Andrews d-94
turns yeah I I see it it's closed the
door itself is not very big maybe a foot
long and a half a foot wide open it says
Dr Andrew d-94 hesitates what what's in
there nothing just open it Dr Andrews
repeats himself no no way man you're
lying and I'm not opening anything until
you tell me what's on the other side of
that door Dr Andrew's size we both know
that you're going to do as I say d94322
you have no other choice unless you want
to go back to that death row cell block
where we found you d94 shakes his head
and rubs the bridge of his nose fine
fine he says Dr Andrews can hear the
squeaking of hinges through the
microphone on d94's earbud it's open now
what do you see anything
ah no there's some cobwebs and dirt but
other than that it's just dark d94
thinks for a moment why is this little
door here is this some like pet door or
something you have to be I don't know
pretty small to get in there agreed just
hang tight and let me know when you hear
something we won't keep you there for
long here's something like like what
asks d94 you'll know when you hear it
says Dr Andrews five minutes go by
without a sound then 10 15. the basement
is damp and Cold d94 theme CC's
creatures scurrying around the floor but
he doesn't say anything because
acknowledging them makes his situation
more real and a lot more scary after a
half hour of waiting in silence d94
screams what the heck was that what was
what Dr Andrews is startled out of a
Daydream by the show ounce of d94 in his
ear something just moved past the door I
definitely saw what in God's name was
that yes d94 Dr Andrews tries to remain
calm but he can barely contain his
excitement the entity in the wall is why
you're down there what do you mean you
said there wasn't anything down here I
said there was nothing down there that
could hurt you if you follow my
instructions this will continue to be
true can you hear anything asks Dr
Andrews no I can't hear it but before
d94 can finish his sentence a voice
speaks from behind the wall he can't
understand what the voice is saying at
first but as his heart begins to slow
and the blood stops thumping in his ears
d-94 can make out her words oh thank
goodness I wasn't sure you would be able
to find me what took you so long says
the voice of an old woman d94 takes a
step back from the door there's someone
on the other side of that wall he hisses
into the microphone at Dr Andrews tell
it that the road is out and you had to
find an other way up says Dr Andrews in
d94's earpiece what why just do it if
you want to get out of there d94 Dr
Andrew says a little impatiently ah the
the road is out so I had to find another
way up says d94 to the little open door
on the wall oh yes the rain washed it
out I was worried I wouldn't ever get to
see another person again being stuck up
here and all
can you see me asks the voice
um no I I can't says d94 doc what is on
the other side of that wall come over
here a little closer I I can't see you
properly either says the voice it's fine
you can get closer just don't touch the
door Dr Andrews says I really don't want
to do that it says d94 do it and you
will be that much closer to getting out
I hate you whispersd94 he slowly
approaches The Little Door and speaks
into it hello oh there you are the voice
pauses as if whoever's speaking is
examining d94 I'm sorry I can't see like
I used to all right so dark in here and
it's been so long reach through the door
and let me feel your hands where I can
tell you're really there
what d94 steps away from the door no way
am I putting my hand in there come on
now don't be rude I just want to feel
that you're there it's been so long just
just a touch the voice says a little
harsher than before
grew you lady I'm not getting my hands
anywhere near This creepy hole in the
wall it says d94 he turns around and
starts walking away from The Little Door
towards the staircase leading back to
the main level of the house before he
can put his foot on the first step d-94
hears Dr Andrew's voice screaming in his
ear stop moving look you're going to
have to do it we haven't been able to
recover anyone who refuses to do what
she asks I cannot guarantee your safety
unless you put your hand through that
door are you kidding me shouts d94
you're telling me that sweet creepy old
lady will somehow kill me if I don't do
what she asks we're not entirely sure
what happens but you need to put your
hand through that door if you want to
get out of there says Dr Andrews d-94
turns back toward the little door and
slowly approaches it this is my
nightmare he says more to himself than
anyone else he reaches out slowly and
puts his fingers through the doorway he
immediately pulls them back and steps
away from the door ah I I really don't
want to do this d94 Whispers he steps
forward again and sticks his hand all
the way through the doorway for a moment
nothing happens ah all right I've got my
hand in there now what oh I can chew now
you're right there thank you for coming
oh it's been so long since someone came
and with a gift as well oh sweet ling
you're so kind so kind to me gift
what gift d94 asks nervously it's so
dark and Lonesome and I've just been so
hungry for such a long time thank you
sweetling I'll take your gift from you
you are such a rude little brat you
don't really deserve it you've had it
for too long and you don't deserve it
it's mine now mine for my belly thank
you what are you talking about you
psycho d94 stutters suddenly something
grabs his hand and pulls him against the
wall he screams in agony as Dr Andrews
hears a wet ripping sound coming through
the microphone it sounds as if some type
of metal instrument is cutting through
flesh oh God no help me help me d94
screams please please please Dr Andrews
hears the sound of d94's body hitting
the floor as he passes out it's quiet
for a moment don't worry you ungrateful
child don't worry I'll fill you up too
you can have mine I'll give it to you
sweet boy good boy fill you up says the
old woman's voice from the other side of
the wall Dr Andrews listens as the
hinges of The Little Door squeak and it
click shut he picks up the phone next to
him and Dows it go in and get him bring
him back to site 94 for observation and
try to keep this one alive please he
hangs up the phone and prepares the lab
for d-94322 to be brought in d94 slowly
comes out of his medically induced coma
two days after the incident with
scp-4173 he's stable but doesn't feel
great and he can't help but sense that
something is different d94 looks at
where his hands should be there's
nothing there that crazy old lady ate my
hand he starts screaming a medical team
rushes in as red lights begin to flash
and Sirens Blair they attempt to
restrain d94 during the struggle d94
catches a glimpse of himself in a mirror
on the far side of the room he stops
fighting for a moment there is a growth
expanding from his head what the heck is
that he yells pointing to his reflection
d94 begins to struggle again this time
much more intensely he begins scratching
at the growth on the side of his head
without much success in the process he
pushes the growth further into his skull
it penetrates his brain d-94 blacks out
the medical team ties d-94 to the bed
and tries to get a reading on his vitals
the growth is putting too much pressure
on his brain they Rush him to the ER but
d-94322 dies before he reaches the
operating table Dr Andrew stands over
the body of the deceased class D subject
cut him open he says to the doctor
standing in the room one of them pulls
out a scalpel and makes an incision into
the side of d94's head what is that one
of the doctors says the other bends over
to get a better look after a moment he
turns away and vomits into his face mask
Dr Andrews picks up a pair of forceps
off the table he sticks them deep into
the hole in the side of d-94's head and
clamps down hard Dr Andrew pulls out a
decomposing hand the fingers are still
moving as if trying to grab onto
something there's no explanation for how
it got in there but it is obvious that
scp-4173 played some sort of role in the
phenomenon Dr Andrews goes back into his
office to review previous Case Files on
scp-4173 everyone who had put their hand
into the small doorway has been pulled
towards the wall and had their hand
chopped off the severed appendage never
ends up being a clean cut which leads Dr
Andrews to hypothesize the gruesome
makeshift operation is done with some
sort of tool with teeth once the hand of
the victim is severed
scp-4173 always thanks the person for
their gift she then informs them not to
worry about their hand as it will be
replaced but then something incredibly
strange happens like with d94 a decaying
hand will appear somewhere in the body
but it isn't always inside the head in
fact depending on how polite the test
subject is to the old one woman behind
the door the closer to the wrist the
decaying hand actually ends up for the
test subjects who are rude to the old
lady the decaying hand ends up in some
pretty interesting places she really
hated d-94322 Chuckles Dr Andrews to
himself Dr Andrews continues flipping to
the back of the file on
scp-4173 the SCP Foundation doesn't
quite know how it happens but people who
refuse to offer their hand to scp-4173
suffer a worse fate than those who
surrender to the old lady in every case
where a subject tries to get away from
the small door some inexplicable Force
seems to grab them from behind and drag
them through the tiny opening in these
cases there is nothing left of the test
subject it is likely fatal as a human is
much smaller than the opening itself so
the only way a body could fit through
the doorway is if every bone is broken
and every muscle compressed to a quarter
of its actual size I'm not sure which is
worse Dr Andrews says aloud as he closes
the file on
scp-4173 he glances at the picture paper
clip to the front of the manila folder
depicting the tiny doorway he can't
quite pinpoint why but the fact that the
door slowly closes after the old woman
gets what she needs from her victims
sends chills down his spine the words of
the old woman echo in his head don't
worry I'll fill you up too you can have
mine I'll give it to you sweet boy good
boy fill you up morality tends to get
lost very quickly when you start working
at the SCP Foundation during the
Whirlwind of basic training site
orientation and learning the difference
between Euclid ketter and formula object
classes you'll have to make peace with
the fact that as a new member of
foundation staff you'll probably end up
having to turn a blind eye to doing some
morally compromising things then again
it's such a normal everyday Occurrence
at the foundation that almost everyone
working for them is desensitized to
whatever ethically dubious or downright
violent tasks they have to partake in
and at the end of the day everyone knows
that it's all for the greater good to
keep anomalies securely in containment
for the benefit and protection of
humanity but the one part of foundation
life that Simon Bennett just couldn't
reason with was the very existence of
d-class personnel now anyone with
previous knowledge of the SCP
foundation's dubious practices will of
course be aware of d-class but do Simon
who had just been recruited as a member
of site security Personnel the whole
concept was not only alien but
completely abhorrent d-class personnel
as he'd come to learn were completely
Expendable their ranks were filled with
convicted felons almost all of them
guilty of violent crimes the foundation
seemed to have a habit of plucking
inmates from the highest security
prisons and penitentiaries in the world
covering their tracks by staging the
deaths of these unwilling recruits into
d-class from there these criminals were
essentially used as little more than
human Lab Rats and it was this part that
really didn't sit well with Simon the
very idea left him torn on the one hand
d-class were arguably the worst of the
worst most if not all of them were
guilty of horrific and brutal crimes
some that could never be forgiven by
anyone but on the other Simon struggled
to rationalize taking these prisoners
from their incarceration only to subject
them to anomalous creatures and entities
most scps could do things to a d-class
that were almost as bad as what these
convicts had done to their victims and
some could Dole out far far worse Fates
did their actions make their cruel
faiths justifiable did d-class Personnel
deserve the amount of punishment for
their crimes Simon didn't know it was a
perplexing moral conundrum most days at
the foundation those questions echoed
around his head he was probably better
suited to a role in the Ethics Committee
than Rank and file security he was
uncertain if it was better to leave a
violent murderer to serve their sentence
in prison until their eventual execution
or abduct them and use them as a d-class
guinea pig it wasn't long before his
fellow security officers tried to
dissuade Simon from questioning the
foundation's methods reminding him how
lucky he was to be selected to join them
and how an easy application of amnestics
could take that all away leaving him not
only jobless but his memory wiped as
well ultimately as weeks turned into
months then became years in the blink of
an eye security officer Bennett's moral
compass was ground down he started
getting used to the idea of the
foundation's way of doing things asking
fewer and fewer questions to oppose how
morally and ethically ambiguous a lot of
their experiments and procedures were
obedience to others slowly became apathy
and the Simon that had once been
concerned with the ethics of d-class
experimentation soon began looking at
them as Expendable assets just like the
rest of the SCP Foundation did he even
started to resent a few of them that
seemed to have gotten off easy on a few
occasions a member of d-class personnel
got to interact with the friendly kind
of anomaly it didn't seem fair Simon
thought that while he and the other
security Personnel had to put their
lives on the line whenever a dangerous
SCP breach containment meanwhile a
d-class who might have been a multiple
murderer or domestic terrorist got to
sit in a testing chamber with a friendly
entity like scp-999 the Tickle Monster
keeping up to date with the special
containment procedures for the various
anomalous objects and beings held at the
foundation was an essential part of a
security officer's job ongoing testing
and new discoveries that were about an
entity often led to them needing new
updated measures to keep them securely
contained but it was during a routine
check of these procedures that Simon
came across something strange well maybe
not so strange when you work at the SCP
Foundation but definitely a noticeable
level of strangeness reading through the
containment procedures for one of the
anomalies housed at the site Simon found
a list of instructions fairly standard
stuff for the foundation the strange
part was that he was sure that he had
never read this list before but at the
same time it wasn't a new update
recently added to an entry in the SCP
archive it was paradoxically brand new
information a detailed description of
containment measures yet also seemingly
something that had been written and
archived ages ago reading through the
instructions they described a process
that was essential to keeping one of the
site's anomalies secure it had even been
given its own name the special
containment procedures referring to the
whole practice as a monthly termination
the more that Simon read his eyes would
widen further as he learned exactly what
the steps of this process entailed in
his earlier days he wouldn't have
thought of this so-called monthly
termination as excessive a needlessly
cruel act even by the standards of the
SCP Foundation but that was the old
Simon a man who hadn't yet become Jaded
by his work before he had come to adopt
the same apathy and disregard for life
as his fellow Foundation Personnel
reaching the end of the passage
describing monthly termination Simon
alerted the other security officers
making sure they read the procedure too
some unknown feelings stirred deep
within Simon telling him this needed to
be carried out and it had to happen
right now before long members of staff
had been told to read the entry monthly
termination each one passing it on to
their colleagues then Simon and a large
Detachment of other guards began
marching towards the cell blocks where
d-class Personnel were imprisoned almost
a third of the site's incarcerated
inmates were rounded up it couldn't have
been any more than a few hundred Simon
wasn't sure he couldn't see all of them
from where he was standing but mostly he
didn't care all he could focus on was
following the monthly termination
procedure to the letter together he and
the security Detachment escorted the
collected d-class Personnel through the
facility single file all Marching In
efficient and perfectly synchronized
motion it was almost like a
choreographed military display if he
hadn't been so preoccupied with thinking
only of the procedure Simon might have
realized how strange all this was all
the Personnel were moving at once in
such Flawless timing even though this
hadn't been planned in advance and yet
he and the other Personnel had only just
learned about monthly termination and
yet they were carrying it out as if they
had done it a thousand times before the
security officers continued ferrying the
d-classes through the facility
eventually leading the convicted felons
to the main entrance the doors were
opened without question nobody who had
read the monthly termination
instructions saw what was going on as
anything out of the ordinary a long
winding row of inmates in Foundation
issue orange jumpsuits were then guided
out of the site's main doors instructed
by the security to keep walking even
further none of them knew how far they'd
really walked a lot of d-class personnel
complained and moaned but the few that
tried to leave the single file lines
were quickly put back in place by the
security department most of them were
directly verbally aggressive cursing and
threatening the security officers but
they seemed compliant walking the way
they were told to it was as if they had
to obey almost like their legs wouldn't
let them resist one begged to be let go
turning to Simon and pleading not to be
taken wherever it was they were going
I'm sorry Simon replied plainly with
barely any emotion behind his words it
was a lie he didn't feel sorry in fact
he hadn't even been sure why he
apologized at all the reply had happened
almost unnaturally like something else
was speaking through him he wasn't even
sure how far away they'd gotten from the
facility it might have felt like miles
if he hadn't been thinking about it but
he wasn't none of the officers were they
were following their instructions
totally unaware that they'd been walking
for so long that they were starting to
get blisters they all somehow knew they
had gotten far enough beyond the reach
and sight of the foundation facility
they started in so far in fact that the
surveillance systems wouldn't be able to
see them still moving with the same
complete synchronous timing Simon and
the other security officers herded the
d-class Personnel towards a wooded
clearing they formed a ring around the
inmates before pushing them down onto
their knees a few of them hung their
heads some even shedding a tear they had
already figured out what was about to
happen those that had him quickly caught
up when they saw the security officers
covering or deactivating their head
cameras then reaching for their
when they returned to the facility Simon
and the other officers would all give
the same story they collectively led a
third of the science d-class to an area
out of surveillance range and executed
them all with their handguns at least
that's how they all remembered the
incident but what they thought they'd
done didn't quite match what had
actually happened naturally the
foundation higher-ups quickly got wind
of what happened and of such a massive
expenditure of their Expendable d-class
resources the incident forced the SCP
Foundation to launch a full-blown
investigation into the actions of Simon
the other security officers and
additional Personnel on site they
quickly recognized the pattern of
behavior they had seen it before they
already knew not one of the guards had
actually fired their weapons in fact
none of them had been acting of their
own free will Simon and the others had
no idea that the monthly termination
procedure didn't exist in the
foundation's records and was actually
the symptom of an
scp-2193 event all those d-class that
had been rounded up and marched out into
the middle of nowhere were still gone
though not shot Point Blank like the
officers thought but the prisoners were
still no longer alive either although
he'd never remember it when Simon had
been stood amongst his fellow officers
one of the d-class had begun floating
upwards lifted off the ground by some
invisible force the convicted felon
drifted about three meters in the air
without warning The Prisoner was then
launched up practically fired towards
the sky like a rocket traveling into the
upper atmosphere at several times the
speed of sound one by one the members of
d-class All Began experiencing the same
thing floating off the ground only to be
catapulted up into the stratosphere with
such speed and force that they vanish
from view in seconds meanwhile all Simon
and the other security officers did was
stand by and watch keeping their head
cams covered or Switched Off The Last of
the d-class prisoners stood in the
clearing the one that had asked Simon to
be set free he was still asking begging
to be helped down as his feet were
hoisted up against his will practically
screaming for someone anyone to do
something his eyes locked with Simons
for a split second before he too was
sent hurtling into the sky moving that
high in that fast isn't something a
human being is at all likely to survive
now rid of the d-class that they had led
to their deaths all the gathered
security Personnel looked up it was
night Starlight cast across an Inky
canvas of dark sky but Simon was fixated
on the moon they all were none of them
could take their eyes off it as it
slowly appeared to Blink like a watchful
eye hanging in the space above them not
one of them would remember what they had
seen or what they had truly done no
member of d-class was a saint it's true
they were murderers criminals and
dangerous individuals maybe some of them
were so bad that they did deserve to be
used as test subjects to dye the hands
of anomalous entities but then again
does anyone really deserve to go out
like that little is known about the
point of origin of scp-2193 while it
affects the documents stored within the
foundation's database it does not
function like a computer virus or
artificial intelligence instead
scp-2193-1 is an anomalous piece of
information or an info Hazard as scps
like this are known it has been known to
infect digital files specifically the
special containment procedures for
various entities objects and creatures
that the foundation has recorded in its
archives even their most talented
computer engineers and anomalous
researchers cannot determine how this
info Hazard is able to accomplish this
it seems to infect files at random
without any repeating pattern in its
timing or the type of SCP files it
appears in upon infection a file now
containing
scp-2193-1 will include references to a
monthly termination of d-class personnel
making it as an essential process for
keeping an anomaly secure anyone that
reads this suffers from what is known as
a memetic effect essentially they will
believe what they have read and believe
that they have always been aware of this
information on top of that a person
infected by a CP 2193-1 will accept it
as true that the monthly termination is
a legitimate and accepted practice
within the SCP Foundation they can't be
convinced that killing hundreds of
d-class personnel is anything less than
justify now you might be forgiven for
thinking that uninfected Personnel can
easily explain to those who have been
affected by a cp2193-1 that the monthly
termination isn't an official Foundation
policy but this info Hazard has proven
itself to be particularly infectious
when spreading its memetic influence any
member of foundation Personnel not yet
exposed to
scp-2193-1 can be easily convinced that
the monthly termination is both morally
acceptable and a foundation held
procedure that is absolutely necessary
for anomaly containment if anyone that
has read and therefore believes the
monthly termination process the and they
will display a lack of cognitive
dissonance whenever someone attempts to
present them with information that
conflicts with
scp-2193-1 while no document within
their internal database has a record of
the monthly termination procedure back
in January of 1999 the foundation was
able to witness the process second hand
via one of its agents during an scp-2193
event agent yassan's head camera was
left uncovered recording excerpts of the
precise and perfectly choreographed
execution of numerous d-class Personnel
much like the event Simon was a part of
an unknown anomaly caused the Earth's
moon to appear to Blink It is believed
by some within the foundation that this
is the result of a form of Eldritch
entity a being that demands a
substantial Human Sacrifice every month
this being as of yet remains
unidentified just as unclear is this
anomaly's intentions motives or how it
is able to affect or perhaps use the
moon of course the SCP Foundation has
its own Personnel stationed up there
however during recorded instances of
scp-2193 events their agents at Luna
area 32 have reported no unusual
activity or abnormalities at the
corresponding times the running Theory
among some Personnel is that the moon
isn't this unidentified being's actual
eye but some kind of ocular device like
a spyglass that allows it to observe the
monthly termination whatever this being
is it apparently possesses an immense
level of power how exactly it is able to
create
scp-2193-1 and infiltrate the
foundation's internal database with that
info Hazard is still unknown as is the
exact reason why it goes to such trouble
such incalculable lengths seemingly just
for the purpose of killing so many
d-class inmates the immediate assumption
albeit admittedly amorbid and cynical
one held by most Foundation researchers
studying scp-2193 is that this entity
needs this almost ritualistic monthly
sacrifice in order to sustain itself
what idea suggests it could be a
creature that opposes how the foundation
uses its d-class Personnel maybe it just
like Simon used to questions the
morality of convicts being used as
Expendable guinea pigs and as such it
uses its Eldritch levels of power to
remove them from the foundation's reach
for good or perhaps despite its
subterfuge this being feeds on those who
have wronged others making d-class
Personnel Prime candidates that would
certainly explain why the monthly
termination procedure causes security
officers to only bring the foundation's
force of expendable convicts and after
all there are benevolent scps out there
even friendly ones so it stands to
reason that this being could be trying
to rid the world of people who are bad
enough to be put into d-class but then
again this world is rarely so kind
scp-2193-1 makes Foundation officers
bring D classes out to where they can't
be seen causing them to cover their head
cameras and believe a phony story about
execution by sidearm so nobody knows
what really happens to them it even
hides the info Hazard detailing the
monthly termination procedures at random
moving it around to a new file whenever
it's detected such great effort is taken
by this entity to cover its tracks which
would suggest a far more nefarious goal
it is entirely possible that this being
does all this simply to amuse itself
expending countless lives and Foundation
resources purely for a sick sadistic
form of entertainment with no way of
knowing the entity's true intention the
SCP Foundation can only sit and
vigilantly wait an artificial
intelligence surveying their database
for the next instance of
scp-2193 call them what you will be it
myths urban legends ghost stories or
just full Yarns the fact is we've all
heard at least one traditionally stories
like that were just shared around a
campfire but nowadays they have ended up
spreading far and wide across internet
message boards and creepy threads
everything ranging from unsolved missing
persons cases actually being the result
of alien abductions to haunted videos
carrying an unforgiving curse or some
missing unaired episode of popular TV
shows that had somehow been Unearthed by
an online sleuth we're always quick to
share these ideas these stories but deep
down a part of us knows that there's no
truth to to them Urban myths are
speculation that someone has turned into
A Tale of Terror for nothing more than
to give some quick scares to whoever
they tell it to but then that person
passes that tail on to someone else and
suddenly the story had become a
widespread Legend with no discernible
point of origin sure they might still be
fictional but through sharing these
stories we as humans bring them to life
not literally of course that would be
outlandish after all when was the last
time you heard of a fictional story
becoming reality growing up with
exposure and unfiltered access to the
internet in the late 2000s Paul Jacobs
and his friends had been fascinated with
and admittedly pretty terrified by the
notorious legend of the Slenderman it
began as whisperings in an online Forum
a story that was intentionally designed
to be a modern day Urban myth and just
like so many others before it the myths
spread what had started as a Forum post
became unnerving photoshopped images of
a tall faceless figure in a suit lurking
in the woods next an indie video game
and even a real world tragedy given how
young he was at the time still being in
high school Paul and a few others had
bought into the Slenderman myth
wholesale he believed it to be real this
towering expressionless Boogeyman the
more he learned about this malevolent
creature every story blog post or creepy
YouTube video made about Slenderman only
added more and more to his Legend and
kept young Paul awake at night afraid
that every noise outside his bedroom
window was the faceless horror of course
if you take away that belief the
possibility an urban legend might be
true then it simply loses its power it's
that potential that maybe Towing the
line between fantasy and reality that
can allow these stories to go on and
incite fear forever but that wasn't the
case for the Slenderman story and the
The Craze for it quickly died down after
it was debunked numerous times over
casting it permanently back into the
realm of fiction but the profound effect
the legend had on Paul at a young age
ended up informing his future as he Grew
Older his past fear of certain stories
became a keen interest in how these
Tales could influence people could any
story have that same impact or only
those that walked the line between
fictional and maybe being true did these
urban legends become more real to people
because of their subject matter or did
human beings give them that power to
transcend the constraints of fiction
just by believing in them as Paul got
older he began to study the truth behind
certain urban legends attempting to
trace them back to their Origins some
were often inspired by real events but
with specific details that had gradually
been altered from the original story the
more and more people passed it around
ghost stories seemed to be the most
changeable but with some roots in the
real World a person might have died a
hundred years ago and the story of them
haunting their old home or final resting
place would start to circulate then
shortly after another similar story
might emerge and the two would overlap
whoever was telling each story might
have added or omitted certain details or
combined elements of more than one tale
until what was left being passed around
was neither the first story nor the
second but a hybrid of different
versions from different storytellers
there was one legend that Paul felt
drawn to more than others and it was a
rather obscure one to say the least
during his self-conducted research into
stories of this nature he learned about
a tale that told of an ancient sect
called the davites according to Legends
some that dated so far back that they
preceded almost all of recorded history
these daveites were a callous and cruel
civilization they had emerged from a
book so the story went and sought only
to wage war on other other cultures and
enslave their enemies but Paul also
uncovered one detail of the story that
intrigued him more than any other it
referred to something known as the
Eternal text and was regarded as some
kind of deity or figure of worship by
the devites The Legend stated that this
text had helped create the book that
they had emerged from of course this all
sounded like highly fictitious nonsense
to Paul Jacobs he knew that things of
such nature didn't exist in the real
world they were only part of stories but
he had noticed that this particular
story seemed to have passed its way
through the ages searching further Paul
had uncovered The Works of an obscure
author from the United States who had
only a few works that were known about
during the 1940s and 50s even then most
of his stories weren't widely published
only a few shorter pieces making it into
a magazine that had long since stopped
being printed this writer had died in
1957 having never seen his career in
fiction come to fruition but despite his
short-lived career and being considered
a somewhat subpar author at the time the
writer's work had garnered its own
little cult following online mostly
comprised of amateur authors it was
through them that Paul managed to obtain
some scanned copies of the anonymous
writers stories particularly some that
he felt wore a striking similarity to
the David Legends of the Eternal text
one story in particular written in a
style lifted directly from H.P Lovecraft
was based on a supposed encounter the
writer claimed to have had with
something that closely resembled the
Eternal text Paul also studied the
writer's own personal journals that he
had managed to recover scans of the
entries from it seemed to imply that the
author came across what he called the
written God and that this compelled him
to write a fictitional version of those
events it was only after writing about
this new encounter that what he had
depicted in his story seemed to come
true exactly as he'd written them this
led to a recursive process of the writer
creating these encounters only for them
to occur thus causing him to write about
it and then make it happen the entire
Prospect not only confused and
bewildered Paul but intrigued him
further as well although he had no way
of confirming what this writer had
claimed was true Paul believed that on a
smaller scale the author had achieved
the same effect that occurs during the
passing down of urban legends but the
difference here was that it had all been
done through himself via a singular
person telling variations on the same
story allowing it to continue and
perpetrate recursively of course Paul
didn't actually believe in this written
God or Eternal text those were all just
part of the fiction but he wanted to
experiment further and see if he could
achieve the same process for himself
taking an empty notebook Paul started to
write the first things that came to mind
basing a short story off of the
anonymous author's own
he intentionally changed a few key
details noting down things that weren't
in the original the written God appeared
behind me he wrote adding on a whim the
line it had no face the whole intention
of Paul's experiment was to pass his new
version of the story onto someone else
and then try to get them to write it
from memory he wanted to observe if
their mind would change certain details
subconsciously or if they would
misremember elements when they retold
their new version if enough people could
spread the story around each time
altering or adding new parts to it what
effect could it have as he finished his
Rewritten version of the author's tale
attaching it to an email to send to one
of his fellow writers Paul was
blissfully unaware of just what he'd
done a heavy knocking rang out
somebody's fist pounding at the front
door loud enough to wake him leary-eyed
Paul checked the alarm clock next to his
bed it was the middle of the night
stumbling out of bed he staggered his
way towards the repetitive noise unsure
who or what would be calling this late
Paul froze for a second casting his mind
back to the story he had written earlier
surely not it couldn't be right it was
just a story after all but the author he
had described how the things he'd
written had come true there it was that
possibility that maybe what if it was
behind the door right now suddenly
something much heavier than a hand
bashed against the wooden surface of the
front door causing it to fly open the
catch of the lock being ripped out of
the wall by the force of the impact a
group of black-clad figures rushed in
one of them tackling Paul to the ground
before he could even process what was
happening the weight of another person
pinned him down and kept him from moving
despite his attempts at struggling free
then the feeling of something sharped
poked at the Exposed Skin of Paul's neck
a needle filled with he wasn't sure all
he really knew right now was how dizzy
he was unable to stop himself from
slipping away a the sedative quickly put
Paul back to sleep as the agents filed
into his home the floor he woke up on
was freezing cold blinking his heavy
eyelids until they opened again Paul did
his best to stand his head was still
spinning making it hard to keep his feet
still and to make matters worse the room
around him was hardly lit only a few low
fluorescents dimly illuminated the tiny
Space Mr Jacobs a voice boomed over a
crackly intercom the pitch lowered to
distort it further we need you to answer
a few questions for us what corresponded
in confusion where did you first learn
about scp-582
The Voice questioned barely giving Paul
a moment to think about what what's an
SCP he asked back he wrote a story
earlier today correct boomed the Unseen
speaker meekly Paul nodded his
headline activity for any mentions of
scp-582 or anything using any of its
known aliases you mean that written God
Eternal text thing Paul replied catching
on to what the voice had been referring
to I read about it in some stories by
this old author he died ages ago most of
his work is pretty Niche it's actually
hard to track down enough The Voice
interjected bluntly when did you specify
scp-582 would manifest manifest erased
an eyebrow confused again it was just a
story that's what I was doing I was
examining stories and how they change
when they get passed on Mr Jacobs it
sounded as though the voice had shifted
still distorted but now calmer more
collected somebody else was speaking it
is important to answer our questions
your life could be very well
and now do you remember when you wrote
that
scp-582 when it
to appear what do you mean in danger
Paul retorted in a panic what the heck
even are you people
he looked down to see his hands were
trembling suddenly aware of the sweat
coating his forehead Paul took a series
of deep breaths trying to collect
himself I
I don't remember his side his voice now
shaking as much as the rest of him was
The Voice pressed him can you tell us
where it's going to appear I didn't
write a location either Paul answered I
I just said it appeared the words he had
written earlier quickly Came Crashing
back into his head almost like an urgent
warning behind me as he spoke Paul could
sense someone standing near him that
same sensation you get when you know
another person is in the room even when
you haven't looked directly at them yet
Paul tried to keep his head forward only
tilting it slightly to the side seeing
something dark looming just behind his
shoulder he couldn't rationalize any of
what was happening he was too scared to
turn all the way around doing that would
admitted all of this was real and not
just some horrific nightmare not just a
story
[Music]
for the first time the voice over the
intercom sounded uneasy
telling himself he'd wake up any second
Paul rotated with his eyes screwed shut
snapping them open once he was facing
nothing a blank space lacking any
expression and all the normal features
was looming over him with an empty
eyeless stare it had no face just like
in Paul's story he opened his mouth to
let out a scream only for it to be
interrupted by the crunching sounds of
neck bones twisting the wrong way as
Paul's lifeless body dropped back down
to the cold floor
scp-582 vanished just as quickly as it
had arrived the thing about some
anomalies is you have to be very careful
about how you talk about them not just
because they could be listening in and
might hear you but because what you say
about them might just have a nasty habit
of coming true that is the case with
scp-582 otherwise known as its rather
apt nickname a bundle of stories what's
so fitting about that title is its
accuracy that's all As
u582 really is stories but therein lies
it's true power this entity has a way of
propagating and perpetrating itself
continuously adapting and spreading like
a mutating virus except it doesn't pass
from person to person as an illness
there are no symptoms it transmits via
stories
scp-582 is a subject to a process of
passive reality manipulation it doesn't
necessarily directly change the world
around it but can itself be changed by
certain factors what this means is
anything said or written about this
entity even if pulled out of thin air a
fictional account of its Deeds all
becomes real let's say for example you
told a story about scp-582 sneaking up
behind a foundation researcher when his
back was turned telling that story would
cause those exact events to be carried
out in the real world when scp-582
manifests it will do so in accordance
with any details given in a fictional
account about it the same time the same
place on Earth it would appear in the
exact form that the tale specified if
any of those details were omitted or
purposely left vague then the entity
would still be able to manifest and
would do so in a way that fits the rest
of the narrative appearing wherever and
whenever it has an opportunity to as far
as the researchers at the SCP Foundation
can tell the actual abilities of scp-582
are usually left vague when people write
about it one of the few consistencies is
that the entity can disappear and
reappear and will to any place or time
another is that no method of harming or
even killing scp-582 has ever worked
even if written down as fiction in order
to be made fact and the other details or
abilities that someone assigns to the
creature will however become a permanent
addition to its growing myth meaning it
is able to perpetually increase its
power the more people write about it on
the rare occasion multiple different
writers accounts of scp-582 contradict
each other or don't fit into the
entity's own Canon it can easily adapt
to these contradictions this usually
results in conflicting information
having no effect on the bundle of
stories or having so little impact that
it is almost like they didn't happen at
all in short if one author's story
doesn't quite match up with another's
then the effect these additions have to
scp-582 and its ongoing story are
lessened so that they can all either
logically occur or be negated completely
it is because of this adaptability and
that it has been described by multiple
sources that portrayals of scp-582 tend
to be generalized this even extends down
to its appearance it's currently unknown
what the entity's true form is or if it
even has one However the fact that it is
usually depicted as a deity or God means
that this bundle of stories has been
known to manifest as one of several
avatars the most common of these
appearances is that of a humanoid being
standing well over six feet tall when
manifesting as this particular form
scp-582 is dressed in thickly layered
robes made from burlap or Hessian
complete with a hood however no face is
visible underneath the creature's hood
and when presenting as this Avatar it is
often described as carrying sacks of
unknown contents sometimes even
appearing to bleed heavily there have
been a number of other incarnations of
scp-582 including a six-legged form that
is made out of pure molten tar and will
attack any nearby human beings on site
this Avatar would normally appear as
being fused with the first in other
instances it has appeared as a plant
capable of producing both light and
enough radiation to kill anyone in its
radius within a few hours of exposure
other times it has been a vaguely
human-shaped Shadow and even has one
form that exists within more than three
dimensions due to this form existing on
higher Dimensions this made it
impossible to properly perceive it with
the naked eye and resulted in the depths
of anyone who even looked partially at
it who knows maybe at some point it has
even been described as a tall slender
figure in a dark suit with pale skin and
a face with its eyes ears nose and mouth
all missing actually it's probably best
that nobody writes it down we don't want
it becoming real now do we the question
is how can you hope to contain or even
fight something that can be anything
anywhere and have any strength that
someone claims it has well just to be on
the safe side the foundation uses its
own fictional narrative to keep the
entity contained it is their hope that
by describing it as powerless it will
turn the creature's own reality altering
properties against it and actually cause
scp-582 to lose its ability
what thoughts if any that flow through
that alien mine are not mine to know it
remains silent and still within its
chamber entrenched in the Persistence of
its own memory it remains but only as a
shade of what it was its power spent
where at least come to rest so remember
scp-582 possesses no actual
Consciousness or free will anything it
has ever said or done is because someone
wrote that it would and yes we're only
saying that because we don't want to
write that it's broken free from
containment and is currently standing
behind you if we did that it might just
come true an organization with as many
Secrets as the SCP Foundation requires
the ability to dispose of material that
could prove harmful to the facade of
normalcy that the o5 council desperately
wishes to uphold and because most of the
high-ranking researchers are a bit too
smart and practical to Simply flush
classify documents and unwanted objects
down the toilet that means the
foundation has to get rid of evidence
thorough enough to guarantee that
absolutely no trace of what needs to be
disposed of survives for this purpose
several waste disposal plants are used
as front companies for the foundation
and function internally as a foolproof
way to liquidate hazardous material and
comprising information but not all
secrets are so easily forgotten with the
push of a button and a rare few can
prove too resilient to be burned away
this is the regrettable case of the
anomalies contained within the site now
designated
scp-2419 a place where the unfortunate
consequence of amnestic experiments has
led to the creation of hateful Immortal
humanoids faded to be sealed within the
incinerators of the facility these
Undead freaks are known as
scp-2419-a and though they were made
from human bodies the Consciousness that
dwells within each instance is nothing
short of Pure Evil every happy memory
and Associated positive emotion was
extracted from the brains of
scp-2419-8 corpses prior to their
attempted disposal in the incinerators
this was done in order to increase the
effectiveness of standard issue
foundation and nestics but the cost of
this minor breakthrough was that these
bodies all of which were once d-class
Personnel had effectively been stripped
of all human qualities given the sorts
of violent criminal backgrounds that
earns an individual the designation of
d-class personnel these former humans
were the last people that should have
been deprived of the love and joy in
their hearts and when the first of these
Psychopathic laughing men crawled out of
one of
scp-2419's incinerators the foundation
learned all too well what an uninhibited
Criminal Mind looked like driven only by
rage and fury that inspired their most
gruesome acts of exploitation and
violence in life their pain has made
them too hateful to succumb to the
Flames they are the archetypal Sinners
of a burning hell that the foundation's
best intentions paved the road to and
when they break loose all that Hell
Breaks Loose with them but no place of
the dam leaves its Gates unguarded
Dante's Inferno posits that the ancient
Greek mythological figure Minos
Serpentine father of the Minotaur and
judge of wicked Souls guards the pit of
Hell with Stern vigilance the Greeks
themselves favored the image of Cerberus
a three-headed Hound that served its
Lord Hades as a watchdog for the ancient
Egyptians there was Emma the Devourer of
the Dead who consumed the hearts of the
unrighteous in the afterlife while this
sort of guardian beast is not officially
on the foundation's payroll the concept
turned out to be alive and well in the
present day when
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile
stood against the Laughing men and gave
them the fight of their tortured
unliving existence it all began when the
guard stationed at scp-2419 began to
hear banging from inside one of the
incinerators it seemed as though the
scp-2419-a instance on the other side
was determined to breach containment so
mobile task force beta 7 the mass
Hatters were called in to stand with all
weapons at the ready but this was
exactly what the instance wanted as soon
as the Armed Force had fully assembled
The Laughing Man inside ripped the door
from its hinges it proceeded to use it
as a cover and run full speed towards
the mobile task force who opened fire
immediately
scp-2419-a were known to possess
extremely fast regenerative abilities so
it would take a lot of punishment to
slow this instance down but this was no
unthinking zombie and the instant broke
its charge the second it was in the
midst of the mobile task force agents to
twirl the door around like a trained
martial artist this not only sent the
incoming bullets ricocheting everywhere
causing many of the beta 7 operatives to
be hit by their own friendly fire it
also allowed the instance to bludgeon
several agents with sides of the door as
the remaining mobile task force members
retreated to a less exposed vantage
point where they could employ Heavy
Artillery the instance used this moment
of confusion to pitch the Door backwards
towards the incinerators in a boomerang
trajectory the force and spin of the
door knocked two more incinerator doors
off their hinges and caused two other
instances of
scp-2419-a to emerge one who was so
thoroughly decomposed that it appeared
to be more than a flaming skeleton
sprinted forth and through handfuls of
hot Cinders at the foundation agents it
used its still burning body to ignite a
few of the closest agents laughing with
sadistic Glee as it did so seconds after
the emergence of the two new instances a
grenade launcher was fired at the first
Escape e the blast was enough to deal
significant damage but the instance was
indifferent to its own pain it pointed
to the agent wielding the grenade
launcher and a moment later the third
instance was at the agent's throat
strangling him to death it was starting
to become clear to the mold task force
that this was no random Containment
Breach it was a coordinated escape
attempt by three ruthless criminal
masterminds when their time contained at
the site
scp-2419 had probably decided there was
some truth to the old adage that misery
loves company and indeed these 3D class
were some of the best of the best when
it came to being the worst of the worst
d1576 formerly police Lieutenant
Campbell farage a riot cop with a
serious taste for Carnage whenever the
streets of the city Precinct he presided
overturned violent farage always made
sure that the violence didn't down too
quickly his nasty pension for
bludgeoning suspects and citizens alike
with his riot shield did wonders for the
Escape Plan he had coordinated with his
fellow laughing men he was eventually
tried and sent to a supermax after
picking a fight with several other
officers in the line of duty a fight
that resulted in a pair of rookie
officers who opposed his violent methods
being hospitalized with permanent Comas
the skeleton was d-4483 Damian Lambert a
prolific arsonist who terrorized Three
Counties while avoiding detection under
the guise of being a sovereign citizen
if there was ever a person who wanted
just to watch the world burn it was
Damian Lambert he was caught in the
process of setting fire to an elementary
school and was thankfully apprehended
before any of the kerosene he had poured
through the Halls ignited when the truth
about his previous history of Pyromania
came out Lambert faced death row until
the foundation chose to recruit him as
d-class then there was D20 3 16 Arnold
Roper who was better known as the
Illinois Strangler responsible for over
50 deaths in two decades before he was
arrested and detained while he mostly
used his bare hands to do the deed Roper
was fond of using metal chains and heavy
duty choke collars usually worn by
animals to perform his namesake act of
violence Roper wasn't just brutally
strong he was crafty too and the trio of
Laughing Man had him to thank for some
of the finer points of the Escape Plan
the three now Immortal d-class also had
one thing in common each of them had met
the ends of their cruel and violent
lives at the jaws and Claws of
scp-682 and now that they had
outmaneuvered and slaughtered mobile
task force beta 7. their only Collective
goal was to get revenge on the monster
that condemned them all to the fiery
hell of the incinerator The Laughing Man
soon breached the limits of the scp-2490
containment site and began making their
way Overland towards the facility where
all of them had met their original fate
they knew they needed Wheels to get
there so the instances made their way to
the nearest gas station from the waste
disposal plant they'd come from and made
short work of the staff Lambert stocked
up on lighters kerosene and Duraflame
while farage took the emergency shotgun
that the cashier hadn't had time to fire
in her defense it would have been
difficult to accomplish much of anything
with Roper's hands clasped around her
throat once the trio of Undead
Psychopaths had stocked up on weapons
they waited for a suitable vehicle to
pull into the lot and before long there
was a family SUV with a happy family
inside no less farage ordered Lambert to
keep his fire starting tendencies in
check as a gas station explosion was the
last thing they needed right now the
former Rye Cop made his way out to the
car and used the shotgun to threaten the
family out of the car family road trips
can be stressful but rarely does one
expect to be carjacked by a gang of the
undead farage told The unmucky Mortals
that he wouldn't hurt them if they let
himself and his two friends use their
car and true to his word he didn't fire
a single shot the family were all added
to Roper's list of victims instead after
that the three men took to the wheel and
with only their hazy memories of pain
and suffering to guide them drove
relentlessly towards the foundation
facility with their enemy scp-682 was
contained the three had made sure to
leave no human alive at their original
containment site and would allow no
Witnesses who saw their anomalous
corpse-like forms to survive they
couldn't afford to give the foundation a
heads up that the Reckoning was on its
way in a family motor vehicle meanwhile
at the Laughing man's intended
destination
scp-682 was having another perfectly
routine day of painfully soaking in a
tank of corrosive acid this was par for
the course the reptile and it found
itself as eager as anyone else stuck in
a rut to get a break from the repetitive
mundanity of containment little did the
human-hating monster know it would soon
get its wish a few hours later the
facility was shocked to find that
several fires had been lit at the
fringes of the testing units these were
no freak accidents but rather the work
of Damian Lambert the arsonist still had
memories of all the times he wished he
could just burn his jailer's buildings
to the ground and had targeted the most
vulnerable areas for combustion the
Flames threatened the Integrity of
several areas of the facility and
multiple containment breaches were
imminent if the blaze couldn't be kept
under control while any available agents
with firefighting experience sought to
minimize the damage the researchers
evacuated to safer parts of the building
bringing any sensitive documents and
flammable items far away from the
affected sections this kind of
pandemonium was exactly where officer
farage thrived and he soon and The Fray
causing enough commotion that Rover was
able to slip deeper into the facility
completely undetected this turned out to
be the perfect role for the Strangler as
he hadn't eluded the police for 20 years
of his life just by being lucky faraj
and Lambert would both join up with him
after they were finished having their
fun for now his task was to locate the
containment unit of scp-682 and give the
Beast a taste of what the trio had in
store along the way he made sure to
obtain some durable metal chains from a
different containment unit he likely
released some kind of Elder evil in the
process but Roper didn't care about the
consequences the bottom line was that he
was always able to do his best work when
he was armed it wasn't long before he
found the large chamber which housed his
most hated foe
scp-682 Roper laughed maniacally as he
approached the creature floating in its
acid tank remember me lizard the
Strangler said sporting a wide grim the
monster simply growled back at Roper
wishing to tear him apart Roper chuckled
again and wrapped the iron chains around
the vat with all the considerable
strength of his Immortal muscles the
Strangler pulled the chains taut and
shattered 682's containment unit the
anomalous chain snared the creature's
body holding it in place how about now
Robert taunted 682 he laughed but the
creature left back
said the reptile I don't remember
the monster lunged towards a nearby wall
and burst through dragging Roper along
with it by his chains still wrapped
around the creature's body 682 twisted
and turned flinging Roper against every
wall and obstacle in sight but to its
surprise The Stranger was regenerating
and his grip on the chains was
unyielding back down the hall farash was
still continuing his Rampage when he ran
into an unlikely adversary Dr Alto claf
stood between the Laughing Man and the
other researchers and as usual the good
doctor was packing heat he told the
other researchers to go on without him
while he contained the scp-2419 instance
on his own a bold move to be sure but Dr
Cliff had made the same mistake he was
always making by assuming that guns were
the solution to this problem farage
laughed off the bullets and slammed into
Dr clef with enough Force to leave a
crater in the wall behind him he
followed up with a merciless barrage of
punches beating the armed researchers
sent useless and only relenting for a
moment to steal a few of his prized
Firearms with a blow that would have
taken the life of any normal man farage
struck Dr clef once more and left him
lying there a hair's length from Death
Dr clef's anti-anomaly field may have
protected him from reality warpers but
it did very little against being kicked
repeatedly very hard in the face
elsewhere Lambert had made his way into
the facility setting more fires as he
went the arsonist's skeleton was a
terrifying sight to all that beheld it
and when the guards realized that none
of their weapons would have any effect
most of them started to run away from
Lambert rather than towards him all
three laughing men would soon be upon
682 and then the fight of their
afterlives could truly begin until that
moment Roper was buying his Partners in
hatred more time the chains he had
stolen were no ordinary medal and with
them he had managed to keep 682's Jaws
shut while he pounded away at its
exposed ribs with his inhuman strength
Roper had killed more people than either
of his former d-class compatriots but
all that seemed to mean nothing in the
face of this invincible reptile the
shame and powerlessness he had once felt
as the creature had mauled him to death
made his Immortal heart beat without
rage when he was alive the Illinois
stranger had always thought that his
gift for murder made him better than the
average person A man among men but this
thing had made him feel weak in his last
moments of humanity and that sickening
emotion of weakness was still sliding
around in his soul with all of the other
Despair and Malice if his fate were to
live forever as a dead man walking then
he would make damn sure that any
humiliation he suffered would be paid
back threefold this soup of impotent
Fury bubbled within Roper as scp-682's
strength suddenly increased shattering
the weak link of the chains and sending
the hapless Strangler flying backwards
at that precise moment farage leaped out
of a nearby hallway and Unleashed Dr
clef's Arsenal on the reptile this
sustained fire irritated the creature
and it turned its focus towards the
unliving dirty cop it ready to charge
only to be suddenly held fast by Roper
who had grabbed its tail farage fired
until there was no more ammo then pistol
whipped the creature in both of its eye
sockets
scp-682 thrashed and struggled so the
men began to circle the reptile and
Alternate delivering formidable body
blows they took far more damage than
they could dish out with their bare
hands but the Regeneration that their
preter natural hatred granted them meant
that both in could theoretically keep
this up all day Roper grabbed a broken
length of the anomalous chain while
farage picked up a metal table to use as
a makeshift riot shield the Beatdown
continued as 682's eyes regenerated
along with several new sensory organs to
give it a full 360 degree view of the
pitched brawl that was taking place a
fiery explosion blew open a nearby wall
an in-walk Lambert still skeletal and
laughing as uproariously as ever he
threw a Molotov cocktail at 682's back
causing the creature to ignite
immediately the reptile roared in sudden
Agony farage Lambert Roper regrouped as
the creatures flank and pushed together
until they forced it back through the
hole where the arsonist had entered from
they were now all together in The
Inferno the three laughing men who
refused to die and the indestructible
monster that made them into what they
were Roper quickly nodded the chains and
wrapped them around one of the
creature's claws secure during the other
end around his waist like a trained
boxer he bobbed and weaved pummeling the
Beast with all he had and he stepped
back from scp-682 was met with the
immortal man shifting his entire body
weight to pull the creature's leg out
from under it barrage wedged his shield
into the creature's Open Jaw widening it
to an uncomfortable degree and
temporarily limiting 682's bite force he
took out the shotgun that he had stolen
from the gas station and blasted it down
the reptile skullet when that plan had
run its course he started clubbing 682
about its neck and head with the butt of
the shotgun Lambert simply continued to
douse the arena with more flammable
material especially himself and the
creature he climbed onto 682's back with
his burning bones and hammered away at
its defenses with literal fists of fire
the arsonist was incapable of articulate
speech due to the damage to his body
prior to his death but if he could speak
he would probably be celebrating the
fact that he had become one what he had
always wanted to be Damian Lambert was
no mere Pretender with a fetish for fire
he was fire itself a brightly burning
God of destruction that left no inch of
the world unburnt and no molecule of
oxygen unconsumed his mother and father
would be proud of him as they waited in
hell for the son who would never arrive
the son who would make the planet they
left behind into a true hell where he
would reign supreme that is until
scp-682 stole that dream out from under
him with a flash of blue and green from
deep within 682 began to burn with a
never-before-seen chemical reaction an
impossible event that could only be
described as anti-fire the turquoise
anti-flames devoured the orange and
yellow ones leaving Lambert in a state
of panic which was soon shared by his
fellow Laughing Man the three former
d-classes had gotten so used to the
torments of the incinerator that the
idea that anything could be more painful
had never occurred to them and yet here
it was the anti-fire which devoured all
flames and directly inflicted
unimaginable suffering to the trio of
instances every particle of their still
regenerating bodies felt as if it were
ice cold and melting into nothingness at
the same time numbed and broken All Over
Again The Laughing men were consumed all
over by the anti-flames and fell into a
state of suspended animation with the
foundation finally getting everything
back under control 24 hours later
scp-682 was contained in a new acidic
chamber there were some new ordinances
from all present and surviving
researchers about exposing it to fire as
the anti-flames It produced were
considered too hazardous to ever exist
within the facility again as for the
three laughing men who had escaped from
scp-2419 they were returned to their
containment units inside of the
incinerators and never exhibited signs
of aggression or Escape attempts ever
again a psychological profile of farage
Lambert and Roper that all of them could
still feel the sting of the burns left
by 680 anti-fire to this day and that
not even exposure to Natural heat and
fire could ever reduce that pain modern
cognitive Neuroscience tells us that our
memories are about as reliable as a
weatherman at your local news channel
when a couple is asked how did you first
meet they are lured into romanticized
reflection they might recall locking
eyes at a school dance they might recall
the night being just perfect despite the
truth being far from it we don't
remember the spilled punch the stepped
on toes or the
stuttering we only remember the X's and
O's our memory doesn't find the needle
by sifting through the haystack but
rather by lighting a match and setting
the barn Ablaze until All That Remains
is the small piece of silver shining
through the smoke in this way our
memories are our best friends they know
exactly when to lie to us feeding us
misinformation about the past to satisfy
ourselves in the present because if
humans were capable of writing and
recalling accurate personal accounts of
their history our memories would be
stiff unmarketable literature and when a
book gets boring we tend to tap out just
the same when our lives get monotonous
we tend to give up so we have our faulty
biased brains to thank us for our
perceived happiness and fulfillment our
inaccurate memory systems consequently
help us hide trauma contrive purpose and
Infuse unique importance into an
otherwise banal existence but let it be
known not all cerebral restructurings
are gifts from psychology some are
curses from scps which of these two
possibilities is more existentially
terrifying is up to you
scp-5040 is a non-existent Japanese
horror film entitled Tears of Blood
which spontaneously manifests in human
memories
scp-5040 is a master of persuasion
those affected by scp-5040 will remember
going to see the film even when their
supposed attendance would contradict
empirical evidence it manipulates the
Mind into unwavering Faith while humans
occasionally stumble upon the
self-awareness to question their
recollection there are no documented
instances of an individual doubting this
specific memory somehow beyond the
foundation's understanding
scp-5040 manages to suspend the
skepticism of its victims they accept
the memory as Canon as brute fact
victims of scp-5040 do not need a ticket
stop to know they have been to the
theater and scp-5040 afflictions can
occur any place where movies are shown
it even transcends laws and navigates
social norms in cultures where its
content would usually be prohibited by
regulations and frowned upon by the
public it still inserts itself into the
memory of its prey and once that memory
is planted it's an event event that
can't be forgotten like the birth of
your first child like your favorite
football team winning the Super Bowl
like the employee number you punch in
and out of work every day for the rest
of your life it stamps itself into the
Forefront of the subject's brain waving
its arm pleading to be recognized
begging for attention descriptions of
the film are always similar in nature as
are the circumstances and events
surrounding the viewing however reports
of scp-5040's story and characters are
never fully consistent from one subject
to the next and the film setting
subplots character names and much of the
dialogue are different for each viewer
whether this is scp-5040s intent or
inadequacy is unclear casting also
varies and appears largely arbitrary a
broad variety of Japanese performers and
entertainment personalities both living
and deceased have been said to star in
the film even when the actor in question
has no real life associations with the
horror genre imagine famous Japanese
actor Pat Morita better known as Mr
Miyagi from the karate kid being the
lead in a horror film despite the fact
this would be a noticeably strange
casting decision
scp-5040 would still be taken seriously
despite any and all deviations from
expectations of the medium
scp-540 is seen as legitimate kinks in
its design are overlooked by the viewer
similar to how our sleeping selves most
often don't recognize we are dreaming
even when we encounter flying horses
friends with banana fingers and
leprechauns playing Pot Limit Omaha in
Chris Hemsworth's basement this may be
because despite all of its quirks the
film's core is sturdy it's beginning
middle and end are always in agreement
it doesn't stray from Robert McKee's
Universal structure of story not even
the sick twisted M Night Shyamalan
himself could have created a cinematic
experience quite like this after
conducting more than 300 interviews
researchers have constructed a detailed
synopsis of scp-5040's most consistent
story elements and the most common
sequence of events associated with the
viewer's memory of their screening
attendance there is no matinee with this
movie screenings always begin at Sunset
if there are obstacles standing in the
way of the subject's attendance
scp-5040 will see them removed dentist
appointments drinks with a friend a long
procrastinated date with the treadmill
all these commitments for that day and
time will be pushed down the subjects
list of priorities making way for the
movie they will learn that their plans
have been canceled or resolved one way
or another the dentist's office burned
to the ground your friend is suddenly
sober the model of treadmills at your
gym have been recalled somehow someway
time is freed up and when life is kind
enough to offer respite from personal
and social obligations it is modern
humans instinct to sit down and veg out
at this moment the subjects decide to
see a movie at a nearby theater upon
arrival the theater looks to be an
entity in its own right long lines of
patrons are like limbs extending from
its Center box office bright blocky
letters forming the film's title run
across the Marquee like a cheap tattoo
it is truly Madness a frenzied crowd
gathers at the box office pushing and
shoving clawing at the glass partition
for a ticket the entire theater has been
reserved for this special event a
one-time only screening of a rare
critically acclaimed film admission is
entirely free but is it actually free or
has the cost just not declared itself
when the subject reaches the auditorium
they scanned their eyes over the sea of
people heads emerge from the backs of
almost every seat they can only find one
empty space and they have to shuffle
like a crab to get past the massive
other viewers in their seat they noticed
that a large number of people throughout
the audience are wearing disposable face
masks the woman sitting next to the
subject's right wears one such mask as
does the woman on their left and before
you think well that isn't so weird it's
important to note that all of these
accounts were taken years before certain
recent events patrons continue to pack
into the theater despite every chair
being filled more and more people enter
the aisles become overflow seating
regulations of Max occupancy are
dismissed in the darkness of the room
all that can be clearly seen are shapes
the rectangle that is the screen the
hundreds of circles that are the heads
of the audience but there is a shape
that feels misplaced what appears to be
the letter P sticks up from the crowd a
thin line with a bulge protruding from
the top the specificity of its origin is
difficult to Define but once the
subject's eyes adjust to the dark they
notice it's an IV pole carrying a bag of
fluid however there is no clear
indication of who it is connected to
furthermore they notice one of the
masked audience members is wearing a
hospital gown there is little time to
assess any of these strange visuals
because there are no trailers or
advertisements before the film as soon
as the audience is settled into whatever
space they might find temporarily
habitable the theater goes silent and
the film Begins the film opens with a
female protagonist going about mundane
activities in her day-to-day life a
phone call interrupts her it is an
unknown party who tells her that a loved
one has been hospitalized for one reason
or another the protagonist drops what
she's doing to accept the call to action
on her way to the hospital however she
is attacked by a male assailant and
loses Consciousness the protagonist
wakes up in a fog unable to make sense
of her surroundings but the audience
understands that wherever she is she is
in deep trouble she's in a desolate and
unfamiliar building with her arms and
legs bound she is a accompanied by a
number of other female captives some of
whom still remain seemingly unconscious
or possibly dead the woman briefly
discussed their strategy to escape but
they are interrupted when the kidnapper
appears descriptions of hairstyle eye
color and wardrobe would fall short in
showing us who this character really is
instead his Swift and decisive actions
do the talking he sees one of the women
crying and kills her without hesitation
the kidnapper reveals to the woman the
code he intended to operate under he
would release the captives after 24
hours but only under the condition that
they do not cry during the film the
kidnapper demonstrates various forms of
physical and psychological torture on
the group of women despite their best
efforts the captives are unable to hold
back their tears and one by one they are
murdered until only the protagonist
remains frustrated by the protagonist's
unremarkable resolve the kidnapper takes
more Extreme Measures increasing
intensity of her torture however the
antagonist is not one to be messed with
despite being tormented she seems in
control of the situation she doesn't
succumb to the traditional dynamics of
torture even while on the wrong end of
the bat she isn't afraid to swing she
fights back how she can she mocks and
insults her captor and it's then she
finds his weakness although a physically
empowering villain he is emotionally
fragile her grit frustrates him causing
him to lose focus and become noticeably
rattled as the protagonist continues to
weaken her kidnapper with words the
subject in the audience notices what
seems to be a slight echo in the
dialogue they look up to see if
something is wrong with the speakers
they even wonder if this is a stylistic
decision made by the director but then
they notice where it is coming from they
eventually realize that the two masked
women sitting beside them are quietly
repeating every line of dialogue as it
occurs their lips moving causes their
masks to shake softly with each word the
air from their whisper blows the cloth
away from their mouth only for the mass
to collapse back in when the syllable is
completed if the subject looks even
closer they will see that the lower half
of the woman's masks are saturated with
saliva things don't get any more
pleasant when the subject shifts their
gaze down the woman's body just near
their waists their hands are clasped
together so tightly that their
fingernails are digging into their skin
they tremble and fidget as if having
taken on the burden of the world's
anxiety and no medication can calm them
down fingernails dig deeper into their
skin drawing blood and foreshadowing the
film's finale at the film's climax the
kidnapper approaches the protagonist
with a double-edged razor blade and
announces that even if she is freed she
will spend the rest of her life horribly
disfigured this leads to an argument
between the two the subtexts of which
alludes to themes such as nature of
inner and outer beauty the value of
women in society and the societal stigma
against expressions of vulnerability the
argument on the surface however does not
sound sophisticated or profound there is
no consolation for a fight having
emotional depths at the end of the day
the blows will always feel more physical
than intellectual eventually the
kidnapper loses patience and grabs the
protagonist by the shoulders and slams
her to the floor he reaches out his
hands and grabs her by the face the
subject's attention is again pulled from
the screen when they hear groaning from
every direction the wordless hums filled
the theater with a sense of worry and
uneasiness so much so that the subject
feels the room getting smaller as the
air polluted with angst grows thicker as
the subject brings their eyes back to
the film they see the kidnapper gripping
the protagonist's lower lip between his
thumb and forefinger squeezing tight as
to pop her lip like a balloon the
kidnapper then takes the razor blade to
the victim's lips he pauses to mock the
protagonist and while he does this
blinded by pride and arrogance she jolts
into action grabbing the razor right out
of his hands with her teeth she follows
up her burglary with a salt her neck
stabs forward and in a blur she stabs
the kidnapper's eyes out it happens in
the kidnapper has no time to react blood
spills from his face screams pour out of
his mouth during this time the
protagonist Maneuvers the razor into her
fingers she hacks away at her bindings
but they are stubborn and resist her
sighing the battle continues and the
kidnapper is able to tear off the
victim's lips entirely she looks like a
monster now as the kidnapper smiles and
celebrates his wrongdoings the
protagonist finishes freeing herself and
slits the kidnapper's throat with the
razor the protagonist locates the exit
and scrambles towards it as the
kidnapper bleeds to death on the cold
hard floor the protagonist then speaks
her final words due to her injuries her
voice is muffled and raspy she Bears
down and calmly speaks one last time she
mocks the kidnapper telling him that he
cried tears of blood and therefore had
to die according to his own rules during
this climax it is reported that the
subjects experience a sense of dread
unique to any other Terror ever felt
strangely the female appeared not to
correspond to the scene in the film at
all it is a feeling entirely separate
from the viewing experience as if for a
moment the subject is taken out of the
moment in time and transported to a
realm composed only of fear and anxiety
but just as quickly as they left they
returned the foundation sees it worth
mentioning that this peculiar moment
happens to occur during the film's most
clearly recalled scene while
descriptions of violence vary from one
viewer to the next the climax is
unshakable and its consistency this is
further evidence that scp-5040 has a
core Foundation that remains intact
false memories are given validity by our
peers when we tell a story the
inaccuracies are often the best parts
the exaggerated drama the rearranged
sequence of events the jokes you thought
of in retrospect but weaved into later
accounts while a Storyteller knows when
to lie a good Storyteller knows how to
not get caught
scp-5040 captivates its audience but it
seems to know how much it can get away
with by providing a consistent objective
truth a climax that is reported the same
across all accounts
scp-5040 insists even if only briefly on
being a credible film not just a random
sequence of 24 frames per second eyes
back to the screen the film abruptly
cuts to an unspecified point in the
future now wearing a face mask to hide
her disfigured mouth no different than
the one seen worn in the theater the
protagonist walks down the street to her
apartment indifferent to the crowd of
Paparazzi that follows her it is clear
that this is now just a part of her life
the lights flash on her face when she
reaches her bedroom the protagonist
slowly pulls down her mask face free
from cloth she stares at herself in the
mirror it is silent what she sees is
less notable than what she doesn't the
lower portion of her face is gone she
focuses only on that it's hard to know
if she will ever see into her own eyes
again her days might forever be fixed on
what she can't get back and through
those eyes that long to see more she
sheds a single tear over the course of
several minutes her weeping gradually
builds into frenzied sobs and shrieks it
can first be misinterpreted as bad
acting a case of doing too much but as
the crying carries onward it's
understood that the horror in her
wallowing is all too real the film cuts
to Black and the credits roll but the
sound of the protagonist's cries
continue to play with no other audio
until the credit reel ends and even then
in silence it's hard to say if she ever
stopped crying audience members remain
silent after the movie ends exchanging
only Whispers as they exit the theater
feet step over small red puddles and
stains on the theater floor as if they
are sticky puddles of soda those who
remain past this point experience an
escalating feeling of unwelcomeness
until sitting and staying is more
physically demanding than getting up and
walking out some experiences will stay
with you forever even if they never
actually happened alarms go off all
around the facility things descended
into chaos so quickly of course the
staff of the SCP Foundation are
extremely familiar with the horrors of a
Containment Breach by now but this was
something exceptional two anomalies had
joined forces in an unexpected fashion
neutralizing some of the weaknesses that
the two of them usually experienced
needless to say this was bad more
specifically 74 staff members were dead
already several different mobile task
forces had already been dispatched to
hunt down this terrifying new anomaly
but none of them knew where it was
hiding in the depths of the site little
did they know this deadly new hybrid had
already escaped the SCP Foundation and
was already on its way towards a nearby
population Center that's where the real
fun would start but before we get to all
that Carnage let's rewind clock a little
and find out how This Disaster started
some things just go great together like
peanut butter and jelly milk and cereal
or clicking subscribe when you're
watching a video by SCP explained but
for every match made in heaven there's
also a match made in hell like being
covered in sugar water while you walk
past a wasp nest or doing tricks with
your awesome Zippo lighter next to a gas
pump or most horrifying of them all a
combination of
scp-106 and
scp-035 of course the reputations of
these two horrible creatures are well
known and well feared enough on their
own
scp-106 is a humanoid Abomination also
known as the old man capable of walking
through walls and entering his own
private pocket Dimension where he
practices his pre-dilection for pain to
its full potential and then there's
scp-035 also known as the possessive
mask this is one of the most powerful
and dangerous psychic entities that the
SCP Foundation has in its vast
collection some of its more minor
unpleasant qualities are things like the
fact that it constantly drips corrosive
black slime or the fact it immediately
reduces you to a state of brain death
when you're foolish enough to wear it on
the more severe end of its abilities is
its power to crawl into the mind of
anyone around it slowly Whispering
Horrors into their mind until they're
completely under its control or utterly
broken it likely has designs on world
domination or at the very least to
plunge the human race into an
unimaginable pit of Eternal suffering
the one Saving Grace is the fact that
035's corrosive slime slowly destroys
the body of its hosts limiting the
purview of each one of its Reigns of
Terror but occasionally there are
wonderful terrible exceptions to the
rule speaking of terrible our story
began chronologically with scp-106
showing one of its rare signs of
activity this naturally caused waves of
panic to rock through the researchers
and security staff of the site they'd
need to grab a d-class then plug in and
warm up the femur breaker they'd also
need to mobilize groups of on-site
guards with powerful flashlights to slow
the gnarled old monster down but by now
as cp106 had gotten wise to the
foundation's techniques he wouldn't make
himself so easy to capture this time he
wanted to have the proper time to enjoy
himself
scp-106 got up and phased through the
nearby wall his cell was never easy to
escape they filled it with strange
shapes and running water just to confuse
his wretched old mind but once he was
out he was out he avoided the hallways
instead just facing from wall to wall
until he reached a different block of
containment Chambers that's where the
Fateful meeting would take place it
wouldn't be the first time he'd wandered
into other containment cells his battle
with scp-682 perhaps been being the most
famous but this time something was
different the room he'd just faced into
didn't contain some huge writhing
monster or another humanoid Beast it
contained instead a glass container on
top of a Podium the walls coated in
deadly telekil alloy to keep its
prisoners immense psychic power sealed
in but now that scp-106 was in the room
standing mere feet away from the
grinning white mask inside the glass
container there was nothing keeping the
two of them from having an extremely
faithful conversation the first thing as
cp106 noticed was the black liquid
leaking from The Mask strange it seemed
to perfectly match his own secretions
hello there good sir it is an often I
have visitors in here and even less so
visitors who are as handsome as you the
mask said speaking directly into the old
man's frail fractured mind I don't
believe we've ever been acquainted did
come a little closer and remove the
glass box I'll be able to hear you
better that way come on come on don't be
shy the old man felt something about the
mask was distasteful even to a creature
as Despicable as scp-106 something about
the mask just seemed slimy
metaphorically as well as literally and
yet it found itself stepping forward
towards the glass case almost as though
he was sleepwalking how was the mask
invading his mind like this he'd always
been one of the more mysterious
creatures in the foundation's
containment and yet scp-035 had slipped
into his mind like a warm bath on some
level it frightened him yes yes that's
wonderful come closer dear boy you're
doing so well the mask said as the old
man reached forward and began lifting
off the glass case I think I'd look
rather good on you don't you agree let's
cover up that nasty old face of your
you'll look positively spiffing old chap
just do exactly as I say and this is all
going to go wonderfully the old man
picked up the mask somehow not even in
control of his own body anymore an
almost electrical power seemed to pulse
out of the mask and through the old
man's rotting fingertips the old man was
a sadist but he'd never before
encountered this kind of utterly
malicious intelligence this was a mind
geared to commit almost incalculable
evil and while the old man was wondering
how exactly he felt about that he was
already lifting The Mask up to his face
and watching the universe go very very
dark outside a small army of foundation
security operatives armed with
flashlights and assault rifles were
charging through the halls trying to
trace the movements of the old man for
recapture back in the old man's cell a
confused serial arsonist was being
shoved into the femur Breaker by a group
of nervous and impatient researchers
none of them knew they were dealing with
an entirely different Beast down here
now eventually the security team found
the last Rusty Scorch mark on the wall
of a containment cell belonging to
scp-035 before they could even
comprehend the terrifying implications
of this horrible scenario they charged
into the cell in hopes of stopping it
but by the time they were in there both
the Old Man and the mask were already
gone well not entirely suddenly the
guards in the room felt an odd sense of
calm wash over them not a true authentic
calm but an artificially induced one
like the lulling of a cattle while a
bolt gun descends towards their
foreheads the mask's psychic influence
had pacified them making them perfect
prey for the rotten hands reaching out
from the ground and pulling them down
into Oblivion the guards outside heard
the most horrific screaming they circled
the door terrified aiming everything
they out of the entryway but it wouldn't
be enough soon enough this new hybrid
Beast
scp-106 wearing
scp-035 emerged and began its Onslaught
it had the immense physical abilities of
106 bolstered by zero three fives
diabolical intelligence and ability to
Cloud the minds of its victims
inhibiting their capacity to run away or
fight back the most frightening of all
because scp-106 was already adapted to
resist the effect of its own corrosive
mucus it was also perfectly able to
sustain The Mask as a host without ever
melting and falling apart see what we
mean about a match made in Hell how do
you like my new body Gentlemen The Mask
asked its voice dripping with malicious
Glee it isn't much to look at I know but
you're about to get very well acquainted
with its collection of charming
abilities and The Mask stayed true to
its word it rampaged through the
containment site Waltzing through walls
like a gleeful School child with a heart
and mind of the Devil Himself leaving a
pile of melted tortured corpses in its
wake researchers guards janitorial staff
nobody was safe and with every killing
the rest of the staff became
increasingly afraid only strengthening
the psychic hold of the Mask it was
having the best day it could remember in
a long long time the site director and
his team put out a Mayday for all
available mobile task force units to
descend onto the area and help them deal
with this deadly new threat but by the
time they were on their way the mask and
its new scp-106 body had already had its
fun with the foundation even when they
activated the femur breaker nothing
happened the mask was far more
interested in the pain it could cause
outside and far too intelligent to be
lured back into imprisonment by such a
simple trick instead the hybrid made its
way out of the nearby perimeter all
finding its way to a heavily armored
Foundation ground vehicle and sliding in
through the door like a ghost the
operative in the driver's seat was
immediately terrified by the monster
suddenly sitting next to it but then the
mask's psychic effects took over his
mind he became a calm Placid little
servant just like all those other Mortal
fools I feel like a change of scenery
old sport The Mask said to him take me
out to the nearest city it can be the
one of your choosing I feel like having
a little night on the town oh it's been
far too long you know the hypnotized
driver nodded and punched the gas the
guards were too busy controlling the
aftermath of the chaos within the sight
we even noticed the creature they were
chasing had already escaped and if it
reached a nearby City then the chaos
cruelty and Madness it was liable to
release would be the biggest mess the
foundation would need to clean up in
quite some time which was precisely what
the malicious mask had in
meanwhile Dr Robert Scranton woke up in
a dark room well he wasn't sure if it
was a room but it was definitely dark he
rose to his feet in this strange black
void surrounded on all sides by
Blackness it wasn't the belly of
scp-3001 the dreaded red reality again
no this was something new and what's
more he had no idea how on Earth he'd
gotten here Dr Scranton said a cruel
mocking voice behind him turn around old
chap it's been far too long since I've
seen you in the flesh well in a manner
of speaking at least confused Dr
Scranton turned and saw a Vaguely
Familiar sight
scp-035 the possessive mask floating in
the dark behind him what on Earth was
happening here he wondered oh you really
don't remember do you
laughs
mask said with a spiteful laugh replying
to a thought he'd never voiced aloud
they're in your mind doctor as it turns
out you're harder to erase than I
thought perhaps you're buried so deep in
the psyche of that monster
no matter I'll get you eventually how
strange Dr Scranton thought this must be
his mind playing tricks on him somehow
he raised a hand to scratch his head
quizzically and only then realized that
his right hand was gone simply vanished
from the end of his wrist The Mask gave
another sick laugh
oh it's all
I told you I'd get you scratched
the mask cackled with Glee I never
normally get to delete a mind slowly oh
this will be amusing where's Anna
Scranton asked suddenly wondering about
the safety of his beloved wife he
couldn't help but worry when this got
another cruel laugh out of the Mask
remember
remember the mask said through giggles
who killed her you killed her with your
toxic embrace
she died terrified of you and with that
all the awful memories came flooding
back back in the real world things
weren't any less horrifying when the
vehicle had finally made its way to the
nearby City the mass told man had
unceremoniously murdered its chauffeur
and decided to go for a little
exploration it had been so long since it
felt the sun on its pristine white
porcelain such a beautiful day outside
they couldn't wait to kill some people
around here it began its Rampage in a
dark alley snatching some homeless
people and unfortunate passersby through
the graffiti stained stone walls by the
time it was done with them there weren't
even any bones left but this would only
be the start of the masked old man's
horrific Rampage through the city next
he invaded an office building and
decided to unleash his grisly wrath on
the people within some were pulled
through the ground while chatting at the
water cooler others were dragged through
the walls as they went to refresh their
coffee some were simply sitting at their
desks getting on with their daily work
when a dark silhouette appeared behind
them some turned around saw the creature
and screamed immediately others remained
in ignorance and only screamed when an
acidic rotting hand curled around their
shoulder but every single one of them
screamed eventually by this point the
SCP Foundation had started sending all
the mobile task forces in the area to
the nearby city after receiving reports
of unexplainable disappearances and
murders Panic was starting to spread and
that Panic was only making the
nightmarish psychic abilities of the
Mask even stronger the challenge would
be intercepting scp-106 and removing the
mask before became too powerful for them
to do anything about it if they didn't
they could be looking at a loss of life
on a massive scale which was exactly
what scp-035 hoped to indulge in a young
Barista was having a stressful day at a
nearby Boutique coffee shop she retired
to the staff bathroom to splash some
water on her face and re-center herself
she sighed and looked up from the sink
into the mirror to see if her makeup was
running and then screamed a dark figure
was standing right behind her it looked
like a rotting human corpse dripping
with black slime and wearing a grinning
white ancient Greek comedy mask I'm not
interrupting anything am I the masked
old man said amused soon after the dark
presence had Spilled Out into the coffee
shop the psychic powers of the mass
caused its victims to be paralyzed with
sheer Terror unable to escape its cruel
hands the death toll of the day had
already risen to over a hundred and the
masked old man had no intention of
stopping that's when several police
cruisers skidded to a halt in front of
the coffee shop cops disembarked from
their cars and pulled out their handguns
step out of the store with your hands up
one of the over a megaphone any sudden
moves and will blow you to Kingdom Come
this made the masked old man laugh
[Laughter]
oh how very adorable not long after he
was driving a police cruiser further
into town with a pile of Dead Cops left
in the street behind him this was
shaping up to be such a wonderful day he
never wanted it to end back in the pitch
dark of the mindscape Dr Robert Scranton
was looking a little worse for wear both
of his legs had disappeared along with
one of his eyes and much of the rest of
his right arm his remaining eye was
weeping remembering how his embraced as
the old man had killed his beloved Anna
he lost his humanity and become the
worst kind of monster the kind who even
hurts the people he loves most
scp-035 floating in the darkness was
still just laughing at him
[Laughter]
oh you're pathetic Scranton his
look how little is left of you
you haven't even been human in decades
why not give up what little is left
you're mine now
and soon you're going to be nothing at
all and Dr Scranton kept crying because
he feared the mask was right back in the
city the stolen police cruiser pulled up
in front of a preschool and the masked
old man got out this would be the
perfect place for his next Little slice
of fun straining himself out he began
walking to the school knowing that with
the extent of his psychic powers nobody
would be strong enough to run away
they'd all just have to sit there and
suffer just like Dr Robert Scranton
Goodbye old man The Mask said to him I'm
tired of talking to you now Dr Scranton
was ready to give up and let himself
disappear but then something occurred to
him Knowledge from his foundation days I
I must be wearing you Dr Scranton said I
must be wearing you Scranton reached up
to his face with his remaining hand
grasping at something suddenly the face
of the floating mask Twisted into an
infuriated frown what do you think
you're doing it said it's too late
Robert but Scranton wouldn't be deterred
he gripped something invisible over his
face and began to tug even though
pulling on this invisible mask on his
face was agonizing the whole void around
him began to shake and quiver including
the grimacing
scp-035 Scranton just kept pulling stop
that you idiot
stop it stop it stop it you're going to
ruin everything you but it was already
too late Dr Scranton murmured I'm sorry
Anna and gave one last yank that's when
everything went white back in the city
it thankfully wasn't long until a group
of mobile task force agents was able to
locate the two anomalies
scp-106 was sitting cross-legged on the
grass outside of a preschool where
thankfully nobody had been hurt and was
just staring off into space and his
Trembling Hands was another familiar
sight of frowning
scp-035 it's hard to believe it's been a
full 100 days since I began my journey
no my mission into the Beating Heart of
the SCP Foundation I stop this Stone
wrist detection my safety and even my
own life for this cause and I'm sure
that makes you wonder why on Earth I'd
be foolhardy enough to put so much on
the line well my reason is the best no
the only reason that matters for the
sake of off I decided early on that
recording my fine things was essential
both for posterity and so that the art
world may know just how dedicated I've
been in my pursuit of true inspiration
it all started over three months ago
that was when I first managed to embed
myself in the SCP Foundation naturally I
never would have jumped at the idea of
having to fraternize with the likes of
the chaos Insurgency their methods are
far too brutal their organizations
seeped in violence that trivializes my
own pursuit of a deeper meaning but even
I have to admit the insurgency's
methodology can yield results they range
for a convenient accident to befall a
lower level researcher after they
returned home from site 19 the SCP
foundation's largest and most infamous
facility home to many of their equally
Infamous anomalies thanks to a falsified
identity and phony transfer order from
the Insurgency I was able to slip into
site 19 undetected so that I could begin
my search the subterfuge was at first
easy to maintain I love the part
obviously a lab coat and a name badge so
versatile and yet completely unassuming
I was visible and still imperceptible to
the rest of the foundation's personnel
as far as they knew I was just the
latest transfer to site 19 as I spent
the day getting my bearings not one of
them could have possibly known my true
intention my goal was simple and twofold
first and foremost I had long felt I
deserve to be accepted as a member of
the Art Collective known as awcy or are
we cool yet since the 19th century they
have been championing the creation and
exhibition of anomalous artwork truly
pushing the boundaries of what can be
considered artistic expression despite
the foundation's attempts to censor AWC
wise Transcendent ah I had admired their
mission statement from afar for a number
of years and strive to achieve much the
same in my own artwork however none of
my previous pieces quite meant the
collectives anonymous pedigree I know a
way to change that though blending in at
site 19 proved to be fairly simple as
long as you stride around with purpose
few will question what you're doing with
my head in a notebook or a look of
conviction on my face I could freely
make my way around the facility but why
you might wonder what was the actual
intention behind my undercover Mission
well that answer lies in the second half
of my goal recognition not just
notoriety and acceptance into the ranks
of awcy but Fame throughout the
anomalous art world and all the perks
that could come with of course the main
hurdle to overcome was that I needed to
create a piece of art that was anomalous
in its nature and so rather than wait
for inspiration and materials to fall
into my lap I chose to instead seek out
what I needed the anomalies on offer at
site 19 were abundant and knowing where
to start was tricky I made the decision
while still getting accustomed to my new
surroundings that I would start wherever
I felt the most drawn to before the end
of my first week in site 19 I felt the
first poll of an anomaly and uncovered
it in the most unlikely of places during
my day most of the SCP Foundation living
quarters are empty meaning I could sneak
around there undetected it was in the
personal bathroom of One Foundation
doctor that I found
scp-063 to the untrained eye the anomaly
appears to be an ordinary toothbrush
save for the wording stenciled into the
pale blue plastic the world's best
toothbrush of course examining it closer
I learned of its ability to cleave
through inorganic matter like a hot
knife through butter it was quite the
shock slicing the porcelain of the
bathroom sink by accident that would
have led to my detection had I not left
soon after but I reflected on the
toothbrush or top brush and what it
could possibly represent perhaps an
acknowledgment of rituals and their
importance to human health yet at the
same time being sharp enough to cut
anything not organic anything not human
maybe a cp063 was meant to symbolize the
possible dangers of Habitual behaviors
the next day I was able to Bear witness
to an anomalous piece I had only ever
heard rumors of for a time I thought it
to have been the reason for AWC wise
founding after all its nickname was
derived from a particular traditional
art form
SCP-173 the sculpture as those at the
foundation call it I was able to insert
myself into a group of two other
Personnel a researcher and security
officer the former was entering the
container housing SCP-173 to run tests
the latter protecting her naturally I
overheard them looking for a third and
offered my assistance even if all I had
to do was watch the sculpture intently I
wasn't even allowed to Blink without
getting someone else to cover for me
while I did I adored it the messy
structure of concrete and rebound to
fight all Notions of what many believed
art should be it wasn't beautiful or
pristine it dared to be ugly and yet it
demanded to be seen to be looked at and
perceived or else it would break my neck
and claim my life it was everything I'd
hoped pure art personified it was as I
neared the end of my first week in site
19 that I discovered my next anomalous
art piece hidden away in a storage
locker
scp-010 the colors of control these were
a collection of cast iron colors that
according to their file could be used to
control the actions and movements of a
person wearing one via a remote control
these Scholars fascinated me they were
to my interpretation tools to control
yet simultaneously a rejection of the
very rules that control human beings
someone wearing an scp-010 color could
potentially have their entire bodily
shape reconfigured by the person
wielding the remote that alone the fact
that these objects could be used to defy
the physical laws that dictate the forms
we exist in was a meta comment rejecting
the laws of society in order for free
expression expression only achieved by
Art it all made me appreciate awcy's
dedication to anomalous artworks yet I
was still determined to be welcomed into
their Collective my first week hiding
with Insight 19 concluded with a visit
to scp-107 held on a pedestal in an
otherwise empty room was an empty
hollowed-out turtle shell now I for one
don't respect archaeologists art
historians are another matter however I
would rather focus on translating The
Human Experience into my art than waste
mental energy on events or objects from
hundreds and thousands of years ago but
this total shell might be the exception
apparently any liquid placed within the
shell will be absorbed only to rain down
from the clouds above there's something
quite honest about
scp-107 interpreted through the mind of
an artist such as myself it appears to
be a reminder of the natural world's
cyclical process the liquid within it
becomes rain which falls and feeds the
plants the plant life in turn provides
food and shelter for animals humans too
and so on on and on the circle of life
repeats as so embodied by the hollow
shell of an ancient proud Turtle I began
my second week of subterfuge with a
scare a close call that I may have been
discovered one of the foundation's
doctors had complained that his sink had
been sliced in two in spite of my best
efforts to cover my tracks it seemed
that using his denture glue to repair
the damage scp-063 had done didn't quite
have the effect I had intended
nevertheless the reaction by the
foundation seemed to imply that sort of
thing happened all the time an
announcement was made reminding all
researchers to not toy with the world's
best toothbrush despite how fun it was
to slice things up with although they
requested the culprit come forward I
decided to divert the foundations
suspicions away from me hinting to a
security officer I had seen Dr alto clef
leaving the private bathroom where I had
accidentally broken the sink they seemed
to believe he had been capable of
causing the damage almost being
discovered meant I had to reassess my
objective over the following few days I
tried to sink into life among the
foundation's researchers playing the
role of a helpful member of personnel so
as not to attract any further suspicions
and so I was mostly concerned with the
general day-to-day tending to anomalies
most of them I encountered during this
time were living creatures which were of
little interest to me although one by
the designation of scp-049 sporting the
rather aesthetically striking appearance
of a plague doctor complete with dark
robes and a beaked mask at first I
thought him to be a quite in amicable
intelligent fellow that is until I had a
moment alone with him to ask his
opinions on Art the plague doctor
claimed it was of literal importance
when compared to curing the pestilence
naturally I took that to be a personal
insult requesting to the research head
that I'd be transferred away from an
anomaly that was obviously not as
intelligent as I first thought two and a
half weeks had passed and I had still
remained undetected by the foundation
however I had been forced to reassess my
nation awcy were hardly likely to accept
me into their group if I had nothing to
show for my efforts I need to diverse
some materials I could use to create an
anomalous art piece or preferably
something I could claim as my own it
wasn't as if the upper echelons of awcy
possessed their own detailed files on
every anomaly at site 19 they would have
no idea of something I plucked from
containment was an existing SCP or as
staff is still an original piece so I
said about finding something I could be
my magnum opus my breakthrough into the
anomalous art community my key to the
fame fortune and artistic Acclaim I so
obviously deserved you may call it
plagiarism using another anomaly as my
own piece but nobody technically owns
the objects and entities at site 19.
even the foundation themselves are more
so jailers and curators than creators I
however am a Visionary I just needed
something to prove it my search took me
far and wide all over the width and
breadth of sect 19. by the time my first
whole month had passed I'd begun to walk
the corridors and pass by its
containment Chambers just like any other
researcher although not one who I had
interacted with had any clue they were
in the presence of a man who would
reshape the anomalous art World there
was an SCP transferred from another
facility that I witnessed during that
time according to the foundation's files
scp-066 had previously been a ball of
braided yarn and ribbon but had since
become an amorphous ball of meat with
functioning eyes what struck me most
about scp-066 was the question it asked
since transforming are you Eric at first
I thought I'm not Eric but the longer I
pondered it I began to wonder allowing
my perception to be challenged that is
what art does after all perhaps much
like in The Marshall Mathers sense that
we are all Stan all of us may well be
Eric too I can recall another incident
encountering some
scp-131s creatures known as the iPods
which one almost tripped me up their
brightly colored teardrop shaped bodies
were certainly striking a rather
abstract modernist biomechanical design
but it was their eyes that I found
myself ruminating on
scp-131 instances had a single
unblinking eye giving a constant gaze
without faltering I likened it much to
the uncritical unthinking eyes of
certain audiences who in the past had
stared at my artwork and had nothing
interesting to say about it in other
events my attempts to avoid detection
may have proven a little detrimental Dr
Cliff corn on me a little perturbed that
I had implicated him in the sink slicing
incident he at one point seemed to imply
a desire to inflict far Wars damage with
a ukulele of all things although I'm
sure he was just joking at least I hope
so the whole interaction reminded me of
the urgency of my mission I still needed
my anomalous Masterpiece and would need
to have an escape plan in place once I
found it during my next stint of time
hidden among the ranks of the foundation
I tried to broaden my own interpretation
of what awcy would consider to be art
nothing in their admittedly vaguely
defined rules stated my anomalous art
piece couldn't be created from a more
modern medium never mind paintings that
can depict a person's death or a
sculpture that moves whenever unobserved
what about something like photography I
thought to myself however it was around
this time that my hopes for such a piece
were seemingly answered in the form of
scp-105 or Iris Thompson as she
introduced herself Iris had a rather
unique relationship with the Art of
Photography she possessed an ability to
alter images taken on a specific
Polaroid Express camera from 1982. in
the hands of scp-105 the photographs
would come to life like slices of
real-time Frozen one moment then moving
the second she held them she could even
alter these images reaching into the
Polaroid to move or retrieve objects it
instilled an idea in me perhaps taking a
Polaroid of My Chosen anomalous art
would be enough that is until I realized
the photographs were only in
interactable to Iris and breaking her
out of containment was a waste of my
skills as an artist part way into my
third month hiding out in site 19 part
of me began to wonder if the
foundation's security forces were as
formidable as I'd been led to believe it
seemed I barely even needed to hide my
mission to join awcy but that I had
spent so much time in their facility
undetected it was on my 68th day that I
decided to reflect on some of the
potential anomalous pieces I had
encountered so far frustratingly so I
was still yet to discover any that would
wipe the smug rins off of the awcy
members only to replace them with looks
of awe something in sight 19 would
guarantee my spot among the anomalous
Art Collective I was certain of it I
just had to find it a potential
candidate presented itself one that
might have even allowed me to get back
at awcy for denying my entry for so long
I was shown as CP 3037 a miniature model
that protected the city of dubranovic in
Croatia I was watching it and pondering
the meaning behind the sculpture
thinking about why it was made to
specifically look like dubranovic of all
places maybe I pondered it was meant to
be a commentary or condemnation of
urbanization given the city's walls
keeping its residents contained confined
much like how we as humans have become
trapped by our Urban settings finding
comfort in being confined there however
it was while I was examining scp-3037
that I apparently suffered something of
an incident from the moment I touched it
I spoke in only Servo Croatian believing
myself to actually be the city of
dubranovic I awoke a short while later
and was informed by another researcher
that I had been administered with an
extremely high dose of amnestics to
negate the effects of scp-30337 although
later that night I recalled having a
dream about some delicious black risotto
with Squid Ink sauce the research heads
ordered security officers to gather
everywhere the mess hall the foundation
was seemingly aware that they had an
imposter a charlatan in their midst
pretending to be a member of personnel I
made sure my facial expression did not
betray that I was the one they sought
not one of these Philistines could
appreciate my goal of infiltrating site
19. not one had the slightest clue how
revolutionary my actions would be for
the art World however although staying
Vigilant I became increasingly aware
time might not be on my side much longer
after overhearing a conversation about
something known as scp-035 I began
conducting my own secretive Research
into what it was I discovered
information on the so-called possessive
Mass within the foundation's archives
immediately my heart skipped a beat the
porcelain mass that shifted from an
exaggerated comedic grin to a wide frown
it would have made for a perfect art
piece to present to awcy much to my
annoyance
scp-035 was announced at site 19 however
over the next few days I petitioned to
have the possessive mask transferred to
the facilities so that I could claim it
my greatest anomalous art piece stayed
Out Of Reach though I was informed by
senior research staff that the mass
posed a potential danger anyone nearby
was compelled to wear it and would thus
be taken over by its influence
additionally questions started to be
raised as to why I was requesting this
transfer in the first place I was
starting to grow concern that my cover
had been blown by now it very much
seemed that my time was running out and
although it shames me to admit it to say
I handled that notion with Grace and
professionality well that would be a lie
suddenly I found it the perfect
anomalous art piece while rummaging
around the foundation's files I located
one about something known as
scp-1379 as I read more I realized it
would secure my spot within awcy and
forever grant me the recognition I
deserved even better it was a painting
such a classical art medium they'd never
be able to refuse me as I looked at it
directly for the first time I knew I had
found my masterpiece
scp-1379 depicted a clown and two
children on the canvas but the subject
of the painting would hardly matter to
AWC why they only cared that the artwork
was anomalous and
scp-1379 certainly was this painting
would allow me to exact revenge on the
awcy members who'd failed to recognize
my autistic genius for so long anyone
that made a critical remark on
scp-1379 which those awcy snobs were
bound to do when they saw it would first
experience intense pain after 20 minutes
of shot severe Agony the sensations
would subside but that would only be the
start of it everyone at the awcy that
dared to criticize my magnum opus my
scp-1379 would rapidly lose their
ability to imagine any of their
creativity that allowed them to load
their artistic superiority over me would
cease exist none of them would ever make
anomalous art again and they'd surely be
forced to finally accept that I am in
fact the greatest artist of all time
from the moment I sought I began to plan
my escape with
scp-1379 in tow a hundred days have
passed since I arrived here and when I
leave it will be with scp-1379 and this
journal I've not only chronicled how I
infiltrated the SCP Foundation but also
cataloged more about anomalous art than
anyone at awcy ever has once I've lifted
that painting from its containment
Locker my old friends at the Insurgency
have arranged for me to be extracted
from site 19 with
scp-1479 finally I'll achieve my dream
of this journal belonging to one stappa
Stearns has been seized by the SCP
Foundation Stearns was discovered to
have infiltrated site 19 after only a
handful of days however given that he
posed little threat and never left the
facility secure security officers were
instructed to monitor him closely until
he attempted to escape aware of
intelligence reports regarding various
scps noted within his journal the
foundation Dean status Stearns a
security risk after 100 days subject was
arrested attempting to escape and is to
be administered amnestics his journal
will remain at site 19 until further
notice ask anyone that has been through
it and they'll all tell you the same but
moving home is maybe one of the most
stressful things that a normal person
can ever experience it's a logistical
nightmare right from the start the
moment you talk to a realtor about being
interested in selling your current house
and buying another everything goes
downhill from there after that moment an
avalanche of things comes hurtling
towards you finding a place you like
making an offer letting people look
around your house waiting for them to
make a counteroffer exchanging contracts
and that's before you even have thought
about packing and as Milo had learned
doing all of that on your own only makes
this stress of moving feel all the more
potent but he had finally made it after
a constant back and forth with his
realtor the time had come for him to
pack up all of his worldly possessions
and relocate to a brand new place to
call home he had felt it was long
overdue for him to get a change of
scenery and luckily just the right place
had come onto the market to answer that
call it was a pretty big house bigger
than Milo's previous home but
considerably cheaper in fact he thought
it had been significantly undervalued
the house had an almost Victorian era
feel to it all beautifully carved and
varnished Woodwork and creaky old
floorboards but in more of an elegant
refined sort of way rather than a
creepier one that's not to say Milo's
new place wasn't without its more
unsettling elements aside from being big
spacious and easy to imagine as being
haunted the creepiest thing about the
house aside from its frighteningly low
price was the story of what happened to
to the previous owners obviously you
know that legally we have to disclose
whether or not anyone died on this
property the realtor had explained
wearing a forced grin as she showed Milo
around the house hearing that sentence
he could feel the hairs on the back of
his neck stand up someone died here he
asked in disbelief no no no no of course
not sir the realtor instantly walked
back her statement Less in an effort to
ease her clients nerves but more to
ensure that she still closed the deal
and earned her commission bonus then why
the hell would you start a sentence like
that Milo asked we just have to give
full disclosure but I assure you the
previous residents didn't die on the
grounds of this house she gave that fake
smile again it was pretty ineffectual at
reassuring him so what happened to the
last owner well it's a bit of a mystery
to be honest a local Legend if you like
but hey that gives the place more flavor
hearing some spooky history right think
of what a conversation starter that will
be the realtor ended her sentence with a
forced snorting laugh but reigned it
back in when she realized Milo wasn't
laughing with her ah as far as I know
there used to be an older couple living
here the Jaws they were apparently very
quiet reclusive kept to themselves a lot
I'm sure you know the type Milo couldn't
help but notice she shot him a look as
she said that part as if she was
silently passing judgment on the fact he
was planning on moving in alone but they
used to spend a lot of time tending the
garden out front so their neighbors
would see them pretty frequently which
meant they were all okay and no one had
any bad mishaps in the house you know
how old folks can be such a worry when
they get to that age yeah totally Milo
interjected to where the realtor was
stalling he repeated so what actually
happened to them well that's the thing
she Shrugged Nobody Knows the full story
one day the neighbors across the street
noticed they hadn't seen Mr and Mrs Shaw
for quite a while so naturally they came
on over here to see if they were in and
the last thing they wanted was to assume
everything was hunky-dory here I mean
hey better save than sorry right but
once they got inside they couldn't find
either of them Mr and Mrs Shaw were just
gone vanished Without a Trace most
people on the street thought they had
just sold the place kept it quiet and
moved away retired to somewhere nice and
exotic Oh well that sounds nice I
suppose Milo replied relieved to hear
that there hadn't been any brutal
unsolved murders in the house and that
it most likely wasn't haunted that's
just what the neighbors think anyway the
realtor continued of course they hadn't
sold the house they just left it when my
firm came in to repossess the place it
had all their belongings in it some
might even still be laying around here
anyway did you want to have a look at
that contract well strictly speaking
Milo was the only human living in his
new house he was never fully alone he
had arrived with his two closest friends
a pair of pets he had adopted while
living in his old house one was a
hamster by the name of donut named after
his round little body and the golden
brown shade of his fur had reminded Milo
of the glazed sugary baked treat the
other was Pixel a bearded dragon with a
pattern on his scales that resembled
some kind of mosaic art the first order
of business Milo had decided was before
even unpacking he needed to make sure
his scaly and furry friends each had a
suitable place to stay and that he got
them fed little did he realize there was
something else living in the house with
them something that was Far bigger and
was getting much hungrier than either of
his pets would looking around the house
Milo stumbled across a few boxes that he
hadn't brought with him like the realtor
had said the Shah still had some of
their possessions left lying around the
place most of it was useless to Milo old
man's clothes are a set of knitting
needles and rolls of colorful thread it
was those particular clues that seemed
to imply Mrs Shaw had a lot of free time
on her hands and maybe took up knitting
as a hobby during retirement of of
course the bigger clue was the huge
handmade blanket that Milo found draped
over some of the remaining boxes in the
Attic he wasn't exactly well versed in
knitwear but he could appreciate the
craft behind this soft blanket it
clearly had a lot of time and effort put
into making it painstakingly knitting
each and every individual thread looping
it around a pair of Steel needles and
eventually after hours of wearing out
shaking bony fingers produce something
that actually looked quite nice even
though the idea of sitting and knitting
a blanket might have been one of the
most boring uses of time Milo could
imagine he still had to admit he was
surprised that the Shaws had left this
particular piece of bedding behind it
seemed like it would be pretty comfy to
sleep under it might help keep a person
warm at night now that the colder
seasons were approaching what's more was
that the blanket was clean almost like
it had been freshly washed there was no
old person smell on it no dirt or
discoloration not a stain and it hadn't
even accumulated any dust in its fibers
in fact he noticed that there was hardly
any dust at all up in the attic despite
the house being empty for so long he
assumed the Realtors had hired someone
As a caretaker while they found a buyer
for the place and they had kept the
place clean after all what other
conclusion could they have possibly
drawn it's not as if something had eaten
all the dust that would be absurd he'd
have a sort through of the Shaw's
leftovers later maybe sell some of it
off at a local yard sale or give it to a
thrift store but that blanket might come
in handy when it started snowing so Milo
had half a mind to keep it now part of
what makes moving home such a stressful
life experience isn't just all the
logistical and administrative parts of
the process it's only made worse by the
fact that it takes forever to move into
a new house fully that's the part
everyone always forgets about the months
after a move when you're forced to live
amongst towers of cardboard boxes all
your worldly possessions buried deep
within in them and you can never
remember which crate anything is in when
you urgently need it so realizing it
would take him much longer to unpack all
of his things Milo set about making sure
he had everything that donut and pixel
would need already to hand the latter of
his two Pets the bearded dragon usually
spent most of his days in a spacious
glass tank Milo didn't love the idea of
keeping either of his two best buds so
confined but pixel never went very far
anyway content to lay under a heat lamp
almost perfectly still for most of the
day donut on the other hand was much
more of a free spirit the tiny brown
hamster physically could not stay still
and most days seem to be filled with
more energy than Milo was as a result he
let the little guy roll about inside a
little plastic ball all day long until
his little hamster feet gave out and now
donut had much more space to zip around
inside his ball so while he entertained
himself Milo could focus on what needed
fixing cleaning and generally improving
a around the house it didn't take him
long to realize however that the
Realtors had pulled a bit of a fast one
on him despite the absolute steal of a
price that Milo had been offered it
quickly became clear that the unknown
fate of the previous residents wasn't
the only detail about the house that had
been conveniently kept hidden the place
was in dire need of repair with a lot of
the old woodwork rapidly rotting away if
left unchecked parts of the house could
collapse and come apart at the seams to
make matters worse the boiler was an
ancient iron monstrosity that was barely
able to produce warm water which would
quickly become an even bigger problem
when the weather started to get colder
then to top off the trifecta of
unforeseen issues and teething problems
with his new place Milo couldn't sleep
it was to be expected after all the
house was old worn out and had
definitely seen better days there were
bound to be a few noises the odd Creak
coming from upstairs when Milo and his
two pets were all downstairs the tapping
of branches against Windows blowing in
the wind outside but for some reason
every audible disturbance that emanated
from some hidden corner of the building
only seemed to get a thousand times
louder when the sun went down at night
time every squeaky floorboard or random
noise of the house settling was nearly
deafening enough to pull Milo right out
of what little Restless sleep he was
getting the worst part about it was
though he couldn't help it it made him
feel unwelcome as if Mr and Mrs Shaw
were angered that he had moved in in the
dark it was hard not to picture every
sound as one or both of the old couple
creeping through the corridors coming to
reclaim their home and remove Milo from
the premises one night the noises
started invading what little sleep Milo
did manage to get spilling into his
dream and causing them to devolve into
unsettling nightmares there was an old
photograph in a frame that he had come
across in the personal effects left
behind by the Shahs showing the pair of
them staring disapprovingly out of the
image at him now thanks to the creek
taking wooden structure of the house and
the sounds it made at night Milo is
seeing the old couple in every bad dream
he had both their faces were locked in
those same still frozen expressions of
contempt as they tried to exercise him
like an interloper on their property
that was the final nail in the coffin
that made Milo realize he needed to look
at other options surely there had to be
some way to induce a deep enough sleep
so that the sounds the house was making
weren't keeping him up or incepting
nightmares anymore he called the local
doctor arranging a consultation for
later that day as he hung up the phone
something nudged against his foot it was
donut having rolled through the Maze of
cardboard boxes still filling the house
Milo took one look at the little brown
furred hamster than the crates that
still littered the place grabbing the
leftover items that the Shahs had
forgotten to take with them before they
vanished Milo moved those boxes out into
the shed he knew he was probably
reaching that it was hard likely to make
even the slightest difference to his
sleeping but maybe keeping their stuff
away from him would keep the old couple
out of his head the only thing he kept
in the house was the blanket there was
no use letting it go to waste especially
knowing that the boiler was on the blink
and it would be cold soon he rolled it
up and left it on his bed leaving his
more mobile pet in the same room before
heading out to see the doctor when Milo
got back a bottle of prescription
sleeping pills in his pocket he couldn't
help but notice his room seemed
different the blanket looked like it had
fallen off the bed and onto the floor
for one but more worryingly Donuts
plastic travel ball had been split open
laying in pieces on the ground with its
furry little occupant nowhere to be seen
over the next few hours Milo searched
every corner of the house calling out to
his hamster trying to lure it back with
more morsels of food but donut didn't
seem to be anywhere he wasn't even
underneath the knitted blanket still
there was no sign as worry set in Milo
Hurley checked pixels cage to see if he
was gone too but the lizard was relaxing
as lethargic as ever completely unfazed
by what was going on it certainly seemed
that when it rained it really poured in
this new house just as he was searching
for his missing hamster Milo heard a new
horrible sound echo through the
corridors this one wasn't so much a
scary noise even if it did make him jump
but it was more the inconvenience that
came with it finally giving out after
God knows how many years it had been
installed for the house is boiler burst
spending the afternoon into the evening
failing to track down one of his Missing
Pets and stopping the huge iron cast
boiler from flooding the basement wasn't
exactly what Milo had in mind for fun
activities to do when he got home going
to bed frustrated made it as hard to
sleep as all the nightly cacophony of
creaking floorboards and branches raking
against the windows he tapped out two of
the pills the doctor had prescribed him
knocking them back with a sharp motion
of his head and a a swig of cold water
before laying back in bed as night had
fallen the temperature also had
plummeted too not having a boiler to
heat his room meant that Milo couldn't
stop himself from shivering in the cold
his breath forming clouds in front of
his face he reached for the knitted
blanket and threw it over himself
curling up underneath it to try and
provide an extra layer of warmth to
protect himself from the gnawing cold
the pills did as they were meant to
helping Milo to quickly sleep into a
much deeper sleep than he had
experienced in a while although it
didn't seem to help the nightmares Mr
and Mrs Shaw came back again this time
they had Milo's arms and legs tied up
with their matching disapproving faces
the elderly couple threw something over
their helpless victim and tried to
smother him to death for a dream it felt
so intense so real Milo could feel a
heavy weight on top of his body as he
slept in fact it felt like it was all
around him engulfing and crushing the
life out of him from all sides but it
was the feeling of something wet against
his arm the sensation of liquid against
his skin and the numbness where his
hands should be were what finally pulled
him out of the dream and into the
nightmare through the dark and his
cloudy vision Milo could see a wide
gaping moth filled with teeth the
feeling of being crushed was still
surrounding him and despite kicking his
legs and trying to free himself from
confinement it didn't stop squeezing him
tighter his Panic was already making it
harder to catch his breath but now he
could barely fill his lungs enough to
scream for help not that anyone was
around to hear him but it was the side
of his arm that chilled Milo's blood it
wasn't there anymore part of it just
above the elbow was just gone his hand
fingers every internal bone and muscle
had been reduced to a bloody mess a
slurry of red melting and coming apart
it was runny little more than a liquid
resembling the consistency of sand when
it's under water and becomes sludge most
of his flesh was liquefied going for
further up his arm and as the blanket
pulled its prey into its mouth until
Milo was no more not a trace of him left
just like the previous owners little did
Milo or the Shaws and donut before him
know but he'd been the victim of a
creature that was part of a rather
unique species while they will often
vary in size shape pattern and other
aspects of their appearance
scp-799 always seemed to be ordinary
items of knitted bedware at least at
first they retain heat like a normal
blanket would and are soft to the touch
and for the most part don't seem
directly harmful and usually they aren't
scp-799s are incapable of much movement
instead laying still a lot of time not
unlike a certain bearded dragon that
just lost its owner they also don't seem
to require much in the way of food
extracting with little nutrition they do
need by drawing in household dust a lot
of the organic matter and dust is
comprised of dead and discarded human
hair and skin cells so this makes sense
this feeding is all done through
filtered mouths in the fibers however
this changes if an scp-799 blanket is
forced to go on a long time without food
well they possess this biological trait
themselves
scp-799 don't seem to regard
cold-blooded animals to be the source of
food in fact they don't even seem to be
able to detect other creatures with cold
blood such as reptiles instead scp-799
will metamorphose into a more predatory
form in order to consume any
warm-blooded mammal or human being it
encounters transforming its feeding
orifices and digestive tract into a
singular mouth lined with several rolls
of sharp pointed teeth from there it
will wrap up the largest warm-blooded
animal it can find whether that be a
hamster or a grown man and will tear off
parts of its prey reducing them to
little more than a thin slurry as it
digests their body mass to feed itself
so if you move into a new house and come
across an old knitted blanket maybe
consider throwing it out if you want to
live now go and check out scp-3032 and
then it was an angry spider for more
warnings about everyday objects that can
seem harmless at first but will quickly
turn deadly when you least expect it and
after that if you're in the market for a
piece of anomalous Furniture that's
still soft and cozy like the blanket but
nowhere near as dangerous then
scp-3832 surprise pillow fight might be
just what you need